hi everyone
welcome to this video tutorial on python
data analysis project for 2022. in this
video we'll be covering two interesting
hands-on projects using python
programming you will learn how to use
real-world data to perform data analysis
and data visualization the two projects
are based on coronavirus and olympics
data you will learn to collect analyze
clean manipulate and visualize data with
the help of python libraries such as
numpy pandas matplotlib and cbon these
two projects will give you the idea to
solve real-world problems using
exploratory data analysis so let's get
started with our first project
today we are going to perform two
hands-on projects on covet data analysis
using python and tableau this is going
to be a really interesting and fun
session where i'll be asking you a few
generic quiz questions related to
coronavirus please make sure to answer
them in the comment section of the video
we'll be happy to hear from you covet or
coronavirus is an ongoing global
pandemic of coronavirus disease that
emerged in 2019 and was first identified
in wuhan china
it is defined as an illness caused by a
novel coronavirus called severe acute
respiratory syndrome coronavirus 2
commonly known as sars cove 2.
on march 11 2020 the who declared coven
19 a global health emergency the virus
has so far infected over 22 crore people
and killed more than 4.5 million
innocents
in india there have been over 3.3 crore
confirmed cases and nearly 4 lakh 41 000
deaths have been reported so far
this data is according to official
figures released by the union ministry
of health and family welfare
as the world tries to cope up with this
deadly virus we request all our viewers
and their family members to follow all
the necessary precautions to avoid
getting infected
quiz time
now let's see our first quiz in this
project
what does corona in corona virus mean
here are the options is it a beer
b respiratory is it c crown or is it d
sun
this is a very general question i am
sure a lot of you may already know some
of you may not
please let us know your answers in the
comments section of the video we'll be
glad to hear from you
now in this video we will use
three different kuvin19 datasets and
perform data analysis using python and
tableau
the project will give you hands-on
experience working on real-world data
sets and how you can use the different
python libraries to analyze and
visualize data and draw conclusions
you will learn how to create different
plots in tableau and then make a
dashboard from the visuals
the project will give you an idea about
the impact of coronavirus globally in
terms of confirmed cases deaths reported
the number of recoveries as well as
active cases
we will also see how india has been
affected since the pandemic started and
dive into the different states and union
territories to learn more about the
covenant 19 influence and the
vaccination status
first let me show you the two data sets
that we'll be using
so for our first project using python
we'll be using the first two data sets
kovid 19 india and covet vaccine state
wise
let me open the two data sets
okay
so this is the first data set you can
see here we have
the date
we have the time
then we have the different state names
but scroll down you can see we have
kerala tamil nadu delhi haryana
rajasthan
sladhak punjab
telangana and other states
then we have something called as
confirmed indian national so actually
this
two data sets confirmed indian national
and confirmed foreign national we won't
be using so in the demo itself we'll be
dropping these two columns
what we are concerned about are the last
three columns
the
cured cases or the recoveries
the number of deaths reported and then
we have the total number of confirmed
cases
let me just
sort the b column that is the date
column so that you have an idea
about the recent data we have
i'll continue with the current selection
and
sort it you can see here
this is
till
11th of august 2021
so this data was collected from kegel it
has some discrepancies that we will see
in the demo the data is available for
free
we will provide the link to the data
sets in the description of the video so
please go ahead and download them
the visualizations and results that you
will see in the demo are based on the
datasets that we'll be using we haven't
pre-processed the data to remove
outliers or any missing values
now before i jump into the demo let me
show you the second data set that we are
going to use
okay so coveted vaccine statewise is my
second data set let me open it
there you go
so
this is the second data set that we'll
be using in the python
project you can see we have a column
called updated on then we have the
state again you can see here there are a
few discrepancies here
uh
it has taken the country name and not
the state name below you can see there
are the
different state names
and you can also see we have information
about the total doses administered
we have the sessions sites
first dose administered then we have the
second dose
then we have information about male and
female doses
you can see here the different
vaccines
administered covaxian and cova shield
you have sputnik v
and here are the different age groups as
well
and finally if you see we have
male individuals vaccinated the total
number of female individuals vaccinated
for a particular day
we have information about transgender
individuals vaccinated and finally we
have the total individuals vaccinated
each day
all right before we jump into the
hands-on part let's have a look at the
second quiz in this project
so
here is the second quiz question which
is the first country to start covid
vaccination for toddlers
is it a japan b israel c portugal or is
it d cuba
this is a very recent development that
took place if you watch daily news
updates on coronavirus you will be
definitely able to answer the question
please give it a try and put your
answers in the comments section of the
video it is really important for our
viewers to know the right answer
all right
so now let's begin with our demo
so i am on my jupyter notebook
so the first project we are going to use
python jupyter notebook
i'll just
rename this notebook as
kovid data analysis
project
and click on rename
all right
so first and foremost
we need to import all the necessary
libraries that we are going to use so
first i am importing pandas as pd this
is for
data manipulation
then we have numpy as np
numpy is used for numerical computation
then we are importing
matplotlib c bond and plotly
these three libraries will be used for
plotting our data and creating
interesting visualizations finally i'm
also importing
my date time
function
all right
so i'll hit shift enter to run the first
cell
now it's time
to load our first data set
which is related to
the kovid19 cases in india for the
different states and union territories
so i'll create a variable called covered
underscore df df is for data frame
i'll use my pandas library
and then
give the read underscore csv function
since our data sets are
csv files
and inside
double quotes i'll pass in the
location where my
data sets are present
so i'll just copy this location
i'll paste it here
we'll change
the backslash to forward slash
and after that i'm going to give my
file name followed by the extension of
the file
i'll say covaid 19
india dot csv
let's go ahead and run it
all right
now
to see the first few
rows
of the data frame i'm going to use the
head function
i'll say head and within
brackets let's say i
pass in 10 which means i want to see the
first 10 rows of data
if i run it there you go
here you can see from 0
till 9 so we have 10 rows of information
and these are the different
column names you have s number
date time state or union territory then
you have confirmed indian national
confirmed foreign national
cured cases debts reported and the
confirmed cases
all right
now moving ahead
let's use the
info function to get some idea about
a data set
if i run it you can see here
it gives us the
total number of columns we have nine
columns the total number of entries or
the rows we have eighteen thousand
hundred and ten rows of information
starting from zero till
eighteen thousand one hundred and
you see here the different types of
variables or column names that we have
then it has information about the memory
usage as well
and this side you can see
the data types
cool
now we'll use another very important
function which is
to get
some idea about statistical analysis the
basic statistics about your data set for
that i will be using the describe
function
okay
so if you can see here
the describe function is for
numerical columns only
and you have the measures such as count
the mean standard deviation
maximum minimum the
25th percentile 50th percentile and the
75th percentile value
okay now let's move ahead and import the
second data set
which is related to
vaccination
so i'll create a variable called vaccine
underscore df
i'll write pd dot
read underscore csv function which is
present in pandas
library i'll move to the top and i'll
copy the
file location
and we'll change the name of the file
copy this and
let me paste it here
and instead of kovid underscore 19
underscore india
i'm going to say govet
underscore
vaccine
underscore
statewide
okay
so this is the data set that we saw
covered underscore vaccine underscore
statewise
all right let me run it
cool
and
let's display the first
seven rows of information from this data
frame
i'll be using the head function and
inside the function i'll pass in 7
there you go so here you can see we have
from 0 till 6
there are total
24 columns
a lot of them have null values you can
see here
all right
now
from the first data set which is the
covered underscore df data frame we'll
be dropping a few
unnecessary
columns such as the time column
confirmed indian national and confirmed
foreign national as well as the s number
we don't need these columns so it's
better to learn how to drop the columns
for our analysis
so i'll say
kovid underscore df
dot
i'll use the
drop function
and within square brackets i'll pass in
the
column names the first is s number
i'll give a comma
within double quotes i'll say the next
column is time my third column that i
want to drop is
confirmed
indian national
give another comma
within double quotes i'll say
confirmed
foreign national
outside the
square brackets i'll give another comma
and pass in my next
argument
that is in place equal to i'll say true
i'll give another comma and say
axis
equal to 1.
let's run it
okay it has thrown an error let's debug
the error
says confirmed indian okay it should be
indian national and not indian nation
i'll just
mention it as national will run it again
okay
now we have
removed these four columns
let me show you the data set now
there you go
so we have only the date column state or
union territory cured deaths and
confirmed
now
let's see how you can change the format
of the
date column for that you have the
function called to datetime
i'll say
coved underscore df
i'll pass in my column name that is date
i'll say equal to
pd dot
i'll use the pandas function that is 2
underscore
date time
i'll say covered underscore df which is
my data frame name
pass in my
variable which is date
give a comma
and i'll use my argument that is format
equal to
i'll say percentage y
give a dash say percentage
m
give another dash and say percentage d
let's run it
and i'll print
the head of the data frame
cool
now moving ahead
now we will see how to
find the total number of active cases
so active case is nothing but the total
number of confirmed cases minus the sum
of
cure cases plus that's reported
so let's
find the active cases i'll give a
comment
okay
i'll first write my
data frame name that is covered
underscore df
within square brackets i'll give my new
column which is active underscore
cases
i'll say equal to
kuvit underscore df
and my first column would be
the confirmed cases column
minus
i'll say
kovate underscore df
then i'll pass in my cured column
plus
i'll again say
kovid
underscore df
and
add my
deaths column
this time let's print
the last
five rows from the new
data frame that we have created
okay
let's run it
it has thrown an error let's debug it
says
data frame object has no attribute tails
this should be
teal
there you go
you can see here we have added a new
column called active cases which is
the confirmed cases minus the sum of
cured and
deaths reported column
now we will learn how to create a pivot
table using the pandas
library
so in this table we'll be summing all
the
confirmed deaths and
cured
cases
for each of the states and union
territories
so we'll be using the pivot underscore
table function for this
i'll create a variable called statewise
and say pd dot
i'll use the pivot underscore table
function
i'll pass in my
data frame that is kovid underscore df
and then
i'll give my
values parameter
inside the square brackets i'll pass in
my
columns
confirmed
deaths
and then we'll have the
cure column
give a comma
and next argument would be index
which is going to be my state
slash
the union territory column
let me bring this to the next line so it
is more readable
i'll say union territory
i will
give a comma now
and pass in my last argument which is
agg
function that means aggregate function
and
this function would be max
all right
let's run it
okay
now
i'm going to find out the
recovery rate
so recovery rate is basically
the total number of qr cases divided by
the total number of confirmed cases in
200
so i'll say
statewide
and within
square brackets i'll
pass in my
variable that i want to create which is
recovery rate
this will be equal to
[Music]
the
cured cases
multiplied by 100
by the total number of
confirmed cases
within square brackets i'll give my
column as confirmed
let's run this
okay
i'll just copy this column
paste it here so this time we are going
to find out the mortality rate
so mortality rate is nothing but the
total number of deaths divided by the
total number of confirmed cases into 100
so i am just going to
replace the names here i'll say
mortality
all right
and then instead of cured i'll say
my deaths column
in 200 divided by the confirmed cases
let's run it
okay
now
we are going to
sort the values
based on the confirmed cases column
and we'll sort it in descending order so
let me show you how to do it i'll say
statewide equal to
i'll use the function short underscore
values
so
i'll pass in my variable statewise dot
and use the
short underscore
values function i'll say by
i want to sort it by my confirmed
cases column
give a comma and i'll say
ascending
equal to
false
let's run it
now we are going to plot our pivot table
using a nice
visual so for that i'm going to use
my
background underscore gradient function
and inside that function we'll pass in
our cmap parameter
i'll show you how to do it
style
dot
background
underscore
gradient
and inside this will pass in a
parameter called cmap
so c map stands for color maps this is
present inside the matplotlib library so
here you can see there is a nice
documentation on choosing color maps in
matplotlib
this is provided by matplotlib.org
if i scroll down you can see there are
a number of c maps that you can use
purples blues
you have something called reds
there are other things like magma you
have summer autumn spring winter
cool
all these
you can use whichever color map that you
want and here you can see the different
shades
or the gradients
okay
so i'm going to use
my color map as cube helix
let me run it and show you the
pivot table
there you go
here you can see we have our pivot table
ready
now as i said in the beginning there are
a few
discrepancies in the data set so here
you can see
there's one called maharashtra and
there's also maharashtra triple star
this you can ignore even if i scroll
down you have madhya pradesh followed by
three asterisks you can ignore this
value as well even for bihar we have
so these have been duplicated
and
here you can see the different
state names and union directories then
on the top you have the confirmed cases
cured cases
the debts reported and the new
columns that we created
these are calculated columns recovery
rate and mortality rate
and we have ordered it in
descending order of confirmed cases so
so far
our data says that maharashtra has the
highest number of cases followed by
kerala karnataka tamil nadu andhra
pradesh and uttar prades so these are
the top
five states which have the highest
number of
confirmed cases
even if you see the mortality rate is
also high for maharashtra
and
if i scroll down
the mortality rate is also high for
uttarakhand if you see here
if i scroll further
your punjab the mortality rate is also
high
all right
this was our first
visual that we created in the
kowi data analysis project
now moving ahead
we'll see the
top 10 states based on the number of
active cases
so we'll start
i'll give a comment top 10
active
cases
states okay
so
we are going to explore another very
important pandas function in this which
is known as
group by
so i'll first
pass in my data frame which is kovid
underscore df
dot followed by the group by function
i am going to group my data based on
state slash
union territory column
then i'll say
dot
max which is to find the
maximum value from the states
that have
the highest
active cases so i have passed in my
active cases column
and
we're also
going to group it
based on the date column
after that
we're going to sort the values so i'll
use my function that is sort
underscore values
i'll say
short by
my column that is
active cases
let me bring this to the next line
underscore
cases
give a comma and say
ascending equal to
false
say dot
and then
reset my index
for that i'll use reset underscore index
function
okay
let's check if everything is fine
i have
missed a square bracket here let me give
another square bracket here
okay and all this we are going to store
in our
variable called top underscore 10
underscore
active
underscore cases
okay
now let me go ahead and
run this cell
okay there is
a syntax error here
now let's run it okay
now i'll create another variable called
fig
here we'll pass in
the plt which is for matplotlib
library and will give the
figure size
using the
fig size
argument
it's equal to and within a tuple and
passing the size let's say 16 comma 9.
we'll run it
okay
and
let's give
a title to our plot so here we are going
to create a
bar plot
so
using plt.title we'll pass in the
title let's say top 10 states
with
most
active cases in india
i'll give a comma and pass in the size
of my title let's say 25
okay you can see we are slowly
being able to
create our graph
the most important thing is to pass in
the
x x-axis and the y-axis
i'll say ax which is for axis
to pass in the axis i'm going to use the
bar plot function that is present inside
the c-bond library
i'll say sns.bar plot
i'll say data equal to
my
variable which is top underscore 10
underscore
states
this is actually active states
all right
and now
i'm going to use the
i lock
function
and
take the first 10 states so i'm using a
colon and then giving 10 as my value
iloc is for index location
i'll give a comma and say my
y-axis to be
active cases
give another comma and say my x-axis to
be
state
slash
union territory
give another comma
we are going to pass in the line width
to 2
i'll say line width equal to 2
and will give
an edge color
let's say the edge color is
red
okay
so i have my
access defined now
let's run it
there's an error here it says stopped in
active states not found
let's go to the stop and see the exact
okay so this is
top 10 active cases let me change it to
cases here
now run it
okay the x axis also has a mistake this
should be
state slash union territory
now let me run it
there you go we have our
plot
created but as you can see here the
labels of the
different states and union territories
are overlapping so for that
let me first pass in the
x labels i'll say plt.x
label
and my
x label would be states
then i'll say plt dot
by label
my y label will have the total
active cases
and finally i'll write plt dot show
before i run it let's collate all the
lines of code that we have written for
our
top 10 states for most active cases in
india into one cell
so what i'll do is i'll just copy this
and we'll keep
adding
in this cell itself
okay
i'll go to the top
next we'll copy
my figure size
and we'll
paste it here
next let's take the
title
and put it here
give us peace
and we are going to copy
the cell
and i'll paste it here
all right
now it's time to run it
there you go
you see it here
we have a nice
bar plot ready on the top you can see
the title top 10 states with most active
cases
and you see the edges are in red color
for all the bars
on the x-axis you have the different
state names maharashtra karnataka kerala
you also have andhra pradesh gujarat
west bengal and chatham
so as you can see
maharashtra
has the
highest number of active cases based on
our data followed by karnataka caroline
tamilnadu at second third and fourth
place respectively and
the ninth place we have west bengal in
the tenth place we have chattisgarh
on the y-axis you can see the total
active cases
which are
in lags
okay now moving ahead now we'll see the
top 10 states based on the total number
of
deaths reported
so i'll give a comment
top states
with
highest
debts
okay
so i'll first
create my variable
saying top 10 underscore
deaths
this will be very similar to
what we did here
just that we need to change a few
column names so instead of active cases
we'll be using depths
okay
so i'll start with my
data frame that is covered underscore df
followed by using the
group by function and i want to group my
data
based on
the state slash
union territory column
then i'll choose the max function
and within
double square brackets i'll pass in
my column names deaths and date
let's make it consistent i'll be using
single quotes
okay
i'll say dot
i'm gonna
short my
result therefore i'm using the sort
underscore values function
i want to sort it by
deaths column
i'll give another comma and say
ascending equal to false which means i
want to
order my result in
descending order
then i'll say dot reset underscore index
okay
after that i'll give my
figure size i'll say plt dot
figure
and within
brackets i'll pass in my argument which
is
fig size
equal to
using a tuple i'll say 18 comma let's
say 5
now let's give a title for that i'll use
the title function which is present in
the matplotlib library
i'll say
top 10 states with
most
deaths
and let's give a size to the title 25
now it's time for us to give the access
labels i'll just scroll down
okay
so i'll say ax equal to
again this will be a bar plot so i am
using my cbon library followed by the
bar plot function
my data will be top
underscore 10 underscore depths
which is this variable
i'll give
my index location iloc
i'm going to choose
12 states the reason being
there are some discrepancies in the data
i'll show you once i plot this result
so in the y axis we'll have
deaths column
in the x-axis we'll take
state
slash
union territory
okay
i'll give another comma
and say
line width
equal to 2
and will give
an edge color to our
bars like we did here
so i'll say edge color
equal to let's say
black
okay
now
finally
we'll give
the x label the y label
so i'll say plt dot x label
x label would be states
my y label
will be
total
death cases
then i'll write plt dot show
now let's run it
there you go
you can see here we have a nice bar plot
on the top we have the title top 10
states with most deaths
now
what i specifically wanted you to
see was these discrepancies in the data
you can see here maharashtra is repeated
twice even
in our data that we collected from kegel
karnataka
spelling has an error you can see here
we have a few
rows of information where karnataka is
spelled as
k-a-r-a-a-n instead of k-a-r-n-a
all right so to
remove
these
two results or to ignore these two
results i had given
my index location till 12 so we have
maharashtra karnataka tamil nadu
delhi danuta pradesh west bengal kerala
punjab anthropis
with the states that have the
most number of debts reported
okay
now we'll create a line plot to see
the
growth or the trend of active cases for
top five states with most number of
confirmed cases so the states are
maharashtra karnataka kerala tamil nadu
and uttar pradesh i can show you
so these are the states with
highest number of active cases
okay
i'll just give a comment saying
growth
trend
all right
so for that
we'll start with our
figure size as
plt.figure
i'll use my parameter fixed size equal
to
12 comma 6
i'll say
my axis
as sns dot
this time we are going to create a line
plot
my data would be
the original data frame that is kovid
underscore df
and
within square brackets i'll say covered
underscore df
and we are going to pass in the
state or the union
territory column
i'll give
a dot and use the
isin function
so the
states should include
maharashtra
will give a comma the next state should
be
karnataka
next
we have
kerala
give another comma
my fourth state is tamil nadu
give a comma
and my fifth state would be
uttar pradesh
all right
so i'll give
a comma here and then say
x equal to
the date column
y
will be
active cases column
and i'm going to use another parameter
called hue
which is to
give different colors to the different
states the five states that we are
looking for
so hue
will be my
state slash
union territory column
okay
after this
i'll say
ax dot
set
title
my title will be top 5
affected states
in india
we'll give a size let's say
16
all right okay this should be size equal
to 16
and
to make sure everything is fine let me
just
move it to the above line
okay
now we'll run it
okay there is some error again
it says
invalid syntax let's see where we went
wrong
let me bring this to the above line
okay this should be covered underscore
df
okay
make sure you
keep these small errors in check
let's try and run it again
all right
if i scroll down
there you go here you can see we have
the top five affected states in india
you see the
different
states here and the colors so
this violet or the purple color is for
maharashtra you can see
how the
active cases
surged around
april and may
and then you can see
even for karnataka the active cases
surged very rapidly
around may
and june
then it has decreased luckily
similarly you can see the plots for even
uttar pradesh
as well as for tamil nadu so all the
five states you can see one common trend
that
after
march so around april
the cases started to emerge very rapidly
and
later after july they started dipping
okay
now
we are going to use our second data set
which is related to vaccination
all right
so first and foremost let me go ahead
and
print the data frame for you
so that you know
the data that we are going to use so
this is the data we are going to use
for our next
set of analysis
even this data has a few errors and you
can see there are a lot of missing
values it makes sense because not all
the days you would have
vaccination
for people
and
very crucial
error that we are going to deal with is
this
state column here you can see
in the state column we have india in a
few rows so we are going to ignore these
rows
all right
first let's rename
our updated on column to just
vaccine date
so
you can use the
rename function present in the pandas
library to do it so i'll say vaccine
underscore df dot
rename
i'll say columns equal to
within
curly braces
i'll write
updated
on
which is my
original column name
give a colon i want to change this to
vaccine underscore date
i'll give a comma
and say in place equal to true
so it will change
my
column name from updated on to vaccine
underscore date
in the
original data frame
let's run it now
let me go ahead and print
the first
10 rows
in the data set
you can see here we have successfully
changed
the column name to vaccine underscore
date the rest of the columns remain the
same
all right
now you can
check
the
total number of
columns
rows
the data types
and the memory usage using the
info function
here you can see it
we have total 24 columns
7845 entries
and these are the
columns that are present
and if i scroll further
you see here
sees
the memory usage and here on the right
you can see the
data type
cool
now as you saw
the data has a lot of missing values
let's find the sum of all the missing
values for each column
so i'll say vaccine underscore df dot is
null
and then i'm going to use the sum
function over it
fire on it
there you go so almost
all the columns have
missing values but columns such as
male individuals vaccinated female
individuals vaccinated even for columns
like
the age groups there are a lot of
missing values
now in the next step we are going to
drop a few
missing value columns
so i'll say
a new variable called vaccination
i'll give the data frame name vaccine
underscore df and use the drop function
and inside the drop function we are
going to write
columns equal to
i'll pass in the
column names that i want to drop
i'll say
doses
administered
so this is the column that i want to
delete sputnik v doses administered
i'll give a comma
the second column is e e
f i
the next column is
18 to 44
years
within bracket
it has doses
admin stored
give a comma
i'll say 45 to
60
years
doses
administered
to another comma
the final column that we are going to
drop is
60 plus which is this one 60 plus years
deuces
administered
okay
so these are the columns that we want to
drop
and finally i'll give my parameter
access equal to 1
okay let me just
recheck these
column names first one is sputnik v
doses administer then we have
efi
followed by
18 to 44 years doses administered then
we have 45 to 60 years doses
administered
finally we have 60 plus years
i have added
a s here which was missing and there
should be a space as well
because there's a space here in the
column now let's run it
all right
so we have successfully dropped
the columns that we wanted to drop
now i'll say vaccination dot head
you can see here
we have dropped those columns and we are
left with these columns now
okay
now we are going to
create a
plot
that is a pi plot to see
the vaccination for male and
female individuals so i'll give a
comment
as male versus
female vaccination
to create this pie plot i am going to
use the plotly library that we had
imported which is this one plotly
okay
so first of all we need to filter out
the
male individuals
from our data frame
i'll say male equal to
vaccination
meal
and passing in the column
individuals
vaccinated
we need to recheck the variable name
whether it is correct or not
you see here male
individuals vaccinated
then i'll say
dot
sum
similarly will filter out the female
individuals
i'll say female equal to
vaccination
which is my new data frame
within square brackets i'll pass in the
column name female
individual
vaccinated
i'll say dot sum
okay
okay these should be individuals as per
the
column name present in the data frame
cool
now i am going to say px
dot pi function which is present in the
plotly library
i am going to
give the names of the
pies
so first one is meal
and the second one is
female
give a comma and say
values
equal to
male comma
female
then i'll give a comma and pass in my
title which is
male and
female vaccination
okay
this should be names
all right now let's go ahead and run
this cell
so will take some time to create the
pie chart here we go
see here i have my title male and female
vaccination
so these are the two
pies or the areas
you have the label female and the value
here you have the label meal and the
value
so from our data you can see 53 percent
male
individuals have been vaccinated
compared to 47 percent for female
okay
now we are going to drop all those rows
where
our state was mentioned as india in the
original data set
i had shown this to you in the beginning
so we are going to remove
rows
where
state is india
okay
so to do that i'll say
vaccine i'm creating another variable
called vaccine
and
we'll use our original data frame that
we had imported
is vaccine underscore df
i'll say
vaccine underscore
df dot
state
not equal to
india
now let's
print vaccine
okay you can see here we have our
data frame printed and from this data
frame we are taking only those values
or the rows where state is not equal to
india
cool
now what we are going to do is
we will rename the last column which is
total individuals vaccinated to
just total
so i'll say vaccine dot
rename
we'll use the parameter columns equal to
within
curly braces i'll say
total
individuals
vaccinated
give a colon and we'll change this to
just total
give a comma and say in place equal to
true
and finally i'll print my
head of the new data frame
this should be columns equal to
okay
now you can see here if i scroll to the
right and if i check
we have successfully renamed our column
all
right now moving on to the last two
visualizations that we'll see in this
first project using python that is to
find the states with most number of
vaccinated individuals and the state
with the least number of vaccinated
individuals
okay
just give a comment
most
vaccinated
state
okay
for this i'll first create a variable
called wax underscore
vac which is for maximum vaccination
i'm going to use my
data frame vaccine
followed by the group by function
i want to grip it by state column
and
we'll find the total sum
of vaccinated individuals
for each state
i'll convert this to frame
there should be a dot
to underscore frame
and i'll pass in my column name which is
total
after that
i'll say max underscore vac
equal
to
max underscore vac dot
short
underscore values
i'm going to sort it by
my total column
and say ascending equal to false which
means i want to sort it in descending
order
so that we have the
states with the
highest number of
individuals vaccinated
i want the top five states
now
let's go ahead and
print it
so this will create a nice table for us
there you go
here you can see
we have maharashtra uttar pradesh
rajasthan gujarat in west bengal as the
top five states with most number of
vaccinated individuals
now we are going to use this table and
convert it into a
chart
now i had already written my
code for the
bar plot i'm just going to paste it
so here i have defined my
figure size as 10 comma 5
then i'm giving a title as top 5
vaccinated states in india and the size
is 20 after that i've created a variable
called x
which is going to store my bar plot
this bar plot we have created using the
c bond library
and
you see here i have my
y axis defined
then
i have the line width and the edge color
as well i have given my x label as
states by label as vaccination and i'm
finally
going to display my plot so let's go
ahead and run it
okay you can see it here
we have converted this
table into a bar plot now
so first we have maharashtra with the
highest
number of vaccination
then we have uttar pradesh rajasthan
gujarat and west bengal
now i want
the viewers
watching this video to
find the states with least number of
vaccinated individuals and convert that
table into a
bar plot that will show the
bottom five vaccinated states in india
which means the states which have
least number of individuals vaccinated
so please go ahead and put your
codes in the comment section of the
video it will be very similar to these
two cells just that now we want to know
the least five vaccinated states in
india
so please put the code snippets in the
comments section of this video we'll be
more than happy to know from you in case
you are not able to do it will
definitely give the answers in the
comments itself
all right
so this brings us to the end of the
first project on covet data analysis
using python
so
in this project we used two data sets
one was on
the coveted 19
india data set for different states and
union territories and the second data
set that we used was for
analyzing the status of vaccination in
the different states in india
now we'll move on to our second project
okay so before moving on to our tableau
project let's see the final quiz
which of the following is not a common
coronavirus symptom
so this question is to make you aware of
the correct covet symptoms
here are the options
is it a fever
b
vision loss c loss of taste and smell or
is it d curve
please put your answers in the comments
section of the video and let us know
what you think
now we'll move on to our second covet
data analysis project for this project
we'll be using
the tableau software and a global
coronavirus dataset first we look at the
data set and the fields we have
okay so i am in my data set folder
we have already seen the first two data
sets in our
python project
this time we are going to use the global
covet data let me open it
all right so here you can see
we have the different country names
there are
192 countries in our data set
let me go to the top
so
we have
country or region
we also have the code
for each of the countries
then we have column called last updated
so here you can see our data is still
12th of march
2021
and there are two columns which
don't have any information that is
people hospitalized and people
tested then we have a column called
active cases then we have a column for
confirmed cases
in the different
countries we have the number of deaths
and then we have the incident rate
the latitude and the longitude for the
countries
then we have the mortality rate
this is in fractions
then we have the number of
recovered cases and finally we have a
column called uid
so we'll be mostly using the country
column
active
confirmed deaths
and the recovered cases column
and we'll be using the tableau software
to create interesting visualizations and
we'll convert those visuals and put it
in the form of a dashboard
towards the end of the project
okay so let me
close this file or let it be open
i'll search for tableau public
you can see here i have
tableau public installed
you can use the
desktop version of tableau or the public
version of tableau
so for this project we are going to use
the tableau
public edition
so here you can see i have
created a few visuals already
if you want you can clear them out
okay
now the first thing we need to do is to
connect our csv data set to tableau for
that
under connect
we have to a file
i'm going to use
text file
and under
chrome downloads i'll search for my
folder
covered
india
and here i have my
global covet data file let me open
it this will take some time to load
that you can see
so on the tableau you can see the view
here
it shows the country or the region
you have the last update
you have columns like active confirmed
deaths
mortality rate and recovered
and here you can see the
symbols for the
different columns so this is
a globe which means this field
is a
region or a
geographic field
abc means it's a text field then we have
the calendar which is for a date field
abcr
text field and this
hash represents
numeric fields
all right
so now that we have loaded our data
let me just click on sheet1
so this is the canvas where we are going
to
create our different
reports
all right
so on the left you can see there are two
panes the data pane and the
analytics pane
in the data pane you can see the
name of the data set global covet data
and here you can see the
different
columns that we have in the data set so
on the top
the ones marked in
blue are called as dimensions
and at the bottom whatever you see
are marked in green and are called as
measures so
dimensions are always represented with
blue icons and measures are in green
icons
so
tableau has automatically detected the
different
data types for each of the
columns all right
so
first of all we are going to create a
simple table
to see the total number of confirmed
cases for each of the
countries
so for that i'm going to drag my country
or the region column on to
rows here you have rows i'll just drag
it and drop it here
there you go it has populated all my
country names starting from afghanistan
till
jimbah way so it has ordered in
ascending order of alphabets
now to
see the total confirmed cases for each
country i am going to drag my confirmed
column on to text so here under marks
card you have
the text option i'll just drag it
and drop it here
there you go
so tableau how easily has
shown me a table where you can see the
different country names and on the right
you have the total number of cases that
have emerged
from these countries
now this is not the most recent data as
i told you this data was till march 2021
cool
now you can go ahead and
short the
table based on the
total confirmed cases here on the top
you can see here
there are two options to sort in
ascending order or in descending order
let's first sort in
ascending order
by sum of confirmed cases within country
and region
there you go so here you can see
these are the countries which have very
few cases
and if i scroll down
you have france uk russia brazil india
and u.s with the highest number of kovit
19 cases
if you want you can also
short it in
descending order so that the countries
with the highest number of confirmed
cases appear at the top
you can see it here
and these are the countries that have
very few covet cases
now you can convert this
simple table
into different charts and graphs
to do that
here on the
right top corner you have an option
called show me
now
i can just click on
this horizontal bar graph
so that will automatically convert my
table into a bar graph
again you can go ahead and
short the data
there you go so here you have u.s india
brazil russia uk france spain and italy
this is a horizontal bar graph
sorted in
descending order of confirmed cases
now suppose you want to display only the
top few countries with the highest
number of confirmed cases for that you
can select these bars
so i'll select till let's say
germany
or let's say to argentina
okay and i'll click on keep only you can
see it here it says 12 items selected
that is the sum of confirmed cases i'll
just click on keep only
there you go so
this horizontal bar graph has
information only for these
few countries that have the highest
number of confirmed cases
now you can go ahead and
play with the
color formatting
so here under colors let me choose
a green color
okay
now you can mark here since we selected
only the top 12 countries with the
highest number of confirmed cases so
what we did was we just filtered it to
the top 12 countries so tableau has
automatically added country region in
the
filters card
now if you want you can go ahead and
edit this filter as well
suppose you want to remove argentina you
can just uncheck this click on apply and
okay you see here argentina has been
removed i click on
undo so ctrl z to get it back cool
now you can convert this
horizontal bar plot into a vertical bar
plot let me show you how to do it i'll
just remove these
fields from my
chart
now what i'm going to do is i'll
drag country or region onto columns
and i'll have
confirmed
column under rows
there you go here you can see we have
a vertical bar plot now
and again you can
use the axis now to short your data this
is in
descending order similarly you can sort
it in ascending order here you have the
option to
sort your data
okay
cool
and below you can see the
different country names
all right now you can go ahead and
give
a name to this sheet
let's say
top 10
confirmed
countries
to supply
and click on ok you have the title to
this plot similarly you can change it
here as well
top 10
confirmed
countries
okay
now let's move on to our second
visualization where we will create a
global map so this global map will show
the
different countries
present
in the map and the cases that they have
so to create the map first i'll drag my
longitude
generated
field onto columns and then i'll drag
latitude on to rows
you see here we have the map ready and
now
i'll drag
country region onto detail
so this will give you
the different country names you can see
here we have canada
the united states
mexico
here you have india
sri lanka
there's australia
this is brazil
and similarly we have spain france
belgium
there's
italy here we have also greece
similarly we have the african countries
like
central african republic this congo
angola
and on the top you have russia and this
is iceland so on and so forth
now
i'm going to drag
the
active cases column onto
detail again
now if i hover the cursor you can see
the
active numbers for brazil you can see
for india
you have
countries like china
here you have thailand
algeria
now
i'm going to
drag the confirmed cases column on to
label
so that you have the labels here you can
see here the confirmed labels
cool
now if you only want to focus on a few
countries
present in a particular region you can
highlight that region for example
suppose
for europe you want to focus on this
region if you select it it will
highlight only those countries and if
you hover your mouse over these points
it will show you the active cases and
the total number of confirmed cases
all right now if you want you can go
ahead and change the color of the
circles let's see i'll keep it as
red
okay
so this is how you can create a
map to represent the different active
and
confirmed cases
i'll rename the title to
global
cases
i'll just click on apply and okay
similarly i'll change the sheet name as
well to
global cases
okay
now from this map you can see the
countries such as usa
brazil
you have russia
and india with the
highest number of kovit 19 cases even in
countries such as
spain the numbers are
really high
and
a lot of the african countries were also
impacted
and these small countries like solomon
islands you have
fizzy islands
with few number of cases even for new
zealand as well
all right
now
moving to our next
visual
now we are going to see the top 10
countries where highest debts have been
reported so far due to the pandemic for
this we will create a tree map now
so first of all i'll
choose my country column and
put it under
columns
and then i'll select
the depths column and put it under rows
i have the
bar plot ready
next i'll go to show me and here i have
the option to select a tree map
you see here for a tree map you need one
or more dimensions and one or two
measures so i'll just click on this tree
map
okay here you can see i have my tree map
ready so tableau has automatically
adjusted my fields so it has removed my
fields from rows and columns and put it
under
size color and
label
next i will drag my
country column and put it under filters
and from here
i'm going to choose top
i'll filter by field i'm going to select
the top 10
countries
based on the total number of
deaths just click on apply and click on
ok
so
these are the countries us brazil mexico
india united kingdom italy russia spain
france germany
which have the highest number of deaths
reported
now
you can also
give the label
i'll
put the deaths column under label so
that you have the labels here
all right so this was a tree map that we
created to show the
top 10 countries with the
highest
number of deaths
i'll just
change the title top 10
death's
cases
now you can also edit the title in terms
of the font color and everything
so i'll keep it tableau bold
and i'll choose this as 14 click on
apply and ok
there you go
similarly let's
rename the sheet to
death cases
cool
now moving
to the next visualization where we'll
see
about the recoveries
so before we move on to
create a visualization for the
top 10 or let's say the bottom 10
countries in terms of recoveries let me
show you how to change the
color of the stream app
so here
by default tableau select the automatic
palette
if you want you can change it to
different
palettes let's see i'll go with
gold purple diverging
click on apply and i'll click on ok
this is not looking
that great you can select another one
let's see
red green white diverging
cool
now let's
go to our
fourth visualization which is about
top 10
recoveries
i'll click on apply and ok
first i'll drag my country or the region
column
under
columns
and then i'll take
the recovered column under rows
this time
instead of
sum
we are going to choose
average
okay
and here
i'll select
my packed
bubble chart
after that i am going to drag my country
or region onto colors
and then i'll also
put country under filters
so i'll go to
the top
menu
and i'll filter it by field
i want to show the top 10 countries
based on the average number of
recoveries
so click on apply and ok
you can see here
these are the countries that have
the highest number of
average recoveries you have india brazil
turkey italy argentina germany colombia
russia poland and mexico
i'll just rename this sheet to
recovery cases
cool
now let's move on to our next visual
okay
so here we are going to create a scatter
plot to analyze the total confirmed
cases versus the total number of deaths
so whenever you have two numeric fields
it is better to create a scatter plot to
visualize the
cases
so for that i am going to
drag my confirmed
cases to columns and then i'll drag
my
depths column onto rows
okay
so by default
the shape is a circle
and
to see all the countries i am going to
drag country under color
i'll say add all members
there you go
here
you can see the legend for the different
countries
and
the top you have
us with the highest number of confirmed
cases and the highest number of
deaths as per our data set then you also
have brazil here which has the
second highest number of deaths
then you have
mexico
followed by india
so this data is not a very recent data
this data was last updated on
march
now from this we are going to filter out
the top 10 countries with the highest
number of
confirmed cases
and the deaths
so for that i'll drag my country column
onto filters
and i'll go to top
filter by field
i'll say top 10
and i'll click on
apply and okay
so here you can see we have siberia
sweden
belgium
netherlands
spain
italy france
russia
uk and
you have brazil
so these are the countries which have
the
highest number of
active cases
so instead of active let's select deaths
click on apply and okay
okay
now if you see we have us here
brazil
india
then mexico
uk
russia france
italy germany and spain which have the
highest number of
deaths reported so far
now if you want you can
change
the
size of the circles based on the
highest number of active cases so i can
just drag my active column under size
so you can see here
spain france
uk have the highest number of active
cases
now let's say instead of active i'll
just have
my confirmed cases under size
okay
and then
you can also change the shape from
circle to
any other shape let's say square or this
asterix
okay
let's go with the triangle
cool
i'll rename this sheet to
confirmed versus
deaths
click on apply and ok
i'll rename this to
confirmed
versus
deaths all right
now moving on to our
next visualization where we will see
the mortality
for each of the countries
and figure out which countries have the
highest
mortality rate
okay
so
first i'll drag
mortality rate
onto
column
and then i'll have
my
country column under rows
so there you go
now let me go ahead and
sort it in
descending order so you can see here you
have yemen
there is mexico syria sudan egypt
equator china and other countries which
have the highest mortality rate
and you can also
select the country region under colors
let's go ahead and edit the
color
instead of automatic let's select summer
or
you can go for some other palette let's
say
tableau
classic medium i'll assign this palette
yes i'll apply and okay
all right
finally
we'll
move ahead to our
last visualization where we'll create a
dual access chart
so the dual access chart in tableau will
have one column and two different
visualizations on the rows so here you
have
one column and on the right also you'll
have one column with their own access
values
so this dual axis chart will be for
recovered cases and the
death cases let me show you how to do it
so i will drag
my country
field onto
columns
and then
i'll choose
recovered column onto
rows
so here i have got my
line chart
and the second
column i'm going to choose is the depths
column
i'll hold my
cursor and i'll place it
when i get this
green color rectangle i'll place it here
there you go
so now we have created two measure names
deaths and
recovered
and here you have the access values you
can synchronize the access values if you
want
the recovered cases are in millions and
the debts are in thousands
now let's go ahead and
change
the
recovered line to
bars
and
we're going to short it
okay
now let's change the color
select let's say
blue
i'll assign the palette click on apply
and okay
and if you want you can also change the
color
for
deaths from blue to let's say
winter i'll assign the palette click on
apply and okay
you can have whichever color you want
and to make the access seam you can just
right click on this axis and click on
synchronize access
so here you can see the values
let's keep it in thousands only
cool
i'll rename this sheet to
dual access
okay
now before we move ahead and create our
final dashboard i want to show you
one more
feature in tableau that is to format the
labels so you can see here
instead of writing 5 lakh 30 821 we can
change this in terms of millions or
thousands and write it as let's say 530k
to do that
what i'll do is i'll go to format and
here we have the option
to select
font
and in font i'll go to fields and
click on sum of deaths
and here
in this pane
i'll choose
number custom
decimal places will be zero
and
display units i'll select
thousands
you can see here the values have been
changed to 531k 193k 158k
so on and so forth
cool
now let's go ahead and create our final
dashboard here is the option to create a
new dashboard so i'll just click on
new dashboard
and we are going to increase the size
here so that
it fits our
view
so we have selected the default view and
the size i am going to
choose here is automatic so now we can
drop our sheets one by one
first let's drag the
global cases
sheet here
okay you can see we have our map
now
i'm going to choose the top 10 confirmed
cases
all right
and after that we'll choose the
death cases sheet so tableau will prompt
you to place the sheet
at the right location
okay
and now i'll choose my
fifth visual which is confirmed versus
deaths
and if you want you can choose any one
of
these let's say i'll take the dual axis
chart
now you can just
minimize the
sheets and adjust the
sizes to
make it look better
okay
so you can see here we have our
dashboard ready now you can still
go ahead and customize the dashboards in
terms of adding different filters to it
we are not going to
show that now you are getting some
messages here two are known for nulls
you
can
remove them as well
and here on the top you have the option
to
click on the presentation mode
there you go so this is our final
dashboard that we have created
all right so this brings us to the end
of the
second
coronavirus data analysis project using
tableau
now you can just click on escape to go
back
all right now you can save this
and
this will be published in the
tableau public platform under your
profile
so that brings us to the end of this
video tutorial on kovi data analysis
project using python and tableau welcome
to this exciting video on olympics data
set analysis using python by simply loan
this is going to be a very interesting
and interactive session where i'll give
you a brief about the history of
olympics and throw some light into the
recently held tokyo olympics
but we'll focus more on using olympics
data set that is available on kegel and
perform some exploratory data analysis
you will understand how to use different
functions in python to analyze and
extract meaningful information
during the course of our discussion i'll
be asking you a few general questions
related to the olympics try to answer
them in the comments section of the
video
so let's begin
the olympics is one of the biggest
sporting events on the planet
it is held every four years
the first modern olympics took place in
athens greece in 1896.
as per national geographic
the original olympics took place in 776
bc
so they began as part of an ancient
greek festival which celebrated jews the
greek god of sky and weather
the rings in the olympics logo represent
the five continents europe africa asia
the americas and oceania
from 1924 to 1992 the winter and the
summer olympics took place in the same
year but now the alternate every two
years
before i move on here is an interesting
question for you
only two people have ever won gold
medals at both the summer and the winter
olympics
who are those two people
please share your answers in the
comments section of the video we would
like to know from you
the summer olympics in tokyo began on
the 23rd of july and recently concluded
on the 8th of august
we got to witness some thriller matches
that went down to the wire some amazing
victories and sadly there were a lot of
heartbreaks as well
winning and losing are part and parcel
of any game
fans across the world were really happy
to see this global event happen this
year following last year's postponement
due to the coronavirus pandemic
with our olympic fever high let's take
this opportunity to work around a
project to perform exploratory data
analysis using python to analyze and
visualize past olympics data and answer
specific questions
in this video we will be using specific
python libraries such as numpy pandas
matplotlib and cbond to make sense of
our data and extract meaningful
information
we are going to visualize our results
with different charts and graphs
before i show you the data set that we
are going to use for our analysis
i have another general question for you
which is the first olympics where all
the participating countries sent female
athletes a repeat which is the first
olympics where all the participating
countries sent female athletes
put the year and the city name where the
olympics was held in the comments
section of the video we'll be more than
happy to hear from you
now
let me go ahead and show you the data
sets that we'll be using in this video
so here you can see i have my
olympics data set folder that has two
datasets these are csv files one is
called the athlete underscore events and
the other one is called noc underscore
regions
so
we'll be using these two data sets these
data sets can be downloaded from kegel
we will post the dataset links in the
description of the video please go ahead
and download them these datasets have
been directly taken from the internet
now i'll show you the data sets
so this is my first data set you can see
on the top athlete underscore events so
i have
around
15 columns you can see the count here
and there are
nearly
2 lakhs 71 116 rows of information
so this is a huge data set that we are
going to use
the other data set we are going
to use in this demo is called noc
underscore regions now here one thing to
note is
noc stands for national olympic
committee this is a three letter code
that is given by the olympic committee
we have the region name so afg is for
afghanistan you have alb for albania elg
for algeria we have also a column called
notes you find some
notes about the
region for example here antiqua is
actually antiqua and
barbuda
all right
let's move to the
first data set that i showed you
this is our primary data set for our
demo
so these data sets have been directly
taken from the internet and were not
validated so the results that you will
see in the demo is purely based on the
data that we have collected
so the file athlete underscore events
dot csv contains
nearly 2 lakh 71 116 rows of information
and there are 15 columns
so each row corresponds to an individual
athlete competing in an individual
olympic event
so here id is actually a unique number
for each athlete then we have the name
which is basically the athlete's name we
have the sex or the gender which is male
or f for female
then we have the age of the athlete
which is in terms of integers
we have the height in
centimeters of the athletes then we have
the weight in kilograms
we have the team name these are the
country names you have china denmark
netherland there are around 200 country
names
then we have the noc as i said noc
is a three-letter code that stands for
national olympic committee
we have the games this games contains
the year and the season you can see here
1992 summer you also have the winter
olympic information
all right
then we have a specific year column
to
tell you in which year this event had
occurred
now the year column is also an integer
column
we have the season so whether it was
summer olympics or winter olympics
then we have the city name this is the
host city
then we have the sport name you can see
here we have basketball judo football
tug of war
speed skating there are so many
then we have another column called event
which is the complete even name as you
can see the sport name is basketball but
the even name is basketball men's
basketball to be very specific
again for speed skating you have
different categories like women's
thousand meters 500 meters
all right
now the final column is the middle
column so it has
the information about the athlete
whether
the athlete had won a medal be it gold
silver branch and na means the athlete
did not win any medals so we'll use
these two data sets now let's
get started with the demo
we'll be using jupyter notebook for our
analysis so i'll take you to my jupyter
notebook right away
i've opened it on chrome so this is my
jupyter notebook that we are going to
use you can see here olympics data set
analysis
i have already
have a few cells that have been filled
with some piece of code
and you can see there are
some comments written as well we are
going to use this data set
so let's get started first and foremost
we'll import the data sets so we are
going to use
numpy pandas matplotlib and c bond
let me hit shift enter to
import all the
libraries
all right
now the next thing is to load the
datasets
using
pandas read underscore csv function
so
i'll create a variable called athletes
i'll say equal to
pd dot i'll use the read underscore csv
function
and inside this function will give the
location
of the files so i'll copy this location
and here i'll paste
make sure this is within
quotations
and these are all
forward slash
give another forward slash
and after that i'll give the
file name that is
athlete
underscore
evens
dot csv
i'll close the quotation
let's run it
okay
similarly we will
load the second data set i'll create
another variable called regions
so it will have my data frame
i'll use the same function pd.read
underscore csv
i'll just copy this
file path
till here
we paste it
and
i'll give my second file name which is
noc underscore
regions dot csv
you can verify here
the first one is athlete underscore
events the second one is noc underscore
regions
okay i'll close the quotation and we'll
run it
again okay there seems to be some error
i think this is the regions
cool
now moving ahead
let's see the
first few rows of both the data sets
i'll use the head function for that
i'll say
athletes dot head
so this will print the first five rows
from my data set
athletes you can see here
from 0 to 4 you have five rows of
information the id name sex or the
gender
each height weight
if i go to the right you have games
year season sport event and medal
now let's see
the
second data set that we
imported or loaded
i'll say regions dot head
it says regions
is not defined
let me cross check it
okay i have taken it as region let's
make it regions
cool
now let's run it there you go so these
are the first five rows from our second
data set you have noc region and some
nodes
all right
now the next step is to combine
both the data sets so we'll join the
data frames using the pandas merge
function
let me show you how to do it
so this is going to be a horizontal join
i'll create a variable
called athletes underscore df
then
i'll use my first variable which is
athletes
i'll say dot merge which is my function
name
i'm going to merge
the regions data frame
i'll use the how parameter
in how i'll give my value as
i want to do a left join
and my common column in both the data
sets is actually noc
so i'm going to use
the noc column as my common column to
merge both the data sets
now let's go ahead and
print the
most data frame i'll say athletes
underscore df.head
let's run it
there you go
so
if you see clearly if i move to the
right you can see here we have added two
more columns that were present in the
second data set which was regions so we
have regions and nodes
added to my
first data set that is
athletes underscore
events
cool
now one thing to note here is
see the column names are not consistent
if you see here the rest of the columns
start with a capital letter but if you
see the last two columns that we just
added now start with the lowercase
letters so we'll use
the rename function to make the column
names consistent
but before that
let's
see the
shape of the data frame so i'll print
the shape of the data frame to know the
total number of rows and columns
i'll say
athletes if i hit tab
you will see it will give me
the prompt i'll select athletes
underscore df
i'll use the
shape attribute
let's run it
and see the result you can see here it
gives me the total number of rows so 2
lakh
716 rows and earlier we had 15 columns
in the first data set and now that we
have added two more columns so the total
number of columns becomes
17 now
cool
so now it's time to make the
column names consistent
so i'll show you how to do it i'll say
athletes underscore
df
dot i'll use the rename function
and then
i'll say
columns
equal to
i'll use curly braces
my first column
that is region i want to change it to
a region but the r should be capital now
or uppercase
will give a comma
and then say
my second column
this should be a region actually
my second column that is notes
i want to
change the first letter to uppercase so
i'll say capital n
the rest all remains same
i'll give a comma here
and say
in place equal to true
so it will change
the column names and will reflect
in this athlete's underscore df data
frame
let's run it
now to verify you can again use the head
function i'll run this again
let me scroll down and move to the right
you can see the difference there you go
so we have successfully renamed the last
two columns region and notes
all right
now moving ahead
now
i'll show you how you can use the info
method to print information about a data
frame including the index data type the
column data types
normal values and memory usage
so for that you just need to use the
info function so i'll write
athletes underscore df
dot info
let's run it there you go so here we
have the
data columns you can see total
17 columns you have two lags seventy one
thousand hundred and sixteen rows or
entries
then you have the
different column names and
you see it says non null and the data
type of the column
below you can see some information about
the memory usage
all right
next
the describe method is used for
calculating statistical information such
as mean standard deviation the
percentiles of the numerical values of
the data frame and much more
it analyzes both numeric and object
series and also the data frame column
sets of mixed data types
so let me show you how using
the describe function you can display
some statistical
summary
i'll just write
describe
and
give parenthesis let's run it
okay if i scroll down
you can see here
by default
the describe function will only give
information about numerical columns so
here you can see we have the total count
the mean of each of these columns you
have the standard deviation the minimum
and maximum value and then we have the
25th percentile the 50th percentile and
the 75th percentile value of the
column's id age height weight and year
all right
now one thing to notice here is if you
see the year column
the minimum year is 1896
so this is when olympics started
and until recently
the rio olympics that was held in 2016.
all right
now moving ahead
now let's check if there are any null
values present in the columns of the
data set
so first i am going to create
a variable called
nan values
give equal to
i'll see athletes underscore df
and the function to check is i'll say is
an a
i'll create another
variable
called nan underscore
columns
and here i'll use the any function i'll
say nan underscore
this
variable which is underscore values
dot i'll see
any and i'll print
my nan columns variable
so this will display the result in terms
of
boolean values so if there are any null
or nan or missing values in any of the
columns it will say true otherwise it
will say false
let's display the result
there you go
so if you mark here clearly
so there are
nearly six columns where we have missing
values you have
age height wheat metal region and notes
columns that have
missing values so hence
it has given us true the rest of the
columns do not have any any n or missing
values hence they are false
all right
let me scroll down
now let's see the total number of null
values for the
above
six columns
so i'll say
athletes
underscore df
dot
i'll use the function is null
and again i'll use this sum function
okay this should be is null
if i run it
you can see it here
so our age column has
9474
rows where we have null values
then we have
some null values for the height column
as well for the weight column so these
are the total number of
rows where we don't have
any information regarding each height
weight or region
notes this medal is
self-explanatory because a lot of the
athletes who participate in olympics
don't win any medals so for them
the value is any now before i move ahead
i have a question for
you people
so the question is i want you to print
the column names containing null values
or missing values in the form of a list
so
please answer this question and put it
in the comments section of the video
would be happy to
know your approach
so the question i'll repeat it again i
want you people to print the column
names containing null values or missing
values in the form of a list
so basically
on the top we saw there were
six columns that had
null values i want you to print these
six
columns in the form of a list
all right now moving ahead
now let's see the data for specific
countries
let's say you want to see the athletes
who have participated in the olympic
games from the beginning for india
for that you can filter your result
using a function called query
so let me show you how to do it i'll say
athletes
underscore df
dot
will use the query function
and then
i'll say
team
which is my column name
should be equal to equal to
and the value i'll give is india
now let's
display the first five
rows of information
or the details for the athletes who are
from india if i run this
okay there is some error here
okay so we need to make sure this entire
expression or the condition should be
within
single quote i'll just delete this
single quote from here and we'll add it
in the end
now let's
run it there you go so here you can see
we have
the top five rows
of
the athletes who are from india you can
see here the region is india you can see
the noc is india the team is india
and
let me go to the left you can see the
name of the athlete
the sex each
so for each you have some missing values
you have the weight
team year and everything
all right
similarly you can also check for
japan let me just copy the
above code
i'll paste it here
and instead of india i'll say
japan
i'll run it
there you go
so if you see here
you can see all the details are for the
athletes who are from japan
all right
moving ahead now i want to know the top
10 countries who have participated since
the inception of olympics in
1896
so for that i'll create a variable
called top underscore 10 underscore
countries
and say equal to
i'll use my data frame that is
athletes underscore
df
i'll say dot
team
then i'll use the function
value underscore
counts
i'm going to
sort
my count
in ascending order
just mark the way in which i am writing
the functions
any error in terms of syntax or the flow
will
throw you an error
i want to display the top 10 countries
now let's go ahead and
print it i'll say
top underscore 10 underscore countries
all right
let me run it
okay it has given us an error let's
debug it okay so this should be
value
counts and not count
let's run it again
another error
okay
so this should be
short underscore values and not value
let's run it again
there you go
so here you can see the top 10 countries
participating in olympics since
1896 you have united states then we have
france so these are the number of
participants who have taken part
since 1896.
so the most number of participants have
come from us then we have france great
britain italy germany canada japan
sweden
we also have australia and hungary
i'll scroll down
now we are going to convert this table
that we got or the output that we got
in the form of a graph
so i am trying to create a bar plot to
plot wait for a while
i have given a
title to my plot saying overall
participation by country
and then
using the c bond library and the bar
plot function
i am plotting the
x
and the
y axis so my x axis has top
i should make this top 10 countries
because above we used top underscore 10
underscore countries similarly for
y-axis i'll make it top underscore 10
underscore countries and then i'm using
a color palette called set 2.
let's run it
there you go so if i scroll down you can
see here we have a nice
bar plot
this is a vertical bar plot
and here you can see the bars which
represent the different country names
first we have united states which has
the highest participation since the
beginning of the olympics then we have
france great britain italy germany
canada
and we have the rest of the countries
cool
now moving ahead
the next visualization we are going to
see is the age distribution of the
athletes
so for this we are going to create a
histogram
i'll be using the matplotlib library
specifically for this visualization
so i'll say plt dot figure
will give the figure size using the
argument fig size
equal to and this will be a tuple
actually
my size is going to be 12 comma 6
i'll say
plt
dot
title
now you can give
any title that you want i'll say
each
distribution
of the athletes
then we'll also give the x labels i'll
say plt dot
x label
this will have age
then we see plt dot
y label
and this will have
the label as number of
participants
next
i'm going to use the hist function so
i'll say plt.test
and i'll
pass in my data frame that is
athletes
underscore df
dot
age
which is my column name
comma
i'm going to pass in the
bins
for that i am going to use the np dot
e-range function so mp is for numpy
and inside this i'll say
10 comma
80 comma 2.
so my bins will start from the value 10
and go until 80 with a size of 2
comma
i'll give another parameter that is
going to specify the color of the bins i
want my color to be
orange
and then
i'll use
the edge color to separate the bins
lc it
now let's run it and we'll see the
output
so there you go
so this is a nice
histogram that shows the distribution of
the
age of the athletes you can see the
title each distribution of the athletes
on the y-axis you have the number of
participants on the x-axis we have the
age values ranging from
10 to 80 with a size of
2
and if you say this
we have most number of athletes
who have age between
20 to 30 you can see here
so early 20s we have maximum number of
athletes participating in the olympics
we also have a few athletes who are
beyond 40 years of age you can see here
we have a
few athletes
even closer to 60 also
and similarly we have a few athletes who
are
under 18 years of age
all right
now you can see here the bins we had
taken orange color so our all the
bars are represented in orange color
and the edge you can see here we have
the white color
all right
now moving ahead
now in the initial slides of the video
we discussed the summer and winter
olympic games let's look at the
different sporting events that are part
of the summer and winter olympic games
just to give you a heads up the winter
olympic games are held once every four
years for sports practiced on snow and
ice
so here
i have my variable name winter
underscore sports so i'm extracting
for season equal to equal to
winter and i am going to display only
the unique values now let me run this
cell
okay so you can see here these are the
different windows sports that are
held
during the winter olympics now similarly
let's see for
summer olympics so what i'm going to do
here is i'll just copy this
cell of code and we'll edit the
variables i'll say summer
underscore sports
athletes underscore df remains the same
here season will change it to
summer
dot sport dot unique remains the same
and
here i'll say summer underscore sports
that should be small
now let's run it
there you go
so here you can see we have
more number of olympic sports that are
held during the summer olympics compared
to
winter olympics
so these are the sports that are played
on snow and ice
and
these are the sports that are played
during
summer
moving ahead
now it's time to analyze the total
number of male and female participants
who have taken part in different games
since 1896 till 2016 rio olympics
all right
so i'll say
gender
underscore counts which is my variable
name i'll use my
data frame that is
athletes underscore df
dot
my variable name that is sex
dot
value underscore
counts
and then we are going to print
gender underscore counts
let's run this
there you go
so since the inception of olympics
we have more number of male participants
than
female participants
now here in this current cell you
can see we are trying to plot a
pie chart for male and female athletes
so i have given my figure size then i
have my title as gender distribution i
am using the matplotlib library and the
pi function i am using the variable
gender counts that we used here
then i am giving my labels as gender
underscore counts dot index now i am
using this auto pct the auto pct
parameter enables you to display the
percent
value using python string formatting so
this is my string formatting that i have
used
and i'm
initialized my start angle for the pie
chart as 150 degrees and i'm also giving
shadow to my pie chart so i have written
shadow equal to true
let's run it
all right so you can see here this is my
pie chart that shows you the
distribution of the
male and female
participation
so for me it is 72.5 percent for female
so far it is
27.5 as per the dataset that we have
you can change this start angle to let's
say 180 degree
and it will
change the pie chart to this direction
cool
now moving ahead
this time
we are going to find the total number of
medals that the athletes have won
so i'll use my
data frame athletes underscore df dot
and then my column that is
middle i'll say dot
value
underscore
counts
let's run it there you go so you can see
the gold medals the bronze medals and
the silver medals are
very much
similar to each other the numbers are
pretty much the same
all right
now it's time to focus on the total
female athletes who have taken part in
each
olympics
so i'll create a variable
called
female underscore
participants
i'll say equal to and then use my data
frame name that is athletes underscore
df using
square brackets
i'll say
athletes
underscore df
dot
the gender should be equal to equal to
female
and
i'll use ampersand
i'll say
just copy this
paste it here
lc dot
season
equal to equal to we'll check for summer
olympics
and i want to extract only
the gender column so here it is x comma
my year column which is year
okay
and then
i'll say
female
underscore
participants
equal to
i'll just copy this
paste it here
and then i'll use the group by function
say group by which is part of the pandas
library
i'll say year
and then i want to find the count
i'll reset the index
say reset underscore
index
is a function
and finally we are going to print
female underscore participants
and let's see the head
all right
so what we are trying to do is i am
trying to filter
my data only for the female athletes
for summer olympics
and here
i am printing
the participation
based on each year so i am finding out
the count
so here we need to add
one more square bracket
all right
now
we'll
run it and see the result
the yuko
so you can see here from 1900 1904
all these years you can see the female
participation
let me change it to tail so that we have
the recent data of the
olympics
you can see it here for the beijing
olympics 5816
women athletes participated in 2012
london olympics we had
5815 olympics similarly for
the 2016 rio olympics we had
more participation than the london
olympics so
6223 women athletes had participated
all right
now here
this is another way in which you can
filter your
data for female athletes so i'm
using two parameters my gender should be
equal to female and season
is summer olympics let me just run it i
have stored it in a variable called
women olympics
now
here i am trying to
find a count plot or i am trying to
create a count plot using my cbon sns
library
i have set my style to dark grid
then my figure size i have given as
20 comma 10
my count plot will have the x axis
as year
the data is women olympics
and palette i'm using as spectral and
then i have given a title women
participation
let's run and see the output
there you go if i scroll down you can
see on the top i have the title for my
count plot which says
women participation and on the y-axis i
have the count
and at the bottom you can see the
different year values from 1900 till
2016
and 2016 had the highest number of
female participation
cool
let me scroll down so in this cell of
code we are trying to plot a line graph
let me run it and show you the output
so this line graph shows the trend
which says plot for female athletes over
time so here you can see the line graph
so gradually
the women participation has increased in
olympics since
its inception
there was a slight decrease here this is
around
1950s
and again you can see here there's a
decrease with the women participation in
1980 but since then since 1980 there has
been continuous
increase in the participation of female
athlete numbers
cool now coming to the next section
of our analysis
now we are going to filter the data to
see the details of the athletes who have
won gold medals
so
i'll create a variable called gold
medals
it's equal to i'll use my
data frame as
athletes underscore df
and
within parenthesis i'll use my data
frame name
which is
athletes
underscore df
dot
i'll use the condition middle equal to
equal to
and my value would be gold
next
i'm going to
say
gold medals dot all the
records have medal as gold
now we are going to use this
subset
of the data and perform some more
analysis
so here
i want to take only the values that are
different from nan so i'm going to use
is
finite
function and inside that i have said
gold medals age
let me just run it cool
now i want to see
the athletes who have
secured a gold medal beyond the age of
60 years
which is very rare
so we'll see the total number of
athletes with more than 60 years of each
having won a gold medal
so here i'm going to say
gold medals
i'll use my
column as id
and then
i'll use
my variable
gold medals
and then
i'll say
age
should be
greater than
60
and then
close my square bracket and say count
okay let me just verify if everything is
fine
yeah
i'll run it and we'll see the result so
there are total
six athletes who have won a gold medal
having age more than 60 years
cool
now let me check
for which
sport these six gold medals have come
so i'll say
sporting underscore event
this is going to be my variable name
equal to
i'll use the
same variable name gold medals
i'll going to choose
my sport column
and then
i'll give my
condition
age
greater than
60.
now let's go ahead and
we'll print
the variable spotting event
if i run this you can see it here
so
for art competitions
even for archery and suiting and this
one called rook
we have had gold medals from athletes
who had
an age
more than 60 years
now we are going to plot
this result or the table that we
achieved on the top
so i'll say plt dot
figure
i'll give my
figure size
equal to let's say 10 comma 5
then
i'll say plt dot
we'll use the
tight layout
say tight underscore
layout
then i'm going to use the cbon library
and
create a count plot
for my variable
sporting underscore
event
then i'll say plt dot
title
i'll give the title as
gold medals
for
athletes
over
60 years of age
let's run it
and if i scroll down you can see here we
have a nice count plot i have my title
gold medals for athletes over 60 years
and since
for archery we had
three players who secured a gold medal
having an age more than
60 years
you can see here archery is three at
competition one
rock is one and shooting we had
one medal
all right
now
we'll see the total gold medals
from each country
so for that
i'll say
gold
medals
dot
will use the
region column
and
followed by that i'll use the
value underscore
counts function
and
i'll reset the index
with name
equal to i'll provide the
middle column
then we are going to print the
head for the top five
countries let me run it you can see it
here
so
usa
has secured the most number of gold
medals then we have russia germany uk
and then we have italy
cool
now in this cell i am going to create a
plot to
visualize the table that i got
above
so i have used my labels my titles i'm
using the cat plot function that is
present in the c bond library i have my
x-axis my y-axis the data which is total
gold medals
let me just verify
okay and we'll run it
if i scroll down
you can see this is a different palette
that i had used which is a rocket
and you can see
usa has got the
most number of gold medals then we have
russia germany uk
italy and france now we also have
included france here which was not
present in the stable the reason being i
have used head
as six
so it will give me the top six countries
all right
now we will analyze
and look at the data for the most recent
olympic event that is present in our
data set i'm talking about the 2016 rio
summer olympics
so first of all i'll create a variable
called max year
which will be equal to my data frame
name athletes underscore df
my column name here and i'll use the max
function
then
let's go ahead and print my max here
i'll just show you the output you can
see here my max here present in the data
set is 2016 the rio olympics
next
we will
create another variable called team
underscore names
that will be equal to
my
data frame name athletes underscore df
within square brackets i'll give
parenthesis and then say
athletes underscore df
dot
year
should be
equal to equal to
my
output that is max here
which is actually 2016
and then i'll say
amberson
i'll just copy this
paste it here
this time i'll use the
middle column and c equal to equal to
gold
i'll say dot
team
then i'll say team
underscore names dot
value
underscore
counts
dot head
and will display the
top
10
countries
let me run this
there you go
so in geolympics
united states secured the
most number of gold medals
now the reason this is 137 is we have
also counted
the team events for example basketball
similarly great britain had 64 gold
medals in total
russia 50 we have brazil 34 argentina 21
france 20 and japan 17.
all right
now
using the above result we are going to
create a bar plot i'll just change the
steam underscore list to team underscore
names
similarly here also i'll make the
corrections as
team underscore names
cool
now we'll run it
and you can see here we have a nice
horizontal
bar plot so we have united states at the
top
great britain russia germany china
brazil
so here i'm displaying the top
20 nations since i've used head
as 20
so these are the top 20 nations who
secured the
most number of gold medals in the u.
olympics
alright
now in the final section of this video
we will create a scatter plot to
visualize the height and weight of male
and female athletes who have won a medal
now it can be a gold medal a silver
medal or a bronze medal
but before that
we
need to filter the data only for
athletes who have won a medal
now if you
had noticed here our
medals column also had a few
null values so we are not going to
consider
those null values here we are only going
to consider for the athletes who have
verna medal
so for that i will create a
variable called not underscore null
underscore
medals
equal to i'll say
athletes underscore
df
then
i'll give my
let's make it df
i'll give my condition
let me just copy this
i'll paste it here
and then
i'll give my condition
height
and use
the not
null
function
and then i'll say
ampersand
create another parenthesis i'll say
athletes underscore df
this time we'll consider the
weight column
again i'll use the function as not null
and
i'll close the parenthesis
okay i had missed one s here cool
let me just run it now
all right
now we are going to create our final
plot i'll say plt dot figure
i'll give my
figure size
equal to
i'll say 12 comma 10
i'll say
access
equal to
sns dot
we'll be creating a scatter plot to plot
the
height and weight of the athletes who
have won a middle
i'll say scatter plot
in my x-axis i'll have
height
comma
in my y-axis i'll have
weight
comma
my data should be
not underscore null underscore
medals
so this is what we created here not
underscore null underscore medals
comma
i'll use hue equal to my
sex column
cool
finally i'll say plt dot i'll give a
title to my plot
saying
height
versus
weight
of
olympic
medalist
cool
now let's see our scatter plot
this might take some time to
keep the result because there are so
many athletes present in a data set who
have won a middle and also we are
filtering
in terms of
hue which is for male and female
there you go
so if i scroll down you can see here
we have a nice scatter plot
on the top you have the title of the
plot saying height versus wheat of
olympic medalist you can see
our age as the hue
so blue points are for the male athletes
and orange points are for the female
athletes
and on the y-axis we have the weight in
terms of
kilograms and you have the height in
terms of centimeters
cool
so that brings us to the end of this
demo session on
olympics
dataset analysis
so we used two datasets to
[Music]
carry out this exploratory data analysis
and we
created some
visualizations to analyze and visualize
the data
all right
so that brings us to the end of this
video tutorial on olympics data set
analysis indian premier league that is
ipl is one of the most popular and
exciting events in world cricket
ipl 2022 will begin on 26th of march so
it's the best time for us and our
viewers to learn about how to perform
exploratory data analysis using the
recently held ipl auction data set
so in this video all the results and
insights that you will see are totally
based on the data we have collected from
kegel we will leave a link to the data
set in the description of the video you
can go ahead and download it
for this demo we'll be using python and
jupyter notebook to answer special
questions
so let's get started we'll move over to
our jupyter notebook
okay so i'm on my jupyter notebook and
this is the file that we are going to
use so here you can see i have
some of the cells already filled in
so this will save us some time and we
can
explore this data set in depth so this
is the file that i'll be using or the
ipython notebook
cool
so first let's go ahead and import all
the crucial libraries that will be
needed for our analysis so here you can
see i'm importing the pandas library the
numpy library these are for data
manipulation and numerical computation
then we have c bond and matplotlib for
data visualization
then
i have imported this warnings
module
so that we do not get any warnings while
running the code
cool
so let me just hit shift enter to run
the first cell
so here we will import
all the libraries okay it's done
now the next step is i'm going to create
a data frame in the name of ipl
and here i'm importing the data set
using the read underscore csb function
which is part of the pandas library so
pd here has been imported as pandas i am
giving the
data set location followed by the name
of the data set so here the name is ipl
underscore 2022 underscore dataset dot
csv is the extension of the file
so let me go ahead and run this as well
all right so now we have
successfully imported or loaded our data
set
now the next step let's go ahead and
explore our
data set so i'll use the head function
for this
ipl dot head
okay so here you can see the different
columns we have
an unnamed column which is actually
unnecessary for our analysis so we will
see how to drop this column apart from
that we have the name of the players the
base price at which the
player was sold or whether the player
was a draft pick so here rashid khan
from afghanistan hardik pandya then we
have
subman gill these are all
draft pick and then we have the
price at which
the players were listed in the ipl
auction then we have the type of player
whether the player is a bowler an
all-rounder a batsman
or
a wicketkeeper
then we have the cost in rupees this is
in crores so basically this column tells
us the
price at which the player was sold in
the auction
then we have the price or the cost in
dollars
after that we have
2021 squad basically
this means
in last year's ipl where was the player
so here you can see rasith khan was
playing
for srh the sunrises hyderabad in 2021
but this year in 2022 he'll be playing
for gujarat titans similarly hardik
pandya was playing for mumbai indians
for past few seasons including 2021 but
this season is going to play for gujarat
titans
so on and so forth
now
let's see the total number of players
that are present in the data set and the
total columns that are there for this
i'm going to use
the shape attribute so i'll write ipl
dot shape you can see here there are
total 633 players that were part of the
auction and this includes the players
over
draft pick also
and there are total
eight columns in my data frame ipl
next
let's use the info function to check the
columns the data types and the total
non-null objects so i'll say
ipl dot info which is a function so i
have to use
brackets
there you go so here you can see it
saves to till 633 entries from 0 to 632
data columns we have total 8 columns and
then these are the
different
column names and
here you can see the total
non-null objects present in the
column
and here you can see the data types
and at the bottom you can see the
memory usage as well
cool
now
the dot columns attribute will return
the name of the columns in the
data set so if i say ipl dot columns and
run it it will give me
all the different column names that are
present in the data frame
now as i said
the first column which is unnamed
colon 0 is
actually unnecessary so we are going to
drop it for that
we are going to use the
dot drop function and then i have passed
in my
column name followed by the axis on
which axis is it there and then i say in
place equal to true which means it will
replace
and permanently remove
the unnamed column from the data frame
so let's run it and now we'll again
check
the head of the data frame you can see
before we had the
unnamed column which was the first
column in the data frame and now we have
successfully removed it so player
becomes the first column in the data
frame
all right
now moving ahead
let's see the total number of null
values that are present in each column
of the data set so i'll say
ipl dot i'm going to use the is null
function
followed by this sum function
if i run this you can see here
the player column doesn't have any null
values
similarly base price and type column
also don't have any null values but you
can see cost and rupees and
cost in dollars have
nearly 396
missing or null values the reason being
those players were not
picked in the
ipl auction and hence there was no price
associated
and then you can see there were a few
players who were not part of the ipl
squad in 2021
so
those are being reflected as null as
well
now we'll check the
rows that have
cost in dollar as null or nan so here i
have
used ipl and after that i am passing in
the column name which is cost in dollars
and then i have used the is null
function
if i run this
you can
notice the
cost in
dollars column all these values are any
n or
null
and even the same
rows have any n for cost in rupees as
well
cool
now the
next task is to
fill these
null values or any n values with
zeros so for that i'm going to use the
fill any function and here i passed in
zero so all the null values in the data
set will be replaced with zero
for
cost in
rupees column and
cost in dollars column
let me just run it
all right
okay
now
we will see the players who were unsold
in the 2021 auction which means
we will check the rows that have null
values for the 2021 squad column
so what i'll do is i'll say
ipl
within
square brackets i'll say ipl and then
i'll pass in my
column name which is 2021 squad
and then after this i'll say dot
is null
so
this
cell
will give us
the unsold players in the 2021 auction
if i run this
you see here
you mark the 2021 squad column all these
players were unsold or did not
participate so hence it has any n values
all right
now what we are going to do is we will
replace all the null values
that are present in the
2021 score column with
not participated
like how we did in the previous example
we replaced all the null values with 0
here we'll replace with
a text value called not participated so
i'll say ipl
i'll pass in my column name which is
2021 squad equal to
i'll say
ipl
2021
squad
dot
fill
any
which is the function and here i'll pass
in a
text or a string saying not
participated
all right
let's run it
before that let me just scroll it down
now i'll run it cool
now that we have treated the null value
successfully let's verify it again so
i'll just say ipl
dot
is null
and then i'm going to use this sum
function
if i run this
okay this is also a function cool now if
you see we have successfully removed all
the null values and replaced with either
zeros or not participated and hence
now you can see none of the
columns in the ipl data frame have null
value so it shows zero
great
now moving ahead
now we are going to add another column
called
status
which will hold two values sold and
unsold
but before that
we are going to
slice
our data frame so here i am looking for
all the rows where
cost in rupees
is greater than
0
and those should be unique and
i am storing the value
in a variable called teams so here you
can see we have the different teams
where the
cost in rupees is greater than zero
now
i'm going to create
another
column called status so i have written
ipl
within square brackets i am passing in
the column name which is status and
that will be equal to
the team
replaced by
soul value
let me just run it and show you the
result there you go
so here you can see we have added a new
column called status and it has values
sold
and unsold
if i just say ipl
at the bottom you can see
the unsold values as well
cool
now in the next cell
we are going to check for duplicated
players so there are duplicate rows in
the data frame but here the names of the
players are same but in reality the
players are different
so
it is quite understood that different
players can have the same name
so
to get those names i am using the
duplicated function and i'll say keep
equal to false which means i don't want
to keep those players
now let's run it
there you go so here you can see
lalitha we have
two entries so lalithyadev here is an
all-rounder whose base price was 20 lakh
for 2022 ipl
and
last year
he was playing for the delhi capitals
and this year also
he is
sold
to delhi capitals
next we have
lalitha
who happens to be a bowler so this is
again different
so last year
he was unsold and even this year he
remains unsold
similarly we have amit mishra
who earlier used to play with the delhi
capitals but this time he remains unsold
so on and so forth so you can see two
entries for subham shrink as well and
shivam mishra
all right
now
let's answer a very basic question
we are going to find out how many
players
have participated
in the 2022 ipl auction
for that we have already seen
the total number of rows that were
present but again i am going to use the
shape function and within
square brackets i am going to say 0
which means it will give me the total
number of rows
and you can see 633 players were part of
the auction this is as per our data that
we have collected from kegel
up next we are going to find
how many types of players have
participated
so i'm going to say
types equal to
say ipl
i'll use the column name which is type
and i'm going to find the
count of
each type of players that are present in
the data frame
i'm going to use the values underscore
counts function
and then i'll say
type
dot
reset underscore index
if i run it
okay there is an error here let me debug
the error
okay so this should be value underscore
counts and
the variable name is types are not type
so let's run it
you can see here
we have the different
types of players so all rounders there
are total 242 all rounders are part of
the auction then we have 215 bowlers 112
batsmen's and 64 wicket keepers
now using the above
table that we just created
i am going to
plot my first
pie chart
so for that i am going to use the
matplotlib pi function so plt dot pi
i am using
types dot values since i want
only the values from this table
and then
i'm saying labels equal to types dot
index
i've used a label distance of 1.2 to
maintain some space
and then this is my format in which i
want to
print or show or display the percentage
of
distribution i am going to use shadow so
it says shadow equal to true which is
another parameter or an argument and
then i am going to start my angle at 60
degrees
and here i have used a title called rule
of players participated
that will have a font size of 15 and
finally i am saying plt dot plot
so let me just run it
there you go so here we have a nice
pie chart or a pie plot so you can see
the different pies here
we have all rounder wicket keeper
batter and bowler
so majorly
there are all rounders in the auction
followed by bowlers then we have 17.69
percent batters and 10.11 wicketkeepers
which is the lowest
cool
now
we are going to create another bar plot
or a bar graph that will tell us how
many players were sold and unsold
so for this i am going to use a count
plot so we will create two bars one for
sold and the other one for unsold and
each of the bars will have different
colors
one will have orange the other one will
have pink and i'm using
labels so to label the x-axis and y-axis
i have sold or unsold by label will have
number of players the title of my bar
graph would be sold versus unsold i am
given a font size of 15 and i am saying
plt dot plot
now the function that you see here at
the bottom
will display the data labels for each of
the bars
let me just run it and show you the
result there you go
so i have used a figure size of 10 comma
5
all right now you can see we have a
really good
bar plot which says there were total 237
players sold and 396 players were unsold
as per the data we have
cool
now you can also
print
the total sold and unsold values let me
show you how to do it
i'll say ipl
dot we can use the group by function
and i want to group it by
status column
and
the value that i want to measure is
the player's
count
so i'll say players
rather player and then i'm going to use
the
count function if i run this you can see
here
i've successfully grouped the unsold and
sold players the values are matching
with
the bar plot that we just created so
sold where 237 players are unsold are
396.
cool
now
we are going to see the total number of
players bought by each team again this
is going to be a count plot so basically
a bar plot
so here the condition i'm passing is
in the teams column the value shouldn't
be unsold
so
players bought means the value should be
sold so here i am using this condition
and the rest of the things remains the
same
one improvement
i have done here is i am using x6
rotation equal to 70 degrees this
basically means the x labels would be
tilted by 70 degrees
now let's see
the bar plot there you go so here you
can see i have the title players bought
by each team on the y-axis we have the
number of players
and on the x-axis you can see the values
have been tilted by
70 degrees let me just zoom in so that
you can see better
and this is the bar plot
so the maximum a team can purchase is 25
players some of the teams have also
purchased 24 22 and 23 players let me
just
show you so
gujarat titans have totally purchased 22
players
then
delhi capitals have total 24 players in
their squad
again
lucknow super giants have 22 players if
i scroll and see again
bangalore loyal challengers or rcb
they're all challenges bangalore have
22 players in the team
and rajasthan royals and sunrises
hyderabad have
24 and 23 players respectively in the
teams
all right
now
we will create three more columns
called
retention
base price
and base price unit
for that
first of all i am creating a new column
called retention which is equal to
ipl base price let me just run it
and then
i'm going to replace
these values that are present in the
list 2 crore 40 lakh 20 lakh 1 crore 30
lakh 1.5 crore
with
from auction
and i'm saying in place equal to true
let me just run it
then we are going to
treat the base price
so here
in the base price
column i'm going to replace
draft pick value as 0 so let's run that
as well
and now
i'm going to split
the base price
value into two separate values called
breeze price unit and base price so
basically i'm splitting
on this piece
that i have let me show you how it is
going to split
so this is let's see our
base price column
what i did was i
replaced the draft pick values to zero
and then the rest of the values will be
split into two columns called base price
unit so basically it will have the
unit
of the base price let's say crores or
lacks
and
the base underscore price column will
have the value which is 2 here 40
20 20 so on and so forth
let me just scroll down
and run that particular cell
now to create
these two columns the base price unit
column and the base underscore price
column i have used the lambda function
and i'm splitting based on the space
let's just run it
now i have replaced
retained with zero
and
let me show you the
final data frame that i have
so here you can see we have replaced
the draft pick values in the base price
column to zero
and on the right side you can see the
three different columns that i wanted to
create
so one is called retention so zeros
refer to draft pick
any other value will say
the player was picked from the auction
then you have the base price
unit so here
you can see crores
lacks
and the value base prices 2
40 so on and so forth
cool
choose from over 300 in demand skills
and get access to 1 000 plus hours of
video content for free visit scale up by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more
now
let's check how many players were
retained and bought from the auction by
each of the teams
so i'll say
ipl let me just scroll down
dot
i'm going to use the
group by function
then i'll say
team
comma
retention
and i'm going to
use the value
as
retention because i want to find the
count of
retained players
then i'll say colon -1
let me run it
you can see here
the different team names because i have
grouped by team and then retention so i
have changed super kings
from the auction they had picked
21 players and they had retained
four players
coming to delhi capitals delhi capitals
in the 2022
ipl auction they picked total 20 players
and they have retained four similarly if
i scroll down let me talk about let's
say punjab kings they have
pegged 23 players from the auction and
retained two players from
the team last year
talking about
rcb or all challenges bangalore they
have picked 19 players from the auction
and they have retained
three players
all right
now in the next cell of code
we are going to display the players in
each team
based on the different types of players
so let me just run it and show you the
result
so here i am using the same condition
the value shouldn't be equal to
unsold
and i am going to use another parameter
called hue for the different colors so
here
i have used hue
as type because i want to
show the players in each team based on
the different types
again i have given my
title to the bar plot
and then i have the x label the y label
and my rotation is 50 degrees now
if i scroll down you can see the
different
types of players here is the legend so
blue is for boolea
orange or yellow
it's for all rounder green is for batter
and red
which also looks like maroon is for
wicket keepers
and on the
x-axis you can see the different team
names
all right
now let's answer another
couple of questions so here i have
what is the highest amount spent on a
single player by each team
so to solve this question i'll say
my data frame name that is ipl
then i'm going to say
retention
equal to equal to
this should be from auction because you
want to see the highest amount spent and
not
from the retained players
then i'm going to
group
by
i'll say
team
and then
i'll say
cost
in
let me just copy it from here
cost in rupees
that is in crores
and
i'll say
max
colon
-1
dot
sort underscore
values
i'll say ascending
equal to false which means i want the
sorted
result in descending order
okay
let me just
bring this
to the left side and we'll run it
there seems to be some error let me
check the error it sees
there's a spelling mistake this should
be
team
let me run it again there you go
so you can see
mumbai indians
have spent
15.25 crores
for one of the players and
this player happens to be shan kissin
then
chennai super kings have spent the
highest amount for
a player who happens to be a bowler the
name is deepak chahar they have bought
him for 14 crores kolkata knight riders
bought
shreyas ayer for 12.25 crores
and so on and so forth
so these are the highest amounts spent
on a single player by each of the teams
let me scroll down
now we are going to see the player
retained at
maximum value or maximum price
now if you follow ipl
the maximum
price
at which a player was retained happens
to be ravindra jadeja so let's see at
what price was he retained
i'll say
retention
equal to equal to i'll say
retained
then i'll say
sort underscore
values
by equal to
i'll use the
same column
cost in
rupees
that's in crores
i'll say
ascending equal to
false
dot
head
and i want to find the top player
again there's some error
let's see
where is the error
she's ascending equal to false
dot head
okay this should be
sort underscore
values
within bracket i should say
buy
i think this should be fine now let's
run it
there you go
so you can see here our result is player
name ravindra jadeja who was retained
for 16 crores by chennai super kings
cool
now
the next cell of code will
display or print the top five bowlers
who have been picked in this year's ipl
based on
their cost in inr
let me just run it and show you the
result
you can see here deepak chahar went for
14 crores then we have shraddha thakur
who was bought by
delhi capitals earlier he was part of
csk
for
10.75 crores then we have prasada
krishna who has been bought by rajasthan
royals this time
last year he was with keker and he has
been bought for 10 crores similarly
lockheed ferguson has been bought by
gujarat titans and he played for kkr
last season he has been bought for 10
crores while his base price was too
close then we have avish khan
you can see avishkhan's base price was
just 20 lakhs and he has been bought for
10 crores by lucknow super giants again
and last year he was part of the delhi
capitals
now you can replace
this value
suppose let's say you want to find the
top five batsmans picked or battles
picked with the highest amount you can
just see
batter instead of bowler and if i run
this
you can see here
surya sayer was bought by
kolkata night riders for 12.25 crores
last area was part of delhi capitals
then you have
shimmerin hate mayor who's from
west indies he has been
picked by the rajasthan royals for
eight point five crores then we have
rahul tribati sikha dhaban and that
particle
now if you wanted to check for
let's say all rounders
you can replace batter with all-rounder
if i run this
you can see
lamb living stone has been bought by
punjab kings this season
for
11.5 crores his beast price was just one
crore and last year he was part of the
rajasthan royals
then we have a player from sri lanka
asuranga then we have hershel patel
shahrukh khan and rahul devatia who have
been
the top five all-rounders picked at
highest amount
cool
now finally
we want to
see the players who were part of the ipl
last season but were not picked for this
year's ipl
so for that what i'm doing is first i'm
renaming my
2021 squad column
this column i want to
rename it as previous team
let's run it
then
i am going to find out the unsold
players so here i am saying previous
team not equal to
not participated
and then
i am using another condition team should
be equal to equal to unsold and i'm
going to find out only the player and
the previous team
so let's run it and see the result
so here you can see
these players were part of the ipl last
season but
they haven't been picked this season
and last season they had played for
let's say suresh shrine i played for csk
steve smith was part of the delhi
capitals suckabulhassen
was part of kkr if i scroll down you
have david milan who played for punjab
kings in 2021
in morgan
who played for kkr he also captained kkr
but unfortunately he was
not picked this season chris lin from
australia also
remained unsold this season
and to tie we have been cutting aditya
there are other players as well
we have kane richardson dhawal kulkarni
cool so these were the players who were
part of the ipl season 2021 but
unfortunately were not picked and
remained unsold for 2022 season
cool
and that brings us to our
end of this demo session on
ipl data analysis 2022 so we learned
how to
use the different functions
and attributes that are part of the
python libraries and we manipulated the
data we visualized the data and
answered some specific questions
in this video we'll be using four
publicly available data sets about
formula one that has information from
1950 to the 2019 f1 season
we'll see how using the python libraries
you can perform exploratory data
analysis and draw valuable insights
so let's begin by understanding what
formula one is
formula one also known as f1 is a
motorsport defined by open wheeled
single seat race cars
it features the best drivers in the most
powerful and technically advanced cars
the sport is governed by the fia that is
international automobile federation
here 10 teams comprising of two drivers
each compete in a series of races over a
period of one year to find out the
ultimate driver and a constructor
champion
in our demonstration we'll be using four
data sets let me show them one by one
these are all csv files
now this is the first data set that
we'll be using in our demo so if you
notice the data set does not have
columns
names in fact none of the data sets have
column names so while importing the data
set we will assign the column names
using the names parameter
i'll show that in a
while
now this is the results data set
the results data set has information
about
result id
then we have the race id driver id
we have
the constructor id
grid position
then we also have information about the
fastest
lap then we also have information about
rank
the fastest lap speed
and the status id
now moving on to the second data set
which is about
racers
now this is the second data set which is
about races so
it has information about the race id the
year in which the race was held then we
have
the round number circuit id
then the name of the
grand prix so you can see here australia
malaysia and chinese spanish monaco
turkish british german
and others
then we have the
date on which the gp was held or the
grand prix was
held
you have the time
and a url which basically leads to the
wikipedia page of that particular
grand prix for that year
now moving on to our third data set
so this is our third data set which is
about
drivers
now it has the driver id the name of the
driver you can see here hamilton rosberg
alonso
uh ryken
then we have sato
masa
button weber and all
after that we have the
number code
then we have the
phone name of the driver the surname of
the driver
and then we have the date of birth of
that particular driver we have the
nationality as well
we have the wikipedia page
for the
driver
now moving on to the last data set which
is about
constructors
so this is the fourth and the final data
set that we'll be using in our data
analysis project so here we have the
constructor id
then the constructor reference
in formula one
and this is the actual name of the
constructor so we have mclaren
we have
bmw sauber williams then we have ferrari
toyota red bull force india
we also have jordan jaguar and all
next we have the
nationality and the url
that is the wikipedia page of
that particular constructor
now let's head over to our jupyter
notebook and we'll start with our
analysis
here is my jupyter notebook that i'll be
using for this demo you can see some of
the cells are already filled this is
just to make sure we
save some time
so using these data sets that we just
saw and our libraries such as numpy
pandas pad plot lib and c bond
we'll answer specific questions such as
the drivers and constructors who have
been the most successful throughout the
history of f1 sport
then we'll explore the impact of
starting and finishing positions and if
the speed of the cars has changed over
the years
so let's begin with our analysis
first and foremost we are going to
import all the necessary libraries so
here i am importing numpy pandas
matplotlib and cbon
and after that i am writing percentage
matplotlib inline
that is to ensure that
all the plots are embedded in line i'll
hit shift enter to run it
take some time there you go so we have
successfully imported all the libraries
now the next step is to
load the data and assign
column names
so
i'll load my
first data which is results i'll say pd
dot
read underscore
csv
i'll give my
file name which is results dot
csv
and then using the names parameter
i'll pass in the
column names so actually i have written
the column names in a notepad let me
open that
so i have this f1
notepad created which has the column
names i'll just start copying
the column names
within the names parameter i'll paste it
if i scroll to the right you can see the
different column names that
have been assigned
and
that
i'm going to say
comma
and i'll write
header equal to
none
i'll close the bracket
cool
similarly let's
import the second data set which is
about
races i'll say
pd dot
read underscore csv
i'll give my
file name which is racist.csv
and then i'll give the
names parameter this is actually names
and not name
okay
i'm going to
copy the
second line
and i'll paste it here
and again
i'll say
header
equal to
none
we'll import our third data set which is
about
drivers
so i'll say pd dot read underscore csv
i'll say
drivos.csv
then
again use the
names parameter
and i'll copy the
third line now which has the column
names
for the
drivers dataset
here
i
need to give
another parameter which is
header equal to
none
finally we are going to import our
constructors data set
it's a constructors equal to pd dot
read underscore csv which is the
function present in the pandas library
i'll say
constructors.csv which is my
file name
and then again i'll use the names
parameter
i'll go to my notepad and this time i'll
copy the
fourth line which has the column names
for the constructors dataset
i'll paste it
and
here i'll give my
final parameter that is header equal to
none
all right
now
let me hit shift enter to
run it
okay we see some error here let's debug
the error it says
no such file or directory drivers dot
csv
let's see
where was the issue
okay this should be
driver.csv
cool now we have successfully loaded the
data and assigned the
columns to the various data sets
now the
next analysis
is to merge all the data set
so here i'll create a data frame called
df and i'll use
pd dot
merge function
first i'll use the
results data frame that we just
imported above
this one
and
i'm going to
merge it with
racist data frame
and from the resist data frame i am
going to take
specific columns like the
race id
then
i need the
year
after that i need
name
next
i'm going to take
the round column as well
and
i'm going to use
on parameter
on parameter
is actually
the column that is common to both the
data frames that is results and recess
so here my common column
is going to be the raise id because it
is present in both the data sets
and i would like to merge
so for that i am going to use how so i
am going to use a left join
so
if you know sql you will be aware of
left join it takes all the rows from the
left table and only the matching rows
from the right table
i'm again going to use the merge
function so i'll write
df equal to pd dot
merge
i'll say
df comma and now i'm going to
merge the
ivor's data set
and
i'm going to select
specific columns so i'll say
driver
id make sure there are no spelling
mistakes in the
column names
then i'll say
driver
ref which is the name of the driver or
reference
comma
and then i want the
nationality of the
driver
all right
i'll give a comma i'll say on
which column i want to merge so here the
common column
is going to be the driver id
again
how is going to be a left join
going to the final
merge part i'll say again df equal to pd
dot
merge
i'll pass in my data frame and my final
data set which i have is about
constructors
from constructors we are going to choose
specific columns so i'll take the
constructor
id
then
i'll take
the name column
and again the
nationality column of the
manufacturer
here i'll say
on
equal to
the common column i'll use this
constructor id
you give a comma and say how
equal to
left again
make sure
you're merging it with the
right column names so let's run this
cell to merge
all the four data sets
i'll hit
click enter
oops there is some error let's see it
says constructor
id index
okay there's a spelling mistake this
should be
constructor id cool
let's run it
there you go
now the next thing we want to do is to
drop the unnecessary columns
so i'll say df dot
drop
within the drop function
we are going to pass in the
column names i'll say
number
then we also don't want the
position column
next we have
position underscore
text
after that we have
labs
next we are going to drop
fastest
lap
then we'll also drop the
status id
comma
we'll drop the
result underscore id column
then
going to drop the race underscore id
column
we'll also drop
driver underscore id column
and finally we are going to drop
the
constructor underscore id column
and
i'll say access equal to
1
and in place i'll c equal to true
because i want to remove it from my
original data frame that is df
there you go
now the next
thing i want to do is i want to rename
some of the columns so i'll say df dot
rename
i'll say
columns equal to
now we are going to pass in a dictionary
i'm going to change the
rank
to
test
underscore lab underscore rank
let me give a comma
now i'll say
name underscore x
equal to
i'll say the
grand prix name so i'll say gp
underscore name
next column i'm going to focus is
the nationality column so i'll say
nationality underscore
x
i'll give a colon the value i'm going to
pass in is
driver nationality
all right
up next
we have one column called
underscore
y
and that i'm going to change it to
constructor name
another comma
you want to say
nationality
score
y
colon
change it to
constructor nationality
underscore nationality
finally we have
driver
underscore ref column
and that i'm going to replace with
just
driver
finally i'll say
in place
equal to
true
just verify if all the column names are
correct
let's run it
all right so now we have
successfully renamed
the columns
after that
in the next cell i am going to rearrange
the columns so here i am
using the same data frame and
we have just renamed the columns so
starting with your
grand pre name round driver
nationality
and others
let's run this
up next
we're going to drop the
2019 season data because
it is incomplete
so i'll say df equal to df
then i'll say
here
not
equal to
2090
let's see how to
sort the values so i'll say df equal to
df dot
sort underscore values which is the
function name
i'm going to sort it by
year
followed by
round
followed by
the
position
underscore
order
comma i'll say
ascending
equal to
first let's say is false
next i have true
and then
i'll have true
all right
moving ahead now we are going to see how
to replace
the
put slash
n values in
the time column with
something called nan because the time
column was not registered when a driver
did not finish a race or was lab by
another driver
so to do this i am going to say
df.time
dot i am going to use the replace
function
and here i'll say
forward slash
or backward slash
n
and i'm going to replace with
numpies nan
i'll say
in place equal to true
let me just copy this because we are
going to use the same
emitters
next i am going to replace the
milliseconds value
milliseconds dot
replace i'll paste it here
then i'll say df dot
fastest
underscore lab underscore
rank dot
replace
paste it
next i have
df dot
fastest dot lab
dot
time
theory please
to that i have
the next column which is speed so i'll
say fastest
underscore
lap underscore
speed dot
replace
i'll paste it
so here
i'm going to replace
this particular value
the
backward slash
n with
nan
let me run it
cool
step i'm going to
change the data types for
fastest underscore lab underscore speed
to float then fastest underscore lab
underscore rank to float again
now
problem here is we cannot convert it
into an integer because there are
missing values so we are going to change
it to float
again for milliseconds also we are
changing it to float values
let me run it
now
i'll reset the index
let me show you how to reset the index
i'll say df dot
reset underscore
index
and say
drop
equal to
true
give a comma and say
in place equal to true
all right
that we have done our initial
processing step of the data set
now we'll check the shape of the data
set then we see all the data sets the
total number of non-null values the
memory usage and we'll
check the head of the data set
now to see the total number of
rows and columns i'll say print
df dot shape
you can see here there are total 24
197 rows in my data set and there are
total of 15 columns
now let's use
df dot
info function
so it gives me the
year the grand prix name
the round number
driver constructor name grid
position order total number of points
time
then time in milliseconds the fastest
slap rank
the fastest lap speed
the nationality of the driver the
nationality of the constructor
then here we have the
total number of non-null objects
and then you also have the memory usage
at the bottom
finally let's see the
head of the data frame so i'll say
df dot
head let's say i want to check the first
10 rows
there you go
if i scroll down you can see here we
have the top 10 rows printed
and you have the year the grand prix
name round driver constructor name and
other columns now let me just
brief you about what these column names
stand for
so the year column that you see here is
the season that the grand prix took
place and then we have the
name of the grand prix
now the round column is the number of
the race in each season for example one
means it was the first race of the
season and then
two means it was the second race of the
season so so on and so forth then we
have the name of the driver
that we have the
name of the car constructor so you can
see ferrari mercedes red bull renault
then we have the grid that is the
starting position before the race
actually this depends on the
qualifications which occur one day
before the race
then we have the position underscore
order column this means the final
position at the end of the race then we
have the points column that is the total
number of points scored in the race
next we have the time that is the amount
of time that took to finish the race
only the winners time is displayed and
drivers behind the winner are shown how
far behind the winner they are
then we have the milliseconds column
that is the amount of time that took to
finish the race in milliseconds
if i just scroll down
i'll just move to the
right
go to the top
then we have the fastest underscore lab
underscore rank that is the order of the
fastest lab during the race
next we have
fastest lap time that is the shortest
amount of time that took to complete a
lap in the release
then we have the lap speed that is the
average speed of the
fastest lap
then we have the
country to which the driver belongs to
and then we have the constructor
nationality that is the country where
the car constructor is based out of
okay
now
here i'm going to
set my figure size to 10 comma 6 this is
going to be for all the
plots that we are going to create
afterwards
cool
we'll create a data frame that will have
all the grand prix winners
so here i'm going to say
driver
underscore
winner equal to
use my data frame df dot i'll say loc
then i'll say
df
i want
the position underscore
order
and that should be equal to one so which
means
the driver one degrees
and then
i'm going to
use the
group by function
i'm going to group it by
driver
and
for values i'll say
position underscore
order
the
count function
followed by
sort underscore
values
i'll say
ascending equal to
false
you change it to
to underscore
frame
dot
reset
underscore
index
what essentially i am doing here is i am
finding out
all the drivers that have participated
and
won a grand prix
next i'm going to create a
bar plot so this is going to be the
first visualization of our analysis
so i'll say
sb
which we have taken in our
analysis ideally it should be sns but sb
also will work
so i'll say sb
dot
bar
plot going to say data equal to
driver underscore
winner
the y-axis i'll have
driver
in the x-axis i'll have
position
underscore
order
then i have
color equal to
green
that i'll set my
alpha value
to
0.5
or let's say
0.8
then
we are going to
give a title to our plot so i'll say plt
dot
title
let's say most
grand prix
winners in f1
then we are going to label our access so
for y label i will have
driver
name
we have
the x label
that will have
number of
grand prix wins
and i'll say
plt dot
y
text
cool
let's run it
and you can see we have our first
bar plot here now the bar plot
shows that there are
a large distribution of grand prix
events
only a few drivers in history of f1 have
won over 20 grand prey in their careers
and there are some drivers who
completely dominated the f1 racing and
have won over
50 grand priest in their careers so we
are going to focus on those
top five or top 10
drivers
in the next section so what i am doing
here is
from the
above
result that we just got
i'm going to filter out only the
top 10 so i'm going to use the head
function
and
inside that i passed in 10 if i print it
you can see here
as per the data that we have
we have michael schumacher who
is the position
order leader with 91 gp events then we
have hamilton vettel frost cena alonso
then we have stevert clerk and louder
the data that we have is
not the most recent one so if you check
the actual stats hamilton has actually
overtaken michael schumacher and has won
over
103 close to 103 races as of now
and
next we have michael schumacher so this
is not the most recent data
cool
now using this data we'll create another
bar plot for the top 10
drivers so i'll say sb dot
bar plot
i'll say data equal to
the
name that we have used that is top 10
drivers so i'll say top 10
drivers
in the y axis we'll have
the
driver name
in the x axis we'll have
position
underscore
order
for the bars i'm going to use a color
equal to
let's say blue this time
i'll set my alpha value
to be
0.8
and
i'll say let's say
line
width
equal to
0.8
and i'll also give
an edge color of let's say black
follow the same drill i'm going to give
a title to my plot so i'll say plt dot
title
most
gp
winners in a phone
give a y label
that says
driver
name
and then i'll have
x label which will have
number of
on pre
bins
cool
let me see if everything is fine
and then we'll
run this there you go
you can see we have a very nice
horizontal
bar plot that shows the
top drivers in f1 so as per our data
that we have we have michael schumacher
who has won over 91 or close to
91
races then we have hamilton vettel
alonso clark and others
all right
in the same way we are going to create
bar plot for the top constructors that
have participated in f1
so here i am finding out
all the
constructor winners so here
i'm using my position underscore order
equal to equal to 1 and then i'm using
the group by
based on the constructor name
and then i'm finding the count of
position order and sorting the values
in
descending order and i'm changing it to
frame or to a data frame
and to create my bar plot i'm using the
bar plot function the data which is
constructor underscore winner
in the y-axis i'll have the constructor
name on the x-axis i'll have the
position order
so you can see here i've used color as
pink and i've given a title x label by
label
and vitix
let's run it
there you go so here you can see again
the data is
widely
spread
so we have a lot of constructor names
now
our next task is to
check the
top 10 gpa constructor windows so here
i'm using the head function and finding
out the top 10
if i run it you can see here
the manufacturing companies or the
constructors who have won the most
number of
races
are ferrari
mclaren williams then we have more
cities red bull team lotus renault
and others
okay
now we'll convert this data into a
horizontal
bar graph or a bar chart
so that will show the bar plot for the
top 10
constructors
let me show you how to do it
so i'll say
sb which is for c bond dot
bar plot
i'm going to say data equal to
top 10 let me just confirm
the name we have top 10 constructors
scroll down i'll see constructors
y axis i'll have
constructor
on the x-axis i'll have
position underscore order
then
i'll say
color
equal to let's say we'll use the
red color for the bars
then i'll set my
alpha to
0.8
i'll say
line width equal to
0.8
and my
edge color i'll say
black
that i'll say plt dot
title
say
top 10
most
gp
wins
lt dot
by label would be
constructor
name
and i'll have plt dot
x label
as
number of
gp
wins
cool
let's run it
there you go so here you can see we have
ferrari at the top then we have mclaren
williams more cities i'm pretty certain
by
the end of 2021 season mercedes would
have gained a lot of wins
since hamilton
has been on the top
for mercedes for quite
some time now
all right
now
finally we are going to
create a regression plot that will
show how
two variables that is the starting
position and finishing position
vary
so to do that i am going to exclude the
data points with grid 0 because it skews
the data so 0 means that the driver
started from the
pit lane
so i'm using this function called reg
plot
to plot my
regression line
let me run it and show you the result
there you go
so if you see here
we can easily see there is a linear
relationship between the
starting and
finishing position so on the x-axis we
have the starting position on the y-axis
we have the
finishing or the finished place
so which is what is actually expected
right
now we can also see that most recess had
up to
25 drivers you can see the density of
the points here
but
some of the recess also had over 30
drivers you can see the
light color blue dots
next
we are going to
check whether the speed of the cars
changed over the years since this data
is only available from 2004 onwards so
we have
we have taken
years that start from 2004 onwards
now let me show you the result
of this data
so essentially we are plotting the
average speed among
all teams during the fastest lap at
individual grand prix and here on the
y-axis you have the average
fastest speed in kilometer per hour and
then you have the different
gps
and
you can see here the year values
now
in general what we see is there's a
decrease in the average fastest lap from
2004
till around
2015
for almost all the circuits
and again from 2015 onward the speed
started
to increase
you can see here there's an increase
after 2015 there's an increase there's
an increase here as well
you can also notice that
the speed is very different on each
track for instance if you check the
italian grand prix which is here
italian gp has the
fastest race in the calendar with
average speed exceeding over
240 kilometers per hour on the other
hand if you
talk about the
monaco ground pre let me show you if you
see here
the monaco gp is the slowest race with
average speed below
160 kilometer per hour now this is
actually expected because the monaco
grand prix
has very narrow streets and
hence the drivers cannot
drive fast in this circuit
all right
hello everyone
welcome to this live session on sql full
course video by simply loan
in this video
we will learn everything to master
structured query language or sql
this full course video will help you
write sql commands using mysql
postgresql as well as sql server our
highly experienced trainers will take
you through this course but before we
begin make sure to hit the subscribe
button and stay updated with all the
latest tech videos
so we will start by learning the basics
of sql along with understanding entity
relationship diagrams
then you will learn how to install mysql
workbench on windows
we look at the popular sql commands to
select insert update and delete records
and perform other operations on database
tables
you will see how to use the top
numerical and text functions in sql
next we will cover how to use group by
and having an sql followed by joins so
you will learn the different types of
join statements
as well as sub queries in sql moving
further we will understand triggers
stored procedures and window functions
in mysql you will get an idea about
another important topic that is to write
sql queries with python on jupyter
notebook then we will look at another
free and open source relational database
management system that is postgres sql
with extensive hands-on demonstration
finally you will learn how to become a
sql developer and see the top sql
interview questions that are frequently
asked in the interviews
so let's get started with what is sql in
this session we are going to learn about
databases
how data is stored in relational
databases and we'll also look at some of
the popular databases
finally we'll understand various sql
commands on mysql server
now let's get started with what is a
database
so according to oracle a database is an
organized collection of structured
information or data that is typically
stored electronically in a computer
system
a database is usually controlled by a
database management system or dbms
so it is a storage system that has a
collection of data
relational databases store data in the
form of tables that can be easily
retrieved managed and updated
you can organize data into tables rows
columns and index it to make it easier
to find relevant information
now talking about some of the popular
databases
we have mysql database we also have
oracle database then we have mongodb
which is a nosql database next we have
microsoft sql server next we have apache
cachandra which is a free and open
source nosql database and finally we
have postgresql
now
let's learn
what is sql so sql is a domain specific
language to communicate with databases
sql was initially developed by ibm
most databases use structured query
language or sql for writing and querying
data sql commands help you to store
process analyze and manipulate databases
with this
let's look at what a table is
so this is how a table in a database
looks like
so here you can see
the name of the table is
players on the top you can see the
column names so we have the player id
the player name the country to which the
player belongs to and we also have the
goals scored by each of the players so
these are also known as fields in a
database
here each row represents a record or a
tuple
so if you have the player id which is
103 here the name of the player is
daniel
he is from england and the number of
goals here score is 7. so you can use
sql commands to query update insert
records and do a lot of other tasks
now we'll see what the features of sql
are
sql lets you access any information
stored in a relational database with sql
queries data is extracted from the
database in a very efficient way
the structured query language is
compatible with all database systems
from oracle ibm to microsoft and it
doesn't require much coding to manage
databases
now we will see applications of sql
sql is used to create a database define
its structure implement it and lets you
perform many functions
sql is also used for maintaining an
already existing database
sql is a powerful language for entering
data modifying data and extracting data
in a database
sql is extensively used as a client
server language to connect the front end
with the backend thus supporting the
client server architecture
sql when deployed as data control
language dcl
helps protect your database from
unauthorized access
in this session we'll learn about ear
diagram starting with what is an er
diagram and why it's been so much used
by the companies then we will learn
about the symbols used in the ear
diagram and get familiar with the
components of it
so hey everyone i am abhisar ahuja from
simply learn and welcome to this video
on er diagram in dbms but before we
begin if you love watching tech videos
subscribe to our channel and hit the
bell icon to never miss an update
let's start have you ever wondered how
these big ecommerce companies manage
their tons of data that keeps updating
every second and these data sets keep on
updating in their databases to perform
operations on this data they should have
a conceptual understanding of these
databases and this is done by
understanding er diagrams of the
databases
so let's understand what an ear diagram
is
an entity relationship diagram
describes the relationship of entities
that needs to be stored in a database
er diagram is mainly a structural design
for the database it is a framework made
using specialized symbols to define the
relationship between entities er
diagrams are created based on the three
main components entities attributes and
relationships
let's understand the use of er diagram
with the help of a real-world example
here a school needs all its student
records to be stored digitally so they
approach an id company to do so
a person from the company will meet the
school authorities not all their
requirements describe them in the form
of ear diagram
and get it close checked by the school
authorities as the school authorities
approved the ear diagram the database
engineers would carry further
implementation
let's have a view of an ear diagram
the following diagram showcases two
entities student and course and the
relationship
the relationship described between
student and course is many to many as a
course can be opted by several students
and a student can opt for more than one
course here student is the entity and it
possesses the attributes that is student
id
student name and student age
and the course entity has attributes
such as course id and course name
now we have an understanding of er
diagram let us see why it has been so
popular
the logical structure of the database
provided by er diagram communicates the
landscape of business to different teams
in the company which is eventually
needed to support the business
a diagram is a gui representation of the
logical structure of a database which
gives a better understanding of the
information to be stored in a database
database designers can use er diagrams
as a blueprint which reduces complexity
and helps them save time to build
databases quickly
er diagrams helps you identify the
entities that exist in a system and the
relationships between those entities
after knowing its uses now we should get
familiar with the symbols used in ear
diagram
the rectangle symbol represents the
entities over symbol represents
attributes a rectangle embedded in a
rectangle represents a weak entity a
dashed oval represents a derived
attribute a diamond symbol represents a
relationship among entities double oval
symbol represents multi-valued
attributes now we should dive in and
learn about the components of er diagram
there are three main components of fear
diagram entity attribute
and relationship
entities have weak entity attributes are
further classified into key attribute
composite attribute multi-valued
attribute and derived attribute
relationships are also classified into
one-to-one relationships one-to-many
relationships many-to-one relationships
and many-to-many relationships
let's understand these components of
fear diagram
starting with entities
an entity can be either a living or a
non-living component an entity is
showcased as a rectangle in an er
diagram
let's understand this with the help of
an er diagram here both student and
course are in rectangular shape and are
called entities and they represent the
relationship study in a diamond shape
let's transition to greek entity
an entity that makes airlines over
another entity is called a weak entity
the weak entity is showcased as a double
rectangle in er diagram
in the example below the school is a
strong entity because it has a primary
key attribute school number
unlike the school the classroom is a
weak entity because it does not have any
primary key and the room number
attribute here acts only as a
discriminator and note a primary key
now let us know about attributes
attribute
an attribute exhibits the properties of
an entity an attribute is illustrated
with an oval shape in an er diagram in
the example below
student is an entity and the properties
of student such as address age name and
role number are called its attributes
let's see our first classification under
attribute
that is key attribute
the key attribute uniquely identifies an
entity from an entity set
the text of a key attribute is
underlined in the example below
we have a student entity and it has
attributes name address row number and
age but here row number can uniquely
identify a student from a set of
students
that's why it is termed as a key
attribute
now we will see composite attribute
an attribute that is composed of several
other attributes is known as a composite
attribute and oval showcases the
composite attribute and the composite
attribute oval is further connected with
other roles
in the example below we can see an
attribute name
which can have further subparts such as
first name middle name and last name
these attributes with further
classification is known as composite
attribute
now let's have a look at multivalued
attribute an attribute that can possess
more than one value are called
multivalued attributes these are
represented as double oval shape
in the example below the student entity
has attributes phone number roll number
name and age out of these attributes
phone number can have more than one
entry and the attribute with more than
one value is called multivalued
attribute
let's see derived attribute
an attribute that can be derived from
other attributes of the entity is known
as a derived attribute in the er diagram
the derived attribute is represented by
dashed over and in the example below
student entity has both date of birth
and age as attributes here age is a
derived attribute as it can be derived
by subtracting current date from the
student date of birth
now after knowing attributes let's
understand relationship in er diagram
a relationship is showcased by the
diamond shape in the ear diagram it
depicts the relationship between two
entities in the below example student
study course here both student and
course are entities and studies the
relationship between them
now let's go through the type of
relationship
first is
one-to-one relationship when a single
element of an entity is associated with
a single element of another entity this
is called one-to-one relationship
in the example below we have student and
identification card as entities we can
see a student has only one
identification card and an
identification card is given to one
student it represents a one-to-one
relationship
let's see the second one one-to-many
relationship
when a single element of an entity is
associated with more than one element of
another entity is called one-to-many
relationship in the below example a
customer can place many orders but a
particular order cannot be placed by
many customers
now we will have a look at many to one
relationship
when more than one element of an entity
is related to a single element of
another entity it is called many to one
relationship for example students have
to opt for a single course but a course
can be obtained by number of students
let's see many to many relationship
when more than one element of an entity
is associated with more than one element
of another entity is called many-to-many
relationship
for example an employee can be assigned
to many projects and many employees can
be assigned to a particular project
now after having an understanding of pr
diagram let us know the points to keep
in mind while creating the year diagram
first identify all the entities in the
system embed all the entities in a
rectangular shape and label them
appropriately this could be a customer a
manager an order an invoice a schedule
etc
identify relationships between entities
and connect them using a diamond in the
middle illustrating the relationship do
not connect relationships
connect attributes with entities and
label them appropriately and the
attributes should be in our shape
assure that each entity only appears a
single time and eradicate any redundant
entities or relationships in the ear
diagram make sure your er diagram
supports all the data provided to design
the database
make effective use of colors to
highlight key areas in your diagrams
there are mainly four types of sql
commands
so first we have data definition
language or ddl
so ddl commands change the structure of
the table like creating a table deleting
a table or altering a table all the
commands of ddl are auto committed which
means it permanently save all the
changes in the database we have create
alter drop and truncate as ddl commands
next we have data manipulation language
or dml
so dml commands are used to modify a
database it is responsible for all forms
of changes in the database dml commands
are not auto committed which means it
can't permanently save all the changes
in the database
we have select
update
delete and insert as dml commands now
select command is also referred to as
dql or data query language third we have
data control language or dcl
so dcl commands allow you to control
access to data within the database
these dcl commands are normally used to
create objects related to user access
and also control the distribution of
privileges among users
so we have grant and revoke which are
the examples of data control language
finally we have something called as
transaction control language or tcl
so tcl commands allow the user to manage
database transactions
commit and roll back our example of tcl
now let's see the basic sql command
structure
so first
we have the select statement
so here you specify the various column
names that you want to fetch from the
table we write the table name using the
from statement
next
we have the where clause to filter out
our table based on some conditions so
you can see here where condition 1
condition 2 and so on
then we have the group by clause that
takes various column names so you can
write group by column 1 column 2 and so
on
next we have the having clause to filter
out tables based on groups
finally we have the order by clause to
filter out the result in ascending or
descending order now talking about the
various data types in sql
so we have
exact numeric which has integer small
int bit and decimal
then we have
approximate numeric
which are float and real
then we have some date and time data
type such as date time time stamp and
others
then we have string data type which
includes car this varchar and text
finally we have binary data types
and binary data types have binary
var binary and image
now let's see some of the various
operators that are present in sql
so first we have our basic arithmetic
operators so you have addition the
subtraction multiplication division and
modulus
then we have some logical operators like
all and any or between exists and so on
finally we have some comparison
operators such as equal to not equal to
this greater than less than greater than
equal to or less than equal to not less
than or not greater than now let me take
you to my mysql workbench where we will
learn to write some of the important sql
commands use different statements
functions data types and operators that
we just learned in this session we will
learn how to install mysql workbench and
then we will run some commands
firstly we will visit the official
oracle website that is mysql.com
and now we will move to the downloads
page
now scroll down
and click on my sequel
gpl downloads
now under community downloads click on
my sequel installer for windows
the current versions are available to
download
i will choose this installer and click
the download button
now here just click on no things just
start my download
once the installer has downloaded open
it
you may be prompted for permission click
yes
this opens the installer
you will be asked to choose the setup
type we will go with custom
click next
now you have to select the products you
want to install
we will install only the my sequel
server my sequel shell and the mysql
workbench
expand sql servers by double clicking on
it
and choose the version you want to
install and click on this arrow
now you have to do the same thing for
applications expand applications
and choose the my sequel workbench
version you want to install and click on
the arrow
and we'll do the same thing for mysql
shell
and choose the latest version
click on the arrow
now these are the products that have to
be installed in a system
now i will click next
now click execute to download and
install the server
this may take a while depending on your
internet speed
as the download is completed
click next
now you see the product configuration
click next
now we will configure our sql server
instance
here we will go with the default
settings and click next
and under authentication select use
strong password encryption for
authentication which is recommended and
click on next
now we have set the password for your
root user by the way root is the default
user this user will have access to
everything
i will set my password
now i'll click on next
and here also we'll keep the default
settings
and click on next
now to apply configuration we will
execute the process
once all the configuration steps are
complete click finish
now you will see the installation is
complete it will launch my sql workbench
and my sql shell after clicking on
finish
so now the shell and workbench has
started
now will connect by clicking on the root
user it will ask for a password enter
the password and it will connect
successfully
now the workbench has started
now we'll just connect the server
so first we'll open command prompt
now we'll reach the path where mysql
files are present
i'm going to this pc
local desk c
program files
my sequel
my sql server 8.0
bin
and i will copy this path
now i will open the command prompt and
write a command cd space
and paste the link and press enter
now i'll write another command that
would be my sequel
minus u
space
root
minus p and press enter now it will ask
for a password
just enter the password
and press enter
now the server has started and now we'll
see some commands in my sql workbench
first we will open my sql workbench
now we'll click on the local instance
mysql 80
and enter the password to connect to the
local host
now the mysql workbench has started
now we'll see some commands
the first command we will see is show
databases
show databases semicolon
and now we'll select the whole command
and click on this execute button
and here we will see the result
in the result grid
these are the databases that are stored
already in the database
now
there are four databases that is
information schema mysql performance
schema and s5s
now we will select one of the database
we'll use
mysql
now we have selected the mysql database
and now in this database we will see
which tables are stored in this mysql
database to see that we will run a
command
show tables
select the command
and click on the execute button
these are the tables that are stored in
this mysql database that is columns
underscore component db
and much more
now let me now go ahead and open my my
sequel workbench
so in the search bar i'll search for
my sequel workbench you can see i'm
using the 8.0 version i'll click on it
and
here it says welcome to mysql workbench
and below under connections you can see
i have already created a connection
which says local instance then you have
the root the localhost and the port
number let me click on it
you can see the service
the username is root and i'll enter my
password
and hit ok
now this will open the sql editor so
this is how the mysql workbench looks
like
here
we learn some of the basic sql commands
so first let me show you the databases
that are already present
so the command is so databases
you can hit tab to auto complete i'll
use a semicolon
i'll select this and here on the top you
can see the execute button so if i run
this
below you can see the output it says
show databases seven rows are returned
which means
currently there are seven databases
you can see the names
all right
now
let's say i want to see the tables that
are present inside this database called
world
so i'll use the command use
world which is the database name
now let me run it so currently i'm using
the world database
so to display the tables that are
present in the world database i can use
the show command
and write show tables
give a semicolon and i'll hit ctrl enter
this time to run it
all right so you can see the tables that
are present inside this
world database so we have three tables
in total city country and country
language
now
if you are to see the rows that are
present in one of the tables you can use
the select command
so i'll write select star which
basically means i want to display all
the columns so star here means to
display all the columns
then i'll write my
from
the table name that is
city
so this command is going to display me
all the rows that are present inside the
city table
so if i hit ctrl enter
all right you can see the message here
it
says thousand rows were returned which
means there were total thousand records
present inside the city table
so here you can see there's an id column
a name column this country code district
and population
all right similarly you can check the
structure of the table by using the
describe command so i'll write describe
and then
i'll give the
table name that is city now let's just
run it
there you go the field shows the column
name so we have id name country code
district population
type here shows the data type of each of
the columns so district is character 20
id is an integer population is also
integer
null says yes or no which means if no
then there are no null values if it's
yes which means there are null values in
your table
key here represents whether you have any
primary key or foreign key and these are
some extra information now let's learn
how to create a table in mysql so i'll
use the create table command for this
and before that
let me create a database
and i'll name it as sql intro so the
command is create
database
and i'll give my database name that is
sql underscore intro
let me give a semicolon and hit ctrl
enter
you can see i have created a new
database
now
if i run this command that is show
databases
you can see this
newly created database that is sql intro
if i scroll down
there you go you can see the name here
sql intro
okay now within this database we'll
create a table called employee details
now this will have the details of some
employees
so let me first show you how to create a
table
that will be present inside the sql
intro database
so i'll use the command create
table
and then
i'll give my
table name that is going to be employee
underscore details
next
the syntax is
to give the column names so my first
column would be the name column which is
basically the employee name
followed by
the data type for this column since name
is a text column so i'll use
varchar
and i'll give a value of 25
so it can hold only 25 characters
okay next
i also want the age of the employee
now age is always an integer
so i'll give int
okay
then
we can have the gender of the employee
gender can be represented as f or m f
for female and m for male so i'm using
the car data type or character data type
and i'll give the value as one
then let's have the
date of join
or doj
and this is going to be of data type
date
all right
next
we'll have the city name that is the
city to which the employee belongs to
so again this is going to be varchar
15
finally we'll have a salary column
and salary we'll keep it as float since
salary can be in
decimal numbers as well
now i will give a semicolon
all right so let me just quickly run
through it so first
i wrote my create command then the table
which is also a keyword
followed by
the table name which is employee details
here and then
we keep the column names such as name
age
this gender
date of join city and salary
for each of the columns we also gave the
data type
all right so let me just run it
okay
so here you can see we have successfully
created our first table
now
you can use the
describe command to see the structure of
the table
i'll write describe emp underscore
details
if i run this
there you go
so under field you can see the column
names then you have the data types
null represents if
the table can accept null values or not
and these are basically
empty
and we haven't set any default
constraint
all right
moving ahead
now let's learn to add data to our table
using the insert command
so on a notepad i have already
written my insert statement so let me
just copy it and then i'll explain it
one by one all right
so if you see this
so we have used an insert into statement
or a command
followed by
the table name that is emp details
then this is the syntax using values i
have passed in
all the records
so first we have jimmy which is the name
of the employee then we have 35 it
basically represents the age
then m means the gender or the sex
then we have the date of join
next we have the city to which the
employee belongs to and finally we have
the salary of the employee so this
particular information represents one
record or a tuple
similarly the next employee we have is
shane
you can see the age and other
information
then we have
mary this duane sarah and amy
all right
so let me go ahead and
run this
so this will help you insert
the values in the table that you have
created
you can see we have successfully
inserted six records
now
to display the records let me
use the select statement so i'm using
select star from emp underscore details
if i run this
you can see my table here and the values
it has
so we have the name column the age
column the state of join city salary
and these are the values that you can
see here
moving ahead now let's say you want to
see the unique city names present in the
table
so in this case you can use the distinct
keyword along with the column name in
the select statement so let me show you
how you can print the distinct
city names that are present in our table
now if you notice this table clearly
we have chicago seattle boston austin
this new york and there's seattle
repeated again so i only want to print
the unique values
so for that i can write my select
statement as select
distinct
then i'll give my column name which is
city from
my table name that is emp details
if i run this
you can see
my query has returned five rows and
these are the values so we have chicago
seattle which was repeated twice is just
been shown once then we have boston
austin and new york now let's see how
you can use inbuilt
aggregate functions in sql
so suppose you want to count the number
of employees in the table for in that
case you can use the count function in
the select statement so let me show you
how to do that
so i'll write
select
i'll use my function name that is count
now since i want to know the
total number of employees i am going to
use their name
inside the brackets from
employee underscore details
now if i run this
this will return the total number of
employees that are present in the table
so we have six employees in total
now if you see here in the result it
says count name now this column is
actually not readable at all
so what sql provides is something called
as an alias name so you can give an
alias to the resultant output so here i
can write select count of name
and use an alias as
as
i can give an alias as
count underscore name
and run this statement again
there you go you can see here in the
resultant
output we have the column name as count
name which was our alias name
now suppose you want to get the total
sum of salaries you can use another
aggregate function called sum
so i'll write my
select statement
and this time instead of count i'm going
to write sum
and since i want to find the sum of
salaries
so inside the bracket i'll give my
salary column
from
my table name that is employee details
if i run this
this will result
the total sum of salaries
so basically it adds up
all the salaries that were present in
the salary column
now let's say you want to find the
average salary so instead of sum you can
write the average function which is avg
so this will give you the average salary
from the column salary so you can see it
here this says average salary now if you
want you can give an alias name to this
as well now you can select specific
columns from the table by using the
column names in the select statement
so initially we were selecting all the
columns for example like
you saw here
the star represents that we want to see
all the columns from the employee
details table
now suppose you want to see only
specific columns you can mention those
column names in the select statement
so let's say i want to select
just the name
age
and the city column
from my table that is employee details
so this will result
in displaying only the name agent city
column
from the table if i run it there you go
it has given only three columns to me
now sql has a where clause to filter
rows based on a particular condition
so if you want to filter your table
based on specific conditions you can use
where clause
now where clause comes after
you give your table name
so suppose you want to find the
employees
with age greater than 30 in this case
you can use a where clause so let me
show you how to do it
i'll write select
star from my table name that is
employee
details
and after this i'll use my where clause
so i'll write where
age
greater than
30.
if i run this
it will give me the output where the age
is only greater than 30 so it excluded
everything that is less than 30.
so we have four employees whose age is
greater than 30 here
now suppose you want to find only female
employees from the table you can also
use a where clause here
so i'll write
select
let's say i want only the name the
gender which is
sex here
comma city
from my table that is employee details
where
i'll give my column name that is sex is
equal to since i want only the female
employees i'll give
f
and run this statement
okay you can see here
our employee table has three female
employees
suppose you want to find the details of
the employees who belong to chicago or
austin in this case you can use the or
operator
now the or operator in sql displays a
record if any of the condition separated
by or is true
so let me show you what i mean
so since i want the employees who are
from chicago and austin
i can use
an or operator so i'll write select star
from
emp details which is my table name
then i'll give my where clause where
city
equal to
i'll give my
city name as cicago
and then i'm going to use the or
operator or
city
equal to
i'll write austin
i'll give a semicolon and let me run it
there you go
so in the output you can see all the
employees
who belong to the city chicago and
austin
now there is another way to write the
same sql query
so you can use an in operator to specify
multiple conditions
so
let me just copy this
and instead of using the or operator
this time i am going to use the in
operator
so i will delete this after the where
clause i'm going to write where city
and use the in operator
inside bracket
i'll give my city names as chicago
and i want
austin so i'll give a comma
and write my next city name that is
austin
so this query is exactly the same that
we wrote on top
let me run this
you will get the same output there you
go
so we have jimmy and duane who are from
chicago and austin respectively
now sql provides the between operator
that selects values within a given range
the values can be numbers text or dates
now suppose you want to find the
employees whose date of join was between
1st of jan 2000 and
31st of december 2010
so let me show you how to do it
i'll write select start from
emp details
where
my date of join that is doj
between
i'll give my two date values that is
first of
jan
2000
and
i'll give my
second value
the date value that is
31st of december 2010
so every employee who has joined between
these two dates will be displayed in the
output
if i run it
we have two employees who had joined
between
2000 and 2010 so we have jimmy and mary
here who had joined in 2005 and 2009
respectively
all right
now in where clause you can use the and
operator to specify multiple conditions
now the and operator displays a record
if all the conditions separated by and
are true
so let me show you an example i'll write
select
star from
employee details table
where
i want the age to be greater than 30
and i want
sex to be
male all right so here you can see i
have specified two conditions so if both
the conditions are true only then it
will result in an output
if i run it
you can see there are
two employees who are male
and their age is greater than 30.
now let's talk about the group by
statement in sql
so the group by statement groups rows
that have the same values into summary
rows like for example you want to find
the average salary of customers in each
department
now the group by statement is often used
with aggregate functions such as count
sum and average to group the result set
into one or more columns
let's say
we want to find the total salary of
employees based on the gender
so in this case you can use the group by
clause
so i'll write select
let's say sex
comma
i want to find the total sum of salary
as
i'll give an alias name let's say
total salary
from
my table name that is employee details
next i am going to group it by sex
okay
let me run it
there you go so we have two genders male
and female and here you can see the
total salary so what this sql statement
did was first it grouped all the
employees based on the gender and then
it found the total salary
now sql provides the order by keyword to
sort the result set in ascending or
descending order
now the order by keyword sorts the
records in ascending order by default to
sort the records in descending order you
can use the desc keyword
so let's say i want to sort my employee
details table
in terms of salary so i'll write select
star from
emp underscore
details
and i'll use my order by clause on the
salary column
so this will sort
all the records
in ascending order of the salary which
is by default you can see
the salary column is sorted in ascending
order
now suppose you want to sort the salary
column
and display it in descending order you
can use this keyword that is desc
let me run it
you can see the output now this time the
salary is sorted in descending order and
you have the other values as well now
let me show you some basic operations
that you can do using the select
statement
so suppose i write select
and
do an addition operation let's say 10
plus 20
and i'll give an alias name as addition
if i run this
it will give me the sum of
10 and 20 that is 30.
similarly
you can use
the subtraction operator
and you can change the alias name as
let's say subtract
let's run it
you get -10
now there are some basic inbuilt
functions
there are a lot of inbuilt functions in
sql but here i'll show you a few
suppose you want to find the length of a
text or a string you can use the length
function
so i'll write select and then use the
length function i'll hit tab to auto
complete let's say i want to find the
length of
country india
and i'll give an alias as total
length
if i run it
you see here it returns 5 because there
are 5 letters
in india
there's another function called repeat
so let me show you how repeat works
so i'll write select
repeat
let's say i want to repeat the symbol
that is at the rate
i'll put it in single quotes because it
is a
text character
and i want to repeat this character for
10 times
close the bracket
and let's run it
you can see here in the output it has
printed at the rate 10 times you can
count it
all right
now let's say you want to convert a text
or a string to uppercase or lowercase
you can do that as well
so i'll write select and use the
function called upper
let's say i want to convert
my string that is india to uppercase i
am not giving in any alias name
if i run this
see my input was
capital i and everything else was in
small letter
in the output you can see it is
converted
my input to all caps
similarly you can change this
let's say you want to print something
lowercase you can use the lower function
let's say this time everything is in
uppercase if i run it
it converts india to lowercase
now let's explore a few date and time
functions let's say you want to find the
current date there's a function called
cur which stands for current
and
this is the function i'm talking about
which is current date
if i run this you will get the current
date
that is 28th of 2021
and let's say you want to extract the
day from a date value
so you can use
the day function let's say i'll use day
and i want to find the day from my
current date
if i run this
you get 28 which is today's day
now similarly you can also
display the current date and time
so for that you can use a function that
is called now
so this will return the current date and
time
you can see this is the date value and
then we have the current time
all right
and this brings us to the end of our
demo session so let me just scroll
through whatever we have learned
so first i showed you how you can see
the databases present in mysql then we
used one of the databases and checked
the tables in it then we created another
database called sql intro for our demo
purpose
we used that database and then
we created this table called employee
details with
column names like name integer the sex
date of join city and salary
i showed you the structure of the
database let me run this again so you
get an idea you can see this was the
structure of our table
then we went ahead and inserted a few
records so we inserted records for six
employees so you have
the employee name the age the gender the
date of join the city to which the
employee belongs to and the salary of
the employee
then we
saw how you can use the select statement
and display all the columns present in
the table
we learned how you can
display the unique city names
we learnt how to use
different aggregate functions like count
average and sum
then we learned how you could display
specific columns from the table
we learnt how to use where clause
then we used
an or operator we learnt about
inoperator
the between operator
then we used an and operator to select
multiple
conditions
finally
we learnt about group by order by and
some basic
sql operations
now it's time to explore some string
functions in
mysql
so i have given a comment string
functions
first
let's say you want to convert a certain
string into upper case
so i can write select
the function i'll use is upper
and within this function you can pass in
the string let's say i'll write india
if you want you can give an alias name
as let's say upper case
i'll give a semicolon
and let's run it
there you go
so my input was in sentence case and
using the upper function we have
converted everything into uppercase
similarly let me just copy this
and
i'll show you
if you want to convert a string into a
lower case you can use the lower
function
and run this you can see the result
everything is in
lowercase now of course i need to change
the alias name to lowercase
now instead of using
lower as the function there is another
function that mysql provides which is
called the
l case
so i'll just edit this and write l case
and let's say
i'll write
india in
uppercase
let's run it it returns me the same
result
cool
moving on
let's say you want to find the
length of a string you can use the
character length function
i'll write select
use the function character length
and i'm again going to pass in my
string as india as
let's say total length
let's run it this time i'm going to hit
ctrl enter to run my sql command
there you go
it has given us the right result which
is 5 because india has 5 characters in
it
now these functions you can also apply
on a table
now let me show you how to do it let's
say we already have the students table
and you want to find the
length of
each of the student names
so here you can pass
s2 underscore name
and you can give the same alias name
let's say total length
and then you can write from
table name that is
students
if i run this
you can see the output
it has given me
total 20
rows of information
it is not readable actually let me also
display these student names so that we
can compare their
length
all right
i'll run this again
and now you can
see the result so josef has six
characters niles has six vipul has five
anubhav has seven
similarly if you see akshay has six
tanis cash seven raghav has six
cummins has seven rabada has six
so on and so forth
now instead of using this character
length you can also use the function
car length
it will work the same way let's see the
result
there you go it has given us the same
result you can either use character
length or care length
now there's another very interesting
function called concat so the concat
function adds two or more expressions
together
let's say i'll write select
i'll use the function
concatenate
the function is actually concat
and i'm going to pass in
my
string values let's say india
is
in
asia
let's run this and see our result
you can see here it has concatenated
everything
let us make it more readable i'll give a
space in between so that
you can read it clearly
now this is much more readable india is
in asia
and if you want you can give an alias
name as well as let's say merged
there you go
now the same concat operation you can
also perform on a table
i'm going to use the same students table
let's say i want to return the student
id
followed by the student name
and then
i am going to merge
the student name
followed by a space
followed by the age of the student
and i can give an alias as let's say
name underscore age
from
my table that is students
let's see how this works
okay you see here
the result is very clear
we have the student id the student name
and the
concatenated column that we created
which was name underscore age where we
have the
student name
with the space followed by the age of
the student
if you scroll down you can see the rest
of the results
cool
now moving ahead
let's see how the reverse function works
in mysql
so the mysql reverse function returns a
string with the characters printed in
reverse order
so suppose i write select
reverse
i'll use the same string again let's say
i have
india
let's run it
you will see all the characters printed
in reverse order again you can perform
the same operation on
a table as well let's say i'll write
select
reverse
and i'll pass in the column as student
name from my table that is students
let's run it
it gives you 20 students and all the
names have been
printed in reverse order
okay
now
let's see what the replace function does
so the replace function replaces all
occurrences of a substring within a
string within a new substring
so let me show you what i mean
i'll write select
replace
i'll pass in my input string which is
let's say orange is a
vegetable
which is ideally incorrect
i am purposely writing this so that i
can
replace the
word vegetable
with
fruit
okay
so what this replace function does is it
is going to find where my word vegetable
is within the string my input string and
it is going to replace my word vegetable
with fruit
let's run it and see the output there
you go now this is correct which is
orange is a fruit
all right
now
mysql also provides some trim functions
you can use the
left trim right trim and just the trim
function
so let me show you how this
left trim works
left trim or l trim removes the leading
space characters from a string passed as
an argument
so say i write select
i'll use the left trim function which is
l trim
and then i am going to purposely give a
few species
in the beginning of the string i'll give
a word let's say india
and then i'll give some space after the
bird india
and see
how the
l trim works if i run this
it gives me india which is fair enough
but before that
let's first find the
length of my string
so i'll use my
length function here
and
within this function i am going to
find the length of my string which has
india along with some
leading and trailing spaces
i'll paste this here give a semicolon
and i'll run it
okay
so the entire string is
17
characters long or the length of the
string is 17.
now say i use l trim on my same string
what it returns me is india
and if i
run length over it you can see the
difference
as in you can see
how many spaces were deleted from the
left of the string you can see here
now it says
17
and
i'm going to use ltrim
let's see the difference it gives me 12
the reason being it has deleted
five spaces from the left you can count
it
one two three four and five so 17 minus
5 is
12 which is correct
similarly you can
use the r trim function which removes
the trailing spaces from a string
trailing spaces are these pieces
when you use left trim it deletes the
leading spaces which is this
now let me just replace l trim with
r trim which stands for right trim
and see the result
so the length is 10 now the reason being
it has deleted
seven spaces from the right of the
string if you can count it one two three
four five six and seven
cool
you can also
use the trim function which will delete
both the leading and the trailing spaces
so here
if i just write trim
and i'll
run it
it gives me 5
because india is total five characters
long and it has deleted all the leading
and the trailing spaces
all right
there's also a function called position
in mysql the position function returns
the position of the first occurrence of
a substring in a string
so if the substring is not found with
the original string the function will
return zero
so let's say i'll write select
position
i want to
find
where
fruit is
in
my string that is
orange
is a
fruit
i'll give an alias as neem
the sum error here
this should be within double quotes
now let's run it and see the result okay
it says at the 13th place
or at the 13th position we have the word
fruit in our string which is orange is a
fruit
now the final function we are going to
see is called ascii
so the ascii function returns the ascii
value for a specific character
let's say i write select
ascii
of
the letter small a
if i run this
it will give me the ascii value which is
97
let's say you want to find the ascii
value
of
4
let's see the
result it gives me
52
all right
in this session we are going to learn
two important sql statements or clauses
that are widely used that is grouped by
and having
first we will understand the basics of
group by and having and then
jump into mysql workbench to implement
these statements so let's begin
first
what is group by sql
so the group by statement or clause
groups records into summary rows and
returns one record for each group it
groups the rows with the same group by
item expressions and computes aggregate
functions for the resulting group
a group by clause is a part of select
expression
in each group no two rows have the same
value for the grouping column or columns
now below
you can see the syntax of group by
so first we have the select statement
and then followed by the column names
that we want to select
from we have the table name
followed by the where condition
and next we have the group by clause
and here we include the column names
finally we have the order by and the
column names
now here is an example of the group by
clause
so we want to find the average salary of
employees for each department
so here you can see we have the
employees table it has the employee id
the employee name
the age of the employee we have the
gender
the date on which the employer joined
the company then we have the department
to which each of these employees belong
to we have the city to which the
employees belong to and then we have the
salary in dollars
so actually we'll be using this
employees table on mysql workbench as
well
so if you were to find the average
salary of employees in each department
so this is how your
sql query with group by clause would
look like so we have selected department
and then we are using an aggregate
function that is avg which is average
and
we have chosen the salary column and
here we have given an alias name which
is average underscore salary which
appears in the output you can see here
from employees and we have grouped it by
department so here in the output you can
see
we have the department names and the
average salary of the employees in each
department
now let me take you to my mysql
workbench where we will implement group
by and solve specific problems okay so i
am on my mysql workbench so let me make
my connection first
i'll enter the password
so this will open my sql editor
so first of all
let me
check the databases that i have
so i'll use my query that is show
databases
let's run it
okay you can see we have a list of
databases here
i am going to use my
sql underscore intro database so i'll
write use
sql underscore intro
so this will take us inside this
database i'll run it
all right
now you can check the
tables that are present in sql
underscore intro database
if i write show tables you can see the
list of tables that are already present
in this database to do our demo and
understand group by as well as having
let me first create an employee table so
i'll write create table
employees
next
i'll give my column name as employee
underscore id which is
the id for each employee
i'll give my data type as integer and
i'll assign
employee id as my primary key
next i'll give
employee underscore
name
and my data type would be
var car
i'll
give the size as 25
my third column would be the age column
age would obviously be an integer
then i have
my gender column
i'll use character data type and assign
a value of 1 or size of 1.
next we have the date of join
and the data type will be date
we have the
department column as well this is going
to be of varchar
and
20 will be the size
next
we have the city column
which is actually the city to which the
employee belongs to
and finally
we have the
salary column which will have the
salary for all the employees
okay
now let me select and run this
you can see here we have successfully
created our table
now to check
if our table was created or not you can
use the describe command
i'll write describe employees
you can see
the structure of the table so far
all right
now it's time for us to insert a few
records into this employees table so
i'll write
insert
into
employees
and i'll
copy paste the records which have
already
written on a notepad so let me show you
so this is my emp notepad and you can
see i have already
put the information for all the
employees so let me just copy this
and
we'll paste it here
all right
let me go to the top and verify if
all the records are fine
all right
so let's run our insert query
okay so you can see here we have
inserted 20 rows of information
and
now let's check
the table information
or the records that are present in our
employees table
i'll write select star from employees if
i run it you can see here
i have my employee id the employee name
age gender
we have the city salary and in total we
have
instead 20 records
now
let me run a few sql commands to check
how the structure of our table is
let's say i want to see the distant
cities that are present in our table
so i'll write select distinct city from
employees
if i run this
you see here there are total
eight different cities present in our
employees table so we have
chicago the shuttle boston we have new
york
miami and detroit as well
now let's say
you want to know the
total number of departments that are
present so you can use distinct
department
if i run this
all right you can see we have seven rows
returned and here are the department
names so we have sales marketing product
tech i t finance and hr
all right
now let me show you
another sql command
now this is to use an aggregate function
so i want to find the
average age of all the employees from
the table
so i can write
select
avg which is the
aggregate function for average
inside that i have passed my
age column from employees if i run this
so the average age of all the employees
in our table is
33.35
now say you want to find the average age
of employees in each department
so for this you need to use the group by
clause
i'll give a comment here i want to find
the average age
in each department
so
i'll write select
department
comma
i'll write
average of age
from
employees
group by
department
now if i run this
you can see here
we have our
seven departments
on the left and on the right you can see
the average age of employees in each of
these departments now you can see here
in the output it says avg of each which
is not readable so i can give an alias
name as
average age
all right i can bring this down
and if you want you can round the values
also
so you can round the decimal places so
i'll use a round function before the
average function
and
the round function takes two parameters
one is the variable and
the decimal place you want to round it
to
so if i run this
there you go you can see here we have
the
average age of all the employees in each
of these departments
all right
now suppose
you want to find the total salary of all
the employees for each department
so
you can write select
department
comma
now i want the total salary so i'll use
the sum function
and i'll
pass my column as salary
from
employees
grouped by
department
let's run this query
you can see here
in the output we have the different
departments
and on the right you can see the total
salary of all the employees in each of
these departments
now here also you can give an alias name
as
total underscore salary
let's run it again
and you can see the
output here
all right now moving ahead
you can also use the order by clause
along with the group by clause
let's say you want to find the total
number of employees in each city and
group it in the order of employee id so
to do this i can use my select query
i'll write select
count of let's say employee id
and i want to
know the city as well
from
employees group by
city
and next
you can use the order by clause
i'll write order by
count
of
employee id
and i'll write desc which stands for
descending
if i run this query
you can see here
on the left you have the count of
employees and on the right you can see
the
city names so in chicago we had the
highest number of employees working that
was four then we had seattle houston
boston austin
and the remaining also had two employees
so in this case we have ordered our
result based on the count of employee id
in descending order so we have the
highest number appearing at the top and
then followed by the lowest okay
now let's explore another example
suppose we want to find the number of
employees that join the company each
year we can use the year function on the
date of joining column then we can count
the employee ids and group the result by
each year
so let me show you how to do it
so i'll write select
i'm going to extract here from
the date of join column i'll give an
alias as year
next
i'll
count the
employee id
from my table name that is employees
and
i am going to group it by
year
date of join
i give a semicolon
all right
so let's run this
great
you see here in the result we have
the year
that we have extracted from the date of
join column and on the right you can see
the
total number of employees that joined
the company each year so we have in 2005
there was
one employee similarly we have in 2009
there were two employees if i scroll
down you have information of other years
as well
now if you want you can
order this as well based on year or
count
okay
now you can also use the group by to
join two or more tables together
so
to show you this operation let me first
create a sales table
so i'll write create
table
sales and the sales table will have
columns such as the product id
which is going to be
of integer type
then we have the
selling price of the product
now this will be
a float value
then we have the quantity sold for each
of the
products so i'll write
quantity
quantity will of integer type
next we have
the state in which the item was sold
and state i'll put it as worker and give
the size as 20.
let's run this so that we'll create our
sales table all right
so we have successfully created our
sales table
next we need to insert a few values to
our sales table so i have already
written the records in a notepad let me
show you
okay so here you can see i have my sales
text file let me just copy these
information
i'll just paste it on
the query editor
okay
now let me go ahead and
run this
insert command all right so you can see
here we have successfully inserted
nine rows of information so
let me just
run it through what we have inserted
so the first
column is the product id column then we
have the selling price at which this
product was sold
then we have the quantity that was sold
and in which state it was sold so we
have california texas alaska
then we have
another product
id which is one two three
and these are the states in which
the products are sold
so let me just
confirm with the
select statement i'll write select star
from
sales where on this you can see we have
successfully created our table
okay
now suppose
you want to find the revenue for both
the product ids
one to one and let's say one two three
since we have just two product id's here
so for that you can use the select query
so i'll write select
product id
next
i want to calculate the revenue so
revenue is nothing but selling price
multiplied by the quantity so i'll use
the sum function to find the total
revenue
and inside the sum function i'll use my
selling price column
multiplied by
my quantity column
i'll give this
an alias name as revenue
from
my table name that is sales
finally i'll group it by
product id
let's run it
there you go so here you can see we have
the two product ids one two one and one
two three and here you can see the
revenue that was generated
from these two products
all right
now let's see
we have to find the total profit that
was made from both the products one to
one and one to three so for that i'll
create another table now this table will
have the cost price of both the products
so let me create the
table first
i'll write create table
let's say the table name is c product
which stands for the cost price of the
products i'll
give my first column as product id
this will be an integer
and i'll have my second column as
cost price cost price will have floating
type values
let's run this
so we have successfully created our
product cost table
now let me
insert a few values into the c product
table so i'll write insert into
c underscore
product
i'll give
my values
for one to one
let's see the
cost price was
270 dollars
for each
and next we have my
product as one two three
and let's say the cost price for product
123 was
250
let's insert these two values okay
next we'll join our sales table and the
product cost table so this will give us
the profit that was generated for each
of the products
so i'll write select
c dot
product underscore id
comma
i'll write
sum
s dot cell underscore
price now here c and s are alias names
so if i
subtract my
cost price from the selling price
that will return the profit that was
generated
i'll multiply this with s dot
quantity
close the bracket
i'll give an alias name as
profit
from sales as s
so here s stands for the sales table
i am going to use
inner join
c underscore
product table
as
the alias name should be c
where
s dot
product underscore id is equal to c dot
product underscore id
we are using product underscore id
because
this column is the common column to both
the tables
and finally
i am going to
group it by
c dot product underscore id
all right
so let me tell you what i have done here
so i am selecting the product id
next i'm calculating the profit by
subtracting the cost price from the
selling price and i've multiplied the
quantity column
i'm using an inner join to connect my
sales and the
product cost table
and i am joining on the
column that is product id and i have
grouped it by c dot product id
let's run this
there you go so here you can see for
product id one to one
we made a profit of
eleven hundred dollars
and for product id one two three
we made a profit of
eight hundred and forty dollars so now
that we have learnt group by in detail
let's learn about the having clause in
sql
the having clause in sql operates on
grouped records and returns rows where
aggregate function results matched with
given conditions only
so now having and where clause are kind
of similar but where clause can't be
used with an aggregate function
so here you can see the syntax of having
clause you have the select statement
followed by the column names from the
table name then we have the where
conditions next we have the
group by finally we have having
and at last we have order by column
names so you can see here we have a
question at hand
we want to find the cities where there
are more than two employees
so you can see the employee table that
we had used in
our
group by clause as well
so if you were to find the cities where
there are more than two employees so
this is how your sql query should look
like
so we have
selected
the employee id and we are finding out
the count using the count function
next we have selected the city column
from employees we have grouped it by
city
and then we have user having clause
so we have given our condition having
count of employee id should be greater
than two so if you see the output we
have the different city names and
these were the cities where the
count of employees was greater than two
all right so let's go to our mysql
workbench and implement how
having works
so suppose
you want to find those departments where
the average salary is greater than 75
000
you can use the having clause for this
so let me first run my table which is
employees
if i run this you can see we had
inserted 20 rows of information
and
the last column we had was salary
so the question we have is
we want to find those departments where
the average salary is greater than 75
thousand dollars
so let me show you how to do it
so i'll write
select
department
comma
i'll use the aggregate function that is
average
salary
i'll give an alias name as
evg
underscore salary
from
employees next we'll use the
group by clause and i want to group it
by each department
and then i'm going to write my
having clause so in having clause i'll
use my condition that is having
average of salary
greater than
75 000
let's run it
and see the output
there you go
so here you can see
there were total three departments in
the company that is sales finance in hr
where the average salary is greater than
75 000
okay
next let's say you want to find the
cities where the total salary is greater
than 200 000 dollars
so
this will again be a simple
sql query so i'll write select city
comma i want to find the total salary so
i'll use the sum function
and i'll pass my column as salary as
i'll give a
alias name as total from
employees
group by
city
and then i am going to use my having
clause
i will pass in my condition as having
sum of salary
greater than
two hundred thousand dollars
all right
so let's run this query
there you go
so
so the different cities are chicago
sheatle and houston where the total
salary was greater than two hundred
thousand dollars now suppose you want to
find the departments that have more than
two employees so let's see how to do it
i'll write
select department comma
this time since i want to find the
number of employees i am going to use
the count function
i'll write count star
as
employee underscore count or emp
underscore count which is my alias name
from
employees
next i'll group it by
department
having
i'll give my condition
count star greater than two
let's run this
okay
so you have departments such as sales
product tech and i t where
there are more than two employees
okay now you can also use a where clause
along with the having clause in an sql
statement
so suppose i want to find the cities
that have more than two employees apart
from houston
so
i can write my query as select
city comma
count
star
as
emp count
from
employees
where i'll give my condition city
not equal to
houston i'll put it in double quotes
since i don't want to see
the information regarding houston
i'll group it by
city
having
count
of employees greater than 2.
so if i run this query
you see we have information for
chicago and seattle only
and we have excluded the information for
houston
now you may also use aggregate functions
in the having clause that does not
appear in the select clause
so if i want to find the total number of
employees for each department that have
an average salary greater than 75 000
i can write it something like this
so select
department
comma
count
star
as
emp count
from
employees
group by
department
and in the having clause
i am going to provide the column name
that is not present in the select
expression so i'll write having
average salary
greater than
75 000
this is another way to use the having
clause let's run this
all right you can see
we have department sales finance and hr
and you can see the employee count where
the average salary
was greater than 75 000
okay
so let me
run you from the beginning what we did
in our demo so first we created a table
called employee then we inserted 20
records to this table
next
we explored a few sql commands like
dixtend then we used average
and finally we started with our
group by clause
followed by
looking at how group by can be used
along with another table and we joined
two tables that was sales and product
cost table to find out the profit
then
you learned how to use the having clause
so we explored several different
questions and
learnt how to use
having an sql in this session we will
learn about joins in sql
joins are really important when you have
to deal with data that is present on
multiple tables
i'll help you understand the basics of
joins and make you learn the different
types of joints with hands-on
demonstrations on mysql workbench
so let's get started with what are
joints in sql
sql join statement or command is often
used to fetch data present in multiple
tables
sql joins are used to combine rows of
data from two or more tables based on a
common field or column between them now
consider this example where we have two
tables
an orders table and a customers table
now the order table has information
about the order id which is unique here
we have the order date
that is when the order was placed
then we have the shipped date this has
information about the date on which the
order was shipped then we have the
product name which basically is the
names of different products
we have the
status of delivery whether the product
was delivered or not or whether it was
cancelled then we have the quantity
which means the number of products that
were ordered and finally we have the
price of each product
similarly
we have another table called customers
and this customer table has information
about the order id
which is the foreign key here
then we have the customer id which is
the primary key for this table
we also have the phone number customer
name and address of the customers
now suppose
you want to find the phone numbers of
customers
who have ordered a laptop
now to solve this problem
we need to join both the tables the
reason being the phone numbers are
present in the customers table as you
can see here
and laptop which is the product name is
present in the orders table which you
can see it here so using a join
statement you can find the phone numbers
of customers who have ordered a laptop
now let's see another problem where you
need to find the customer names who have
ordered a product in the last 30 days
in this case we want the customer name
present in the customers table and the
last 30 days order information which you
can get from the order date column that
is present in the orders table
ok
now let's discuss the different types of
joints one by one so first we have an
inner join
so the sql inner join statement returns
all the rows from multiple tables as
long as the conditions are met
from the diagram a verb you can see that
there are two tables a and b
a is the left table and b is the right
table
the orange portion represents
the output of an inner join
which means an inner join returns the
common records from both the tables
now you can see the syntax here so we
have the select command
and then
we give the list of columns from table a
which you can see here is the left table
followed by the inner join keyword and
then the name of the table
that is b
on
a common key column from both the tables
a and b
now let me take you to the mysql
workbench and show you how inner join
works in reality
so here i'll type
mysql
you can see i have got
my sequel workbench
8.0 version installed i'll click on it
it will take some time to
open
okay
i'll click on this local instance
and here i'll give my password
okay so this is how an sql editor on
mysql workbench looks like
so first of all
let me go ahead and create a new
database
so i'll write
create
database this is going to be my command
followed by the name of the database
that is going to be sql underscore joins
if i give a semicolon and hit ctrl enter
this will create a new database you can
see here one row affected
now
you can check whether the database was
created or not using show databases
command
if i run it
here you can see i have
sql joins database
created
now i'll use this database so i'll write
use sql underscore joins
okay
now to understand
inner join
consider that there is a college
and in every college you have different
teams for different sports such as
cricket football basketball and others
so let's create two tables
cricket and football
so i'll write
create
table
and my table name is going to be cricket
next
i'm going to
create two columns
in this table the first column is going
to be
cricut id
then
i am going to give
the data type as int and use the auto
increment operator
i am using auto increment because my
cricut id is going to be my primary key
then i'm going to give
the name of the students who are part of
the cricket team
and for this i'll use
varchar data type and give the length as
30. i'll give another comma
and
i'll assign my cricut id as primary key
within brackets i'll give
cricket underscore id
cricket id is nothing but a unique
identifier for each of the players like
you have roll numbers in college
okay
let me just run it
all right so we have successfully
created our cricket table
let me just copy this and i'll paste it
here
i'll create
another table called football
this will have the information of all
the students who are part of the
football team and instead of cricket i
am going to give this as football id
all right
and
the name column will have the names of
the students
i'll change my primary key to football
id
all right
let me run this ok
so now we have also created our
football table
the next step is to insert a few player
names into both the tables
so i'll write my insert into command
first let's load some data to our cricut
table
so i'll write cricket and
i'll give my name column
followed by
values and here i'll give some names
such as
let's say stuart
give another comma
the next player i'll choose is let's say
michael
similarly i'll add a few more let's say
we have
johnson
the fourth player i'll take is let's say
hidden
and finally we have
let's say fleming
okay
now i'll give a semicolon and run this
okay so let me just check if all the
values were inserted properly for this
i'll use
select star from
table that is cricket if i run it you
can see i have created a table and have
successfully inserted
five rows of information
now similarly
let's insert
a few student names
for our football table
so i'll change this to
football
and
obviously there would be students who
will be part of both cricket and
football team so
i'll keep a few
repeated names let's say stuart
johnson and let's say hayden are
part of both cricket and football team
then we have let's say
langer
and
let's say we have another player in the
football team that is astral
i'll just run it
okay
you can see there are no errors so we
have successfully
inserted values to our football team as
well
let me just recheck it
i'll write select star from
football
all right
so we have five players in the football
team as well
okay
now the question is
suppose you want to find the students
that are part of both the cricket and
football team in this case you can use
an inner join
so let me show you how to do it
so i'll write select star from
cricket
as i'm using an alias name as c which
stands for cricket
then i am going to write inner join
my next table is going to be football
as f which is an alias name for the
football table
then i am going to use the on
command or operator
and then
i will give the
common
key that is name here so c dot name is
equal to f dot name
so based on this name column from both
the table my inner john operation will
be performed
so let's just run it
there you go so stuart johnson and
hayden are the only three students who
are part of both the teams
all right
now you can also individually select
each of the columns from both the tables
so let's say i write select c dot
cricut underscore id
comma
c dot name
comma
f dot
football underscore id
comma
f dot name
from
i'll write
cricket as c
inner join
football as f
on
c dot
name is equal to
f dot name
now if i run this you see we get the
same output here as well
all right
now let's explore another example to
learn more about inner joins so we have
a database called classic models let me
first
use classic models
i'll run this okay
now let me just show the different
tables that are part of classic tables
all right
so
here you can see there are tables like
customers there's employees office
there's office details
orders payments products and product
lines as well
all right
so
let me use
my select statement to show
what are the columns present in the
products table
okay
so this product table has information
about different
product names you have the product code
now this product code is unique here
we also have the product vendor
a little description about the product
then we have the quantity in stock
buying price and msrp
let's see what we have in
product lines
if i run it
you see here we have the product line
which is the
primary key for this table then we have
the
textual description for each of the
products this is basically
some sort of an advertisement
all right
now suppose you want to find the product
code the product name and the text
description for each of the products you
can join the products and product lines
table
so let me show you how to do it
i'll write my select statement and
choose my columns as product code then
we have
product name
and let's say i want the text
description
so i'll write this
column name
okay
then i'll use from
my first table that is
products
inner join
product lines
i can use using
the common key column that is product
line
close the bracket i'll give a semicolon
and if i run it
there you go so you can see the
different product codes
then we have the different product names
and the textual description for each of
the products
so this we did by joining the products
table and the product lines table
all right
now suppose
you want to find the revenue generated
from each product order and the status
of the product to do this task we need
to join three tables that is orders
order details and products so first let
me show you
what are the columns we have in these
three tables we have obviously seen for
the products table now let me show you
for orders and order details table
so i'll write select star from
orders
if i run it you can see it has
information about the order number
the date on which the order was placed
we also have the shipment date we also
have the status column which has
information regarding
whether the order was shipped or
cancelled
then we have some comments column we
also have the customer number who
ordered this particular product
similarly
let's check what we have under order
details
so i'll write select star from
order
details if i run it
you can see it has the order number the
product code quantity of each product we
have the price of each product then we
have the order line number
okay
so using the product
orders and order details let's perform
an inner join
so i'll write
select o dot
order number
comma
o dot
status
comma
i need the product name which i'll take
from the products table so i'll write p
dot
product name now here o
p are all
alias name for the tables orders
products and i'll use od for order
details
comma
since we want to find the revenue
we actually need to
find the product of quantity ordered
into
price of each product so i'll use a sum
function and inside the sum function i
will give
quantity
ordered
multiplied by
the price of each item
i'll use an alias as revenue
then i'll use my
from clause
from orders as o
inner join
order
details as i'll use an alias name as od
on
i'll write
o dot
order number
is equal to
od dot
order number
i'll use another inner join and this
time we'll join the products table so
i'll write inner join
products as
p
on
p dot
product
code
is equal to
[Music]
od dot
product code
and finally i'll use the group by clause
and group it by order number
all right
let me run this
okay there's some mistake here we need
to debug this
it says
you have an error in your sql syntax
check the manual all right
okay i think the name of the tables is
actually orders and not order
all right now let's run it
okay there's still some error
it says
classic models dot product doesn't exist
so again the product name is
i mean the table name is products and
not product so let's run it again
all right there you go so we have the
order number the status
the product name and the revenue
this we got it using
inner join from three different tables
now talking about left joins
the sql left join statement returns all
the rows from the left table and the
matching rows from the right table so if
you see this diagram you can see we have
all the rows from the
left table that is a and only the
matching rows from the right table that
is b so you can see this
overlapped
region
and the syntax
for sql
left join is something like this so you
have the select statement and then you
give the list of columns from table e
which is your left table
then you use the
left join
keyword
followed by the next table that is table
b on the common key column so you write
a dot key is equal to b dot key
okay
now in our classic models database we
have two tables customers and orders so
if you want to find the customer name
and their order id you can use these two
tables so first let me show you the
columns that are present in
customers and orders
i think orders we have already seen let
me first show you
what's there in the customers table
okay so you can see we have the customer
number
the name of the customer then we have
the contact last name the contact first
name
we have the phone number then there's an
address column there are two address
columns actually
we have the city name the state
and we have other
information as well and similarly we
have
our orders table
so i'll write select start form
orders
so i'll write select star from orders
but on this you can see these are the
information available in the
orders table
okay
so
let's perform a left join
where we want to find the customer name
and their order ids so i'll write select
c dot
customer name
or let's say first we'll choose the
customer number
comma
then i want the customer name so i'll
write c dot customer name
then we have the
order number column which is present in
the orders table and let's say i also
want to see the status
then i'll give my left table that is
customers
as c
left join
orders
as o
on
c dot
customer number equal to
o dot
customer number
let's run it
okay again there is some problem
all right so the table name is customers
let's run it
so there's another mistake here this is
customer number so b is missing cool
let me run it
all right so here you can see we have
the information regarding the customer
number
then
the respective customer names we have
the order number and the
status of the shipment so if i scroll
down you'll notice one thing there are a
few rows you can see which have null
values
this means
for customer number 125 and for this
particular customer name there were no
orders
and similarly if i scroll down you will
find a few more null values
you can see here there are two null
values here for
customer number 168 169 there were no
orders available
all right
now to check those customers who haven't
placed any orders
you can use the null operator so what
i'll do is here
i'll just continue with this i'll use a
where clause and write where
order
number is
null
now let me run this
okay so here you can see there are
24 customers from the table
that don't have any orders in their
names
okay
now talking about right joins
so sql write join statement returns all
the rows from the
right table and only matching rows from
the left table so here you can see we
have our left table as a and the right
table as b
so the right join will return all the
rows from the right table and only the
matching rows from the left table
now talking about the syntax so here you
can see we have the select statement
followed by the select statement you
will have the list of columns that you
want to choose
from table a right joint table b on the
common key column from both the tables
all right
now to show how right join works i'll be
using two tables that is customers and
employees
so let's see
the rows of data that are present in the
customer table first so i'll write
select star from
customers
let's run it so here you have the
customer number the customer name
then we have the phone number the
address of the customers
you also have the country to which the
customer belongs to the postal code
and the credit limit as well similarly
let's see for
the employees table
here i'll change customers to employees
let's run it
okay so we have the employee number the
last name the first name
we have the extension the email id
the job title
and also
reports to here means the manager
okay
so based on these two tables we'll find
the customer name
the phone number of the customer
and the email address of the employee
and join both the tables that is
customers and employees
so let me show you
the command so i'll write select
c dot
customer name
comma
then we have c dot
phone i'll give a space here
next
i want
the employee
number from the employee table so i'll
write e dot
employee number
comma
e dot
email
from
customers as c
right join
employees
as e
on
e dot
my common key column is employee number
here so i'll write e dot
employee number is equal to
c dot
we have
sales
representatives
employee number
and i'm also going to order it by
the employee number column
okay
so you can see i have
my customer name selected from the
customers table the phone number of the
customer then we have the employee
number and the email address so let me
run it
okay there's some problem
all right so the table name is customers
actually
let's run it once again
there you go
so you can see here
we have
all the values selected from our right
table which is the employees table you
can see writes on employees which means
your employees table is to the right
and then we have the customer name and
phone numbers of
the customers from the customer table
which is actually your left table
so you have a few
employee numbers such as one zero zero
two this one zero five six we don't have
any customer name or phone numbers
okay so there's another popular join
which is
very widely used in sql known as self
joins so self joins are used to join a
table to itself
so in our database we have a table
called employees let me show you the
table first
all right
so here you can see we have the employee
number the last name the first name of
the employee we have the email id
and here if you see we have a column
called reports2 now this you can think
of as
the manager column
so the way to read is
for example
for employee number 1056
the manager is one zero zero two so if
you check for one zero zero two we have
in murphy
then
if i scroll down
let's see for employee number
1102
yeah for employee number 1102 the
manager is one zero five six so here you
can see
who is at one zero five six you have
mary patterson
similarly if i scroll down let's say
for employee number one one eight eight
we have
the manager as one one
four three now if i check the table at
one one four three we have anthony bow
so
so the employee julie ferrelli reports
to anthony bow
all right
now suppose you want to know who is the
reporting manager for each employee so
for that you can use a self join
so let me show you how to join this
employees table
i'll write select
and then i'm going to use a function
called concat
within brackets i'll start with my alias
name that is m dot
then i'll write
last name
i'm going to concat last name
followed by a comma
then i'll have my
first name
i'll close this bracket
and then i'm going to give my
alias name let's say manager
comma
next
i'm going to concat
the same
last name and first name and this time
i'm going to use a separate alias let's
say
e which stands for employee so i'll
write e dot
last name comma
and within
single quotes
i'll
give my comma and then i'll write e dot
first name
i close this bracket i'll give an alias
as let's say
employee
from
i'll write
employees
as e
inner join
employs
as
m
on
m dot
i'll use my
common key column as employee number so
i'll write
m dot
employee
number
is equal to
e dot
here i'm going to use the reports 2
column
and then
i'll
order it by
let's say manager
okay now let's run this
there you go so you have your two
columns as manager and employee so for
employee louis bonder
the manager is zerat bonder
similarly if i scroll down
you have there are multiple
employees reporting to this particular
manager similarly we have our manager as
anthony bow and we have
different employees who are reporting to
this particular manager and so on
all right now moving ahead
now let's see what a full join is
so sql full outer join statement returns
all the rows when there is a match in
either left or right table now you must
remember that mysql workbench does not
support full outer join by default but
there is a way to do it
so
by default this is how the syntax of
full outer join looks like now this
statement will work on other sql
databases like microsoft sql server but
it won't work on mysql workbench i'll
show you the right way of using full
auto join on mysql workbench
so to show full outer join i am going to
first use a left join and then we'll
also use a right join and finally we'll
use a union operator so the union
operator is used to combine the result
set of two or more select statements so
first of all let me write
c dot
customer name so for this example i'm
using the customer table and the order
table
comma
o dot
order number
so i just want to know the customer name
and the
order number related to the customer
from
i have
customers
as
c
left join
i'll write
orders as o
on c dot
customer number
is equal to
o dot
customer number
let me just copy this
and after this i am going to use my
union operator
so union operator is used to merge
results from
two or more
tables
so basically this performs a vertical
join
and next i am going to use my right join
operation
so here instead of left join i'll write
right
rest all looks fine
let me just run it
there you go so we have successfully run
our
full outer join operation you can see we
have the different customer names
and
the order that each customer had placed
all right
so that brings us to the end of our demo
session
so let me just run through whatever we
did in this session so first we created
a database called sql joins
then we created two tables like cricut
and football
then we had
inserted a few
rows to each of these tables then we
used this table to learn about inner
join
next
we used a database called classic models
it had multiple tables so we explored
all of these tables like products there
was product lines orders customers and
employees and learned how to use inner
join left join self join
right join as well as full outer join
in this video
we will learn what is a sub query and
look at the different types of sub
queries
then we learn sub queries with select
statement followed by subqueries with
insert statement
moving further we will learn subqueries
with the update statement and finally we
look at sub queries with delete
statement all these we will be doing on
our mysql workbench
so before i begin make sure to subscribe
to the simply learn channel and hit the
bell icon to never miss an update so
let's start with what is a sub query
so a sub query is a select query that is
enclosed inside another query so if i
show you
this is how
the basic structure of a sub query looks
like
so here
whatever is present inside the brackets
is called as the inner query and
whatever is present outside is called
the outer query
so first the inner query gets executed
and the result is returned to the outer
query and then the outer query operation
is performed
all right now let's see an example so we
have a question at hand which is to
write a sql query to display department
with maximum salary from employees table
so this is how our employees table looks
like it has the employee id the employee
name age gender we have the date of
joint department city and salary
now to solve this query
my
sub query would look like this
so i'll first select the department from
my table that is employees
where
i'll use the condition salary equal to
and then i'll pass in my
inner query which is select max of
salary from employees
so what this does is it will first
return the maximum salary of the
employees in the table
then a router query will get executed
based on the salary returned from the
inner query
so here the output is
department sales has the
maximum salary so one of the employees
from the sales department earns the
highest or the maximum salary
if you see in our table
the
employee is joseph who earns
115 000 dollars all right
and joseph is from the sales department
now let's see how this query works
so here we have another question which
is to find the name of the employee with
maximum salary in the employees table so
this is our previous employees table
that we saw
and to find the employee who has the
maximum salary
my sub query would look something like
this so i'm selecting the employee name
from my table that is employees where
i'm using the condition salary equal to
and then i'm passing in my sub query or
the inner query so first i am selecting
the maximum salary
this will return a particular value that
is the highest salary from the table
and if you see our table the highest
salary is 115 000
so our query becomes select employee
name from employees with salary equal to
115 000 so the employee name is josef
here
and
that's the output now if you want to
break it down
here you can see first the inner query
gets executed so our sql query will
first execute the
inner query that is present inside
brackets select maximum salary from
employees the result is 115 000
and then based on the return result our
outer query gets executed so the query
becomes select employee name from
employees where salary equal to 115 000
and that employee is josef
all right
now we'll learn the different types of
sub queries
so you can write sub queries using
select statement update statement delete
and insert statement we'll explore each
of this with the help of example on my
mysql workbench
so let's learn sub queries with the
select statement
so sub queries are majorly used with the
select statement and this is how the
syntax looks like you select the column
name from the table name then you have
the
where condition followed by the columns
that you want to pass the operator and
inside that
you have this sub query so here is an
example that we will perform on our my
sequel workbench so in this example we
want to select all the employees
who have a salary less than average
salary for all the employees
this is the output so let's do this on
my mysql workbench
all right so let me login to my local
instance
i'll give my password
okay so you can see i'm on my mysql
workbench
so let's
start by
writing our sub query using the
select statement
okay so for this demo session we'll be
using a database that is sub queries you
can see it here i have a database called
sub queries
so i'll
use this
sub queries database
and we'll create a few tables as well
okay
if i run it
now we are inside the subquery's
database
so
let me just show you the tables that are
present inside this database i'll write
show tables
if i run it
okay there are two tables employees and
employees underscore b
we'll use this table throughout our demo
session
all right
now for our select sub query we want to
fetch the employee name the department
and the salary
whose salary is less than the average
salary so we will be using the employees
table so let me first show you
the records and the columns we have in
the employees table
so i'll write select star from employees
and run it okay you can see here we have
20 rows of information
we have the employee name the employee
id age gender date of joint department
city and salary so this is the same
table that we saw in our slides
okay
now for our sub query i'll write select
i want to choose the employee name
the department
and the salary
there should be a comma here instead of
a period
next
i'll give my table name that is
employees
where
my salary is less than
and after this i'll start my inner query
or the sub query and write select
average salary so i'm using the ebg
function to find the average salary of
all the
employees
from my table that is employees
if i give a semicolon
and run this
you'll see the output
so we have total 12 employees in the
table whose salary is less than the
average salary now if you want you can
check the average salary
so the average salary is 75 350 dollars
now the employees who have a salary less
than the average salary
so these are the people
all right
now moving back to our slides
okay
now let's see how you can use sub
queries with the insert statement
now the insert statement uses the data
returned from the sub query to insert
into another table
so this is how the syntax looks like so
you write insert into table name
followed by select individual columns or
star from
the table
use the where clause and then you give
the operator followed by the inner query
or the sub query
so here
we will explore a table called products
table
we are going to fetch few records from
the products table based on a condition
that is
the selling price of the product should
be greater than 100
so only those records will fetch and put
it in our orders table
all right
so we are going to write this query on
my
my sequel workbench so let's do it
i'll give my
comment as
update sub query
alright so first of all let's create a
table that is
products so i'll write create table
products
then we'll give our column names the
first column would be the product id of
type
integer
then we have the column as item or the
product
which is of type worker
30.
next we have the
selling price of that product the
selling price will be of type float
and finally we have another
column which is called the product type
and again product type is of the data
type where card i'll give the size as 30
close the bracket and give a semicolon
now let's just
run it
okay so we have successfully created our
products table
now let's insert a few records to our
products table
so i'll write insert into
products
followed by
values i'll give
four records the first product id is one
zero one
the product is
let's say jewelry
then the selling price is let's say
eight hundred dollars
and the product type is it's a luxury
product
next let's insert one more
product detail
the product id is one zero two
the product
is let's say t showed
the price is let's say hundred dollars
and
the product type is
non-luxury
[Music]
next
i'll just copy this
to reduce our task
we'll edit this
the third product's id is 103.
the product is
laptop
and let's say the price is 1300
and it's a luxury product
i'll paste again and finally i'll enter
my fourth product which is let's say
table
and
the price is
400
and it's a non-luxury product
i'll give a semicolon and we'll insert
these four records to our products table
you can see
we have inserted four records let's just
print it now so i'll write
select
star from
products
if i run it
you can see we have our four products
ready
now
we need to create another table where we
are going to put some records
from our products table so that
new table is going to be the orders
table so i'll write create
table
orders
now it will have three columns the
order id
order id will be of type integer
then we have
product
underscore
sold
this would be of type
varying character of size 30 and finally
we have the
selling price column
this will be of type float
let's create our orders table
the table name should be orders and
there is some mistake here okay
you should close the brackets okay
let me run it
so we have our orders table ready
now
let's write our
insert subquery
so i am going to insert
into
my table that is
orders
and i'll select
the product id
comma the item
and the selling price or the sell price
from
my table that is products
where
i'll write
product id
in
i'll write my
inner query select
prod id or the product id
from
products
next i'll give a where clause where
the selling price is greater than one
thousand dollars
so let me tell you what i am going to do
here i am going to insert into my orders
table
the product id
the item name and the selling price from
my products table
where
the product id
has this condition so let me first run
this condition for you which is select
prod id from products where the selling
price is greater than 1000 if i run this
okay
there is some issue here
the column name is actually prod id
now let's run it again so that we can
see the product ids of the products
which have a selling price greater than
one thousand
so it is one zero one and one zero three
now let's run the entire query
there is another mistake here let's
debug the mistake
now this should be product id instead of
product underscore in
let's insert again all right so we have
successfully inserted two records to our
table that is orders
now let's see the
orders table i'll write select star from
orders
if i run it there you go so there were
two products from our product table that
were jewelry and laptop which have a
selling price greater than one thousand
dollars so the selling price for jewelry
was eighteen hundred dollars and for
laptop it was
thirteen hundred dollars
so this is how you can
use a sub query using the insert
statement
all right now going back to our slides
again
all right
now let's see how you can use sub
queries with the update statement
now the sub queries can be used in
conjunction with the update statement
so either single or multiple columns in
a table can be updated when using a sub
query with the update statement so this
is how the basic syntax of an update sub
query looks like so you write update
table followed by the table name you set
the column name you give the where
operator
and then you write your inner sub query
so we are going to see an example
where we will use this employees table
and using this employees table we will
update the records of the salaries of
the employees
by multiplying it with a factor of 0.35
only for those employees which have age
greater than 27
so we are going to use a new table
called employees underscore b for this
as well so let's see how to do it
so i'll give my comment as
update
sub query
before we see the sub query let's see
what we have in the table employs
underscore b
this is basically a replica of the
employees table
there you go
it has the same records that our
employees table has we are going to use
both the employees table and the
employees underscore b table
to update our records
so i'll write
update
employees
set
salary
equal to let me bring this to the next
line
i'll write set salary equal to
salary
multiplied by point
3 5
where age
in
then i'll write select
age from
my other table that is
employees underscore b
where
age is greater than equal to
let's say 27
all right
so let me run through this query and
tell you what we are going to do so i am
going to update the records of the
employees table specifically for the
salary column so i'm checking
if the age is greater than 27 then
we'll multiply the salaries of the
employees with a factor of 0.35
in the employees table
let me just run this
then we'll see our output
okay so it says 18 rows affected which
means there are total 18 employees in
the table out of the 20 employees whose
age is greater than 27
now if you see i'll write select star
from
employees
you can see the difference in the
salaries
if i scroll to the right you can see
these are the updated salaries
okay
now if you check for employees who have
an age
less than or equal to 27
for example marcus whose age is 25 his
salary is the same we haven't updated
his salary
then if you see
if we have okay there is one more
employee maya
we haven't updated the salary of maya
because the age is less than
27
all right
now let's go back to our slides again
as you can see we got the same output
on our mysql workbench
now let's explore
how you can write sub queries for the
delete statement
now sub queries can again be used in
conjunction with the delete statement so
this is how the basic syntax of a delete
query using sub query would look like
you write delete from the table name
where clause the operator value followed
by the inner query in within brackets
so here we are going to use the
employees table
and what we are going to do is we will
delete the employees whose age is
greater than equal to 27
so let's see how you can do it
all right
so i'll
give my comment
as
delete sub query
so we'll follow the syntax that we saw
i'll write delete
from
my table name that is employees
i'll write
where
age
in
and then i'll start my inner query or
the sub query i'll write select
age
from
employees underscore b
where
age is
let's say
greater than equal to
32 or let's say the age is less than
equal to 32
close the bracket and i'll give my
semicolon
let me first run the inner query for you
so that you
get an idea of the employees who are
less than
32 years of age
so there are nine employees in the table
who have an age less than equal to 32
so we are going to delete the records
if i run this
okay it says nine records deleted now
let's
print or display what we have
in the employees table
if i run this
there you go
so if you see the age table we have
total 11 employees now
and all the ages are greater than
32 because we have deleted all those
employees who had an age less than equal
to 32
okay
so
let me show you from the beginning what
we did so first we used our
sub queries database then
we used our employees table
so we started by
looking at how you can use the sub query
with a select statement this should be
insert instead of update
so we learned how to
write an insert sub query
we use two tables products and our
orders table
moving ahead we saw how to write
sub queries using the update command
so we updated the salaries of the
employee by a factor of 0.35 for those
who had an age greater than equal to 27
and finally we saw how to use the sub
query using the delete statement so we
deleted all those records for the
employees whose age was less than equal
to 32 in this video we will discuss an
advanced sql concept called triggers
we will learn what triggers are and how
they can be used to solve problems
we look at how trigger queries are
written on mysql workbench so let's get
started
first
what are triggers in sql
so a trigger is a user defined sql
command that is invoked automatically
when an event occurs
an event can be related to inserting
updating or deleting records in a table
in mysql triggers can be executed
automatically by the oracle server
below is how the syntax of writing a
trigger is
so you write create trigger
followed by the trigger name
now the trigger name should be a valid
sql name
then we have the trigger time
the trigger event and then on the name
of the table then we write for each row
begin
followed by the list of sql statements
and finally the right end
now in the syntax the trigger time
represents either before or after an
event
and a trigger event can be an insert
update or delete operation now let me
take you to mysql workbench where we
will learn how to create triggers and
explore more on how it works so i am on
mysql workbench so first let me go ahead
and create my connection i'll give my
password
all right now this will take you to my
sql editor okay so first and foremost
let me create a new database called
triggers so
i'll write mysql command as
create
database
triggers
let me
run this
okay so you can see here one row
affected i have created my database that
is triggers
next
i'm going to move inside this database
so i'll write the command use triggers
let's run this
okay
now inside this triggers database we'll
be creating our different tables
so
let's check if we have any tables i'll
use the command show tables
now you see there are no tables in this
database
all right
first let's see how before insert
trigger works
so for before insert trigger we'll
create a table called customers and
verify the age of each customer
so i'll give a comment
before
insert
trigger
so let me go ahead and create my
customers table i'll write create table
customers
and i'll give my column names as
cust underscore id which is
customer id
this is going to be an integer
then we have the age of the customer
this is again an integer
and we'll have the
name of the customer
the name of the customer will be a
varchar type i'll give the size as 30
all right
let's create this table okay so we have
successfully created our customers table
now moving ahead i am going to write my
before insert trigger command so we'll
start with a delimiter
so a delimiter is a marker for the end
of each command
next
i'll write my
create trigger
followed by the trigger name
i'll give a valid trigger name such as
each underscore
verify
i'll write
before
trigger
it should be before insert
on my table name would be
customers
then i'll write for
each
row
if
new dot age
is less than
zero
then
set
new dot age
equal to zero which means
while inserting your
values to the each column in case the
each value is negative will convert the
age to zero
i'll give a semicolon
and then i'll write end if
i'll give another semicolon
and
close the delimiter
now let me run this
okay so we have created our trigger
now
let's insert a few values
onto customers
so i'll write insert into customers
values
101 which is the customer id i'll give
the age as 27 and let's say the name of
the customer is
james
let's insert another record
give the value as 102
and this time i'm purposely giving the
age as minus 40 which is less than 0 so
that you can see the output clearly
i have given the customer name as ami
let's insert two more records the
customer id with 103 has an ease of 32
and let's see the name is ben
i'll give another comma
and finally we'll insert our fourth
customer record the customer id is 104
the age i am giving as minus 39 which is
less than zero again and let's say
the customer name is angela
all right now let me run this
okay so we have successfully inserted
four
rows of information to our customers
table
now let's see the difference since we
had created a each verify trigger
which would
change the values of the each column
in case the each value is less than zero
so now that we have inserted four
records to a customer
so
let's see what we have in the customers
table
now let me run it
there you go
so if you see this
for those customers
where the age was less than 0 such as
102 and 103 you can see here
our trigger has automatically converted
those values to 0.
if you can see the trigger we had
created
we had set our new age to zero
if
the age was less than zero
and this is the output we get
so here we looked at how a before insert
trigger works
all right now moving ahead
let's understand how an after insert
trigger works so i'll give a
comment here
as
after insert
trigger
now in this example we'll create two
tables customers and message
now the trigger will be fired if the
birthday column has a null value in the
customers table
you will get a message to update your
date of birth
okay
so first let me create
my customers table
now since we already have one customers
table i'll name it as customers1
and
let me give the column names
so the first column would be the id
column this is going to be an integer
and i'll use the
auto increment parameter
and this will be my primary key as well
next we'll have the name of the customer
this is going to be of type varchar
and i'll use
not null constraint
next
we'll have the email id of the customer
this is again going to be of barca type
and the column we are interested in is
the birthday column
so i'll write birth date
this is going to be of type date
okay
so let's create our table
all right
now we'll create our second table
which is going to be
message
let's create the columns this will have
id int and
i'll use the
auto increment operator
next we'll have the
message id
this is going to be of integer type
we'll
have a column called message
this will be a varchar type let's say
300 characters
and not null
and
i am going to set
my primary keys
as id
and
message id
let's
create our second table then
so we have some error here let's debug
the error
okay so i forgot to
close the bracket here all right
now let me
run this table all right so we have
created our message table as well
next
i'll write my
after insert trigger command so i'll
write
delimiter
next i'll use
create trigger command so i'll write
create trigger
my trigger name would be
check
underscore null underscore date of birth
after
insert
on
customers
1
for
each
row
begin
if
new dot
birth date
is
null
then
we are going to insert
into our message table
give the columns as
message id
and
message
values
new dot id
comma i am going to use the
concat function
where i'll
give my
message let's say hi
followed by the name
followed by
let's say please
update
your
date of
birth
okay
now i'll write end if
i'll
close the delimiter
okay
so let me go to the top and recheck
if you have created a trigger
correctly so i have my
trigger name after insert on customers1
for each row begin
if our new birthday has a null value
then we'll pass in a message saying hi
the name of the customer
then the message would be please update
your date of birth
all right
so let's run the
trigger
okay
now
the next step is to
insert a few records to customer table
so my name of the table is customers1
okay
i'll give the column names as name
email
and birth
okay
we'll
pass in a few values
so our first customer's name let's say
is nancy
comma
i'll give my
email id let's say
nancy at the rate
abc.com
now
let's see i'm purposely passing the date
of birth as null
i'll give a comma
my next customer let's say
the name of the customer is
ronald
and then i'll give the
email id
such as ronald at the rate
xyz.com
and this time i'm going to pass in the
date of birth let's see 1998
november
and let's say 16th
okay
now we'll
add another customer let's say krish
will give the email id of chris
so krish
xyz.com
and let's see
we'll keep the date of birth as 1997
0 8
20.
and finally we'll add
one more record for another customer
let's say alice
i'll give the email id as
alice
at the rate abc.com
and this time i'll purposely pass
the date of birth as null
all right
so let's run the insert query okay
now
let me display the
message table for you so that you can
see the output
and how are
after insert trigger works
there you go so if you see this we had
inserted four rows of information out of
which the first customer id and
the fourth
id had null date of birth
so for those two values you have the
messages hi nancy please update your
data birth and then you have hi alice
please update your date of birth
now you can give a space between hi and
the name of the customer
all right now moving ahead let's
understand how before update trigger
works so i'll give a comment here as
before update
okay
now
to show you how before update works
first we'll create
a table called employees
all right
so let me create my table that is create
table
employees
i'll give my column as
employee id this is going to be an
integer type
and
it will be my primary key
next we'll have the employee name
this will be of
varchar type
and let's say the size would be 25
comma
then we'll have the age of the employee
age will be of integer type
and finally we'll have the
salary of the employee
salary will be of type float
let's create this table
all right
now the next step is to insert a few
records to our employees table
okay so here on the notepad i have
already
written my insert query
so i have inserted nearly seven records
so let me paste it here all right
i'll just go ahead and run this insert
query so that we'll insert
seven employees to our table
okay
next
we'll write our before update trigger
command
so first and foremost i'll write
my delimiter
followed by the create trigger command
i'll give my
trigger name as update underscore
trigger
let's
bring this to the top
okay
i'll use
before update
on
my
table that is employees
for
each
row
i'll write begin
my condition would be if
new dot
salary
is equal to let's say
10 000
i'll write
then
set
new dot
salary
equal to
85 000
i'll give a semicolon
then i'll use
else if
new dot
salary
is less than
10 000
then
i'll set
new dot
salary
to let's say
72 000
i'll give a semicolon
i'll end the
if statement
i'll close the delimiter
by giving a semicolon
okay
so
if you see the employees table we have
the salary values here
now in case
while updating the table
if the salary is equal to
10 000 will set the new salary to eighty
five thousand dollars
else if the salary is less than ten
thousand dollars we'll set the salary
column values to seven to two thousand
dollars
so let's go ahead and run
this trigger query
all right
now let me use my
update command so i'll write update
employees
i'll write set
salary is equal to
let's say eight thousand dollars
now if you see our trigger query
we are setting the salary to eight
thousand dollars which is clearly less
than
ten thousand dollars so our new salary
would be seven to two thousand dollars
so let me
run this
okay
so you can see here six rows affected
so i'll right now select star from
employees
let's run this
okay
if you see this
we have converted our salary column to
72 thousand dollars since we updated the
salary to eight thousand dollars and
according to our trigger query if it's
less than ten thousand dollars the
salary should be seven to two thousand
dollars
which you can see here
all right now moving to our final demo
this time we are going to explore how
before delete trigger command works
so in this example we'll create a table
called salary
we'll store the deleted record in a new
table using the before delete
trigger so first
i'll give my comment as
before trigger
comments are always useful
since they make your query more readable
so let me now create my salary table so
i'll write create
table
salary
i'll give my column names as
eid which is
employee id
and i'll set it as primary key
comma
i'll give
another column let's say valid from
which means the date from which this
salary was effective
is going to be of type date and not null
and then i'll have the amount
amount will be of type float
and again not null constraint
let me run the create table
command okay so we have created our
salary table now
the next thing is to insert a few values
so i'll write insert into
salary
i'll give my column names as eid comma
valid from
comma amount
i'll write values
my first employee id would be 101
followed by a date let's say 2005
may
and
0 1 which is 1st of may 2005.
let's say the amount is 55 000
i'll give another row of information
this time the employee id is 102
and
i'll give a valid from date
let's say the amount is 68 000
i'll give
another employee id let's say one zero
three
two thousand and six
zero nine
zero one
and let's say the amount is seventy five
thousand dollars
okay
let's run this
all right
you can verify also so i'll write select
star from salary
you can see here we have inserted three
rows of information
all right
the next step is to create
another table that will store the
deleted rows so i'll write create
table
let's say the name of the table is
create
or let's say salary delete
i'll write salary del
now this will have the id
the type would be integer
and primary key
i'll also use the auto increment
operator
next we have the eid
which is of type integer
i'll write valid from
date
and
not null
then i have the amount column which is
of type float and not null
my final column would be
deleted
at
the data type will be
timestamp
i'll use the
default constraint as now
so this will return the time and the
date at which the record was deleted
all right
let me create this table okay
finally
let me write my before delete
trigger command
so i'll first declare my delimiter
let's say this time i'm using the dollar
symbol
i'll write
create trigger
my trigger name would be
salary underscore delete
before
delete
on my table that is salary
for
each
row
i'll write begin
next
let's insert
into
salary
delete
i'll give my columns as
employee
id
valid from
an amount
now we'll insert a few values
i'll write values
old dot
eid
comma
old
dot
valid
from
comma
old dot amount
i am going to
close
with the delimiters
all right
so let's
run our
before delete trigger
all right
now let me go ahead and delete one of
the records from the salary table
so i'll write delete from salary
where
employee id is let's say 103
let me run this query
okay so you have successfully deleted
one of the
records in the table
now if you see
our other table that is salary delete
you will find
this information present in the salary
delete column so we have deleted one row
of information that is for employee id
103 which you can find it here now
the final column that is deleted shows
the time at which the information was
deleted or the row was deleted
all right so let me go to the top and
just
give you a recap of what we did in this
demo
so first we created a database called
triggers
then
we started with before insert trigger
where we inserted customer table
and then
we verified the age of the customers
so we saw if the age was less than zero
then we set these to zero
we inserted a few records to the
customers table and purposely we
inserted some negative
age records and then we converted this
ether cost to zero
then we learned how an after insert
trigger works so we created two tables
customers one and message
so wherever
the customers date of birth was missing
we passed in a message saying hi
the name of the customer please update
your date of birth
all right
now moving ahead
we saw how before update trigger works
and finally we learnt about
before delete trigger
so in this video we will learn sub
queries in sql we'll also have a look at
stored procedures and learn about
triggers in sql we'll cover views in sql
and look at some of the important
windows functions in sql
now to learn all of these we'll be using
the mysql workbench on windows
so let's get started with sub queries in
sql
so let me head over to my mysql
workbench
so currently i am on my mysql workbench
let me connect to the local instance
so i'll give my password
i'll click on ok
all right
so this is my
mysql workbench query editor so first we
are going to learn sub queries let me
give a comment
and write sub queries
all right
so first of all let's understand what a
sub query is so a sub query is a query
within another sql query that is
embedded within the where clause from
clause or having clause
so we'll explore a few scenarios where
we can use sub queries so for that
i'll be using my
database that is sql underscore intro so
i'll write my command use sql underscore
intro
now this database has a lot of tables
i'll be using the employees table that
is present inside sql underscore intro
let me just expand this and you can see
here we have an employees table
so let me first show you
the contents within this table i'll
write select star from employees
let me execute it
okay you can see here we have the
employee id employee name age gender
this
date of joint department city and salary
and we have information for
20 employees if i scroll down you can
see there are 20
employees present in our table
so let's say
you want to find the employees whose
salary is greater than the average
salary
in such a scenario you can use a sub
query
so let me show you how to
write a sub query
i'll write the select statement
in the select statement i'll pass
my column names that i want to display
so the column names i want are the
employee name
then i want the department of the
employee and the salary of the employee
from
my table name that is employees
next
i'll use a where condition
where
my salary should be greater than the
average salary of all the employees
so i'll write salary greater than
after this i am going to write my sub
query
so i will give
select
average of salary
from
my table name that is employees
and i'll close the bracket and give a
semicolon
so what it does is
first it is going to find the average
salary of all the employees that are
present in our table
once we get the average salary number
will use this
where condition
where salary is greater than the average
salary number
so
the inside sub query let me run it first
if i run this
this gives you the average salary of all
the employees which is
seventy five thousand three hundred and
fifty dollars
now
i want to display all the employees who
have salary greater than seventy five
thousand
three hundred and fifty dollars
so let's run our
sub query
there you go so there are eight
employees in our table who have
a salary greater than the average salary
of all the employees
all right
next
let's see another example
suppose this time you want to find the
employees whose salary is greater than
john's salary
so we have one employee whose name is
john
let me
run the table once again
okay if i scroll down
you see we have an employee
as
john
you see this
our employee id 116 is john and his
salary is
67 000
i want to display all the employees
whose salary is greater than john's
salary so basically all the employees
who are earning more than 65 thousand
dollars i want to print them
so let's see how to do it
i'll write
select
i want the employee name
comma the gender of the employee
i also want the department and salary
from
my table name that is employees
i'll write where
salary is greater than
i'll start my
opening bracket inside the bracket i'm
going to give my inner query that is
select
salary
from employees
where
the employee name is
john
so within
single quotations i'll give john as my
employee
i'll end with a semicolon
so
let me first run my inner query
so this will give us the salary that
john has which is 67 000
now i want the employees who are earning
more than 67 000
so let's run our
sub query
okay so you can see
12 rows returned which means there are
12 employees in our table who are
earning more than sixty seven thousand
dollars you see here
all these employees have a salary
greater than sixty seven thousand
dollars
okay
now
you can also use sub queries
with two different tables so suppose you
want to display some information that
are present in two different tables you
can use sub queries to do that
so
for this example we'll use
a
database that is called classic models
you can see the first database
so let me use this database called
classic models i'll write use classic
models
now this database was actually
downloaded from the internet there's a
very nice website i'll just show you the
website name so this is the website that
is mysql tutorial.org
you can see here they have
very nice
articles
blogs from where you can learn
my sequel in detail
so we have
downloaded the database that is classic
models from this website you see here
they have a mysql sample database if you
click on this
it will take you to the link where you
can download the database so they have
this download link which says download
mysql sample database
and the name of the databases classic
models
all right
so we are going to use this classic
models database throughout our demo
session
if i expand the tables
section you can see there are a lot of
tables that are present inside this
classic models database we have cricket
customers as employees
offers this orders order lines and many
more
so for our sub query we'll be using two
tables that is order details and
products table
first let me show you the content that
is present inside
the products table first
if i run this
you see here it says 110 rows returned
which means there are 110
different products that are present in
our table which has the product code the
product name
product line
we have the product vendor
description quantity in stock by price
msrp
the other table we are going to use is
order details which has the
details of all the orders
let me show you
the records
order details tables has
okay so there are thousand records
present in this table you have the order
number the product code quantity ordered
price of each item you have the order
line number as well
okay
now
we want to know the product code the
product name
and the msrp of the products whose price
of each product is less than hundred
dollars
for this
scenario we are going to use two
different tables and we are going to
write a sub query
okay
so
if you see here
in the order details table we have a
column called price each
i want to display the product code the
product name and the msrp of the
products which have a price of each
product less than hundred dollars
so the way i'm going to do is
i'll write select
product code
comma product name
now one thing to remember
that this product name is actually
present inside our products table
and product code is present in both the
tables that is products and order
details here you can see this is the
product code column
comma
msrp which is present inside the
products table again
from my table that is
products
where
i'll write
product
code
i'm going to use the in operator
next i'll write my inner query that is
select
product
code
from
my table
order details
where
my price of each product
is less than
100
let me run this
okay so you can see
there are total 83 products in our table
which have
a price
less than hundred dollars you can see
the
price here
okay
now
we learn another advanced concept in sql
which is known as stored procedures
i'll just give a comment saying
stored procedure
okay
so first let's understand what is a
stored procedure
a stored procedure is an sql code that
you can save so that the code can be
reused over and over again
so if you want to write a query over and
over again
save it as a stored procedure and then
call it to execute it
so in this example i want to create a
stored procedure
that will return the list of players who
have scored more than six goals in a
tournament
so i have a database called
sql underscore iq
these are a few databases that have
already created so this database has a
table called players if i expand the
tables
option you see we have a table called
players and
you can see the columns player id the
name of the player the country to which
the player belongs to
and the number of goals each player has
scored in a particular tournament
so i'll write a stored procedure that
will return the list of
top players who have scored more than 6
goals in a tournament
so first of all let me begin by
using mysql underscore iq database
we'll run it
so now we are inside the sql underscore
iq database
let me
select
star from players to show the
values that we have in the players table
you can see there are
six players in our table
we have the player id
the names of the players the country to
which these players belong to and the
goals they have scored
so i'll write a stored procedure
so the stored procedure syntax is
something like this
it should
start with a delimiter
okay
in the delimiter i'll write
amberson amber send
next i'll write
create
procedure
followed by
the procedure name
let's say i want to
name my procedure as top underscore
players
next statement is begin
after begin i'll write my select
statement
i want to select the name of the player
the country
and the goals
each player has scored
from
my table that is
players
where
i'll write goals is greater than
6
will give a semicolon
then
i'll end my
procedure with a
delimiter
that was double ampersand
next
i'll write
delimiter
and give
a semicolon
now the semicolon suggests
this is a default delimiter
and there should be a space okay
now let's run our
stored procedure
there you go so you have successfully
created our stored procedure
now the way to run a stored procedure is
you need to use the
call method and give the procedure name
that is top underscore place in our case
with brackets and a semicolon
let's execute it
okay there is some problem here
so we made a mistake while creating a
procedure
the name of the column is goals and not
goal
let me create that procedure again
okay it says the procedure top
underscore player already exists let's
just
edit the procedure name instead of top
player we'll write it as top players and
similarly we'll edit here as well
now let's create it again
okay
now to
call my procedure i'll write call
space followed by the procedure name
which is top underscore clears
if i run this you can see
we have two players in our table who
have scored more than six goals so we
consider them as the top list in a
particular tournament
all right
now
there are other methods that you can use
while creating a stored procedure
one of the methods is by using an in
parameter
so when you define an in parameter
inside a stored procedure the calling
program has to pass an argument to the
stored procedure
so i'll give a comment
stored procedure using in parameter
all right
so for this example i'll create a
procedure that will fetch or display the
top records of employees
based on their salaries
so we have a table
in our sql underscore iq database which
is called employee details
i am going to use this table you can see
we have the name of the employee the age
sex then we have the date of join city
and salary
using this table i'll create a procedure
that will fetch or display the top
records of employees based on their
salaries
and we'll use the in parameter
so let me show you how to do it
i'll write
delimiter
this time i'm going to use
forward
slash i'll write
create
procedure
followed by the procedure name let's say
sp for stored procedure
sort
by
salary is the name of my procedure
and inside this procedure i'll give my
parameter
in
i'll create a variable var and assign a
data type integer
then i'll write begin
followed by my select statement where
i'll select the name
age
salary
from
my table name that is
emp details or employee details
i am going to order this by
salary
descending
and
i want to
display
limited number of
records so i am using this
limit keyword and my variable var which
i
created here
i'll end my select statement
i'll end my stored procedure with
forward slash
and i'll go back to my default delimiter
that is semicolon
all right
so let me
run this
there should be a space here
all right
so let's run this
okay you can see we have successfully
created our second stored procedure
which is sp underscore sort by salary
now you can also check whether the
stored procedure was created or not
here
you have an option
to see
the stored procedures let me just
refresh this
and you can see we have
three stored procedures that we have
created so far one is sp underscore sort
by salary
the other two were top underscore player
and top underscore players
okay
now let's call our store procedure i'll
write call
space followed by the stored procedure
name which is sp underscore
sort
by
salary
and inside this i'll give my parameter
which was actually var and this var
we have used in
limit
let's say i want to display only the top
three records of the employees
who have the top three highest salaries
okay so let me run it
there you go so ami sara and jimmy were
the
top three employees who have the highest
salary
so you saw how you could use
the in parameter in a stored procedure
we created a variable and that variable
we used in our select statement
and we called our stored procedure and
passed in that
variable
okay
now
instead of a select
statement inside a stored procedure you
can also use
other statements let's say
update
so i'll create a stored procedure to
update the salary of a particular
employee
so in this procedure instead of select
statement we'll use the update command
in this example we'll use the
in operator twice
so let me show you how to do it
i'll write my delimiter first which is
going to be
forward slash
then i'll write create
procedure
my name of the procedure is going to be
update salary
and inside the
update salary name
i'll write in
and then
temp
underscore name which will be a
temporary name variable and the type
i'll assign is varchar 20
i'll again use my in parameter i'll
write in
next
my other variable would be new
underscore salary
and the data type would be float
i'll write begin
and write my update
command or update statement i'll write
update
table name that is employee details
set
salary
equal to
new underscore salary
where
name
is equal to
my temporary variable that is temp
underscore name
so this is my
update command and i'll
end the delimiter
all right
so let's run this
okay we have successfully created our
stored procedure
if i repress this
you can see i have my stored procedure
update underscore salary
okay
now let's say
first of all i'll
display
my
records that are present inside
employee underscore details table
okay so we have six rows of information
let's say you want to update the
salary of employee
jimmy or let's say
mary
from 70 000 to
let's say 72 000
or let's say
80 000
so i'll
call my stored procedure that is update
underscore salary
and this time i'm going to pass in
two parameters the first parameter will
be the
employee name
and next with a comma i'll give my new
salary that i want to
so my
employee name let's say is
mary
and the salary i want
to be updated is let's say eighty
thousand dollars
i'll give a semicolon
and i'll run it
you can see it says one row affected now
let's check our table once again
there you go
if you see this
record
for mary we have successfully updated
the salary to 80 000
now moving ahead
we learn to create a stored procedure
using the out parameter
so i'll give a comment
stored procedure using out parameter
okay
so suppose we want to get the count of
total female employees
we will create total employees as an
output parameter and the data type would
be an integer
the count of the female employees is
assigned to the output variable which is
total underscore emps using the into
keyword
let me show you how to write a stored
procedure using the out parameter
so first i'll declare my delimiter
to forward slash
i'll write
create
procedure
followed by the procedure name
it is going to be sp underscore
count
employees
and inside this i am going to give my
out parameter
and the variable name that is total
underscore
emps which is total employees and the
data type will be integer
next i am going to write
begin
followed by
my select statement that is select
i want the
count of total employees
and the output i am going to put into
my new variable that is total underscore
emps
from my table that is emp underscore
details
where
sex
is equal to
f which means
female
i'll give a semicolon
next
i'll end it
with the dv limiter and i am going to
change the delimiter to a default
delimiter that is
colon
so let me tell you what i am doing here
i am creating a new stored procedure
that is sp underscore count employees
using this stored procedure i am going
to count the total number of female
employees that are present in our table
emp underscore details so i've used my
out parameter and i'm creating a new
variable called total underscore emps
the data type is
here in the select statement i am
counting the names of the employees
and the result i am storing it in total
underscore emps
i have
used my where condition where the gender
or the sex is female
so let's run this
okay so we have created our stored
procedure
let's
refresh this
okay you can see we have our new stored
procedure
sp underscore count employees
now
to call it i'll write call
the name of the procedure that is count
underscore
sp underscore count
employees
within brackets i'll pass in the
parameter as
at the rate
f underscore emp
i'll give a semicolon
then i'll write
select
add the rate
f underscore
emp as
female employees
okay
so as is an alias name
let's run this one by one first i'll
call my procedure and then we'll display
the total number of female employees you
can see in our table we have three
female employees
all right
now with this understanding
let's move on to our next topic in this
tutorial on advanced sql
now we are going to learn about triggers
in sql
so i'll give a
comment here
triggers in sql
so first let's understand what is a
trigger
so a trigger is a special type of stored
procedure that runs automatically when
an event occurs in the database server
now there are mainly three types of
triggers in sql we have the data
manipulation trigger we have the data
definition trigger and login triggers
in this example we will learn how to use
a before insert trigger
so we will create a simple students
table that will have the student's role
number the age
the name and the students marks
so before inserting the records to our
table we'll check if the marks are less
than zero
so in case the marks are less than zero
our trigger will automatically set the
marks to a random value let's say 50.
so let's go ahead and create our
table that is
students
all right
so i'll write
create
table
student
now this table will have the student
role number
the data type is integer
it will have the age of the students
again the data type is integer we have
the
names of the students so the third
column would be name
the data type would be variable
or varying character
size i am giving it as 30
finally we have the marks as floating
type
so let's create this table which is
student
so we have created our table
now
i'll write my
trigger command
so trigger command will start with
delimiter like how our usual stored
procedures have
next
this time i'll write create trigger
then you need to give the
name of the trigger that is mark
underscore
let's say verify
i am going to use a before insert
trigger so i'll write before
insert
on my table name that is student
next i'll write for
each
row
if
new dot
marks
is less than zero
then
we'll set
new dot
marks
equal to 50
so this is my
condition first we'll check
before inserting if any student has
marks less than 0 will assign a value 50
to that student because
usually the marks are not less than 0 in
any exam
i'll write end if
semicolon and i'll close the delimiter
so this is my
trigger command i'll run it
it says trigger already exists
in this case we need to update the
trigger name let's say
i'll write marks underscore verify
underscore
student for st
let's run it again
okay there is an error here because
in our table the column name is mark and
not marks
so here we need to change it as mark
instead of marks
all right
let's run it
okay so we have created a trigger
now
let me insert
a few
records to the student table
so i'll write insert into student
i'll write
values
i'll give the values as
501 which is the student roll number the
age is let's say 10
the name is let's say ruth
and the marks is let's say 75.0
give a comma we'll insert our second
student record
student role number is 502
age is 12
the name is let's say mike
and this time i'm purposely giving a
value of minus 20.5
give another comma we'll insert the
third
record
for student role number 503
age is 13
the name is dave
and
let's say the marks obtained by dave is
90
now we'll insert our final record for
student number
504
the age is 10
neem i'll enter as jacobs
and this time again i'm purposely
giving the marks in negative
12 point let's say 5.
close the bracket
and give a semicolon
and i'll run my insert statement okay so
we have
inserted four rows of information to our
student table
now
let me run
the select query i'll write select star
from student
if i run this you see the difference
there you go
so
originally we had inserted
for 502 the marks was minus
20.5 and for 504
for jacobs the marks was minus 12.5
our trigger automatically converted the
negative marks to 50 because
when we created our trigger we had set
our marks to 50 in case the marks were
less than zero
so this is how a trigger works
now you can also
drop a trigger or delete a trigger you
can just write drop trigger followed by
the trigger name
in this case our trigger name is
marks underscore verify underscore st
i'll just paste this here
and if you run this it will
automatically delete your trigger
you give this as a comment
okay
now moving on
now we are going to learn about another
crucial concept in sql which is very
widely used
this is known as views
so views are actually virtual tables
that do not store any data of their own
but display data stored in other tables
views are created by joining one or more
tables
i'll give a
comment as views in sql
okay
now
to learn views i am going to use my
table which is
present inside classic models database
now this database as i mentioned we had
downloaded
we had downloaded it from the internet
so first of all let me write
use
classic models so i'll switch my
database first
all right now we are inside classic
models
so here let me show you one of the
tables which is called customers so i'll
write select star from customers
okay
i missed s here
let's run it again so this is my
customer table which is present inside
classic models database it has the
contact last name the contact first name
the customer name
customer number we have the address
state country and other
information now i'll write a basic view
command
using this customer table
the way to write is i'll write create
view
followed by the view name which is cust
underscore details
then you write as
select
i am going to select a few
column names from my original customer
table which is this one so i need the
customer name
let's say i need the phone number
and the city so you have this
information here you have the phone
number
and the
city
all right
i'll write from my table that is
customers
if i run this
my view that is cust details will be
created
let's run it
there's some error here because the name
of the table is customers and not
customer
i'll give an s and i'll run it again
all right so you can see we have created
our view
and
to display the contents that are present
inside our view i can write select star
from followed by the view name that is
cursed underscore details
let's run it
there you go so we have the customer
name
the phone number and the city of the
different customers that we have in our
table
all right
now let's learn how you can create views
using joins so we'll join two different
tables and create a view
so for that i am going to use my
products table and the products lines
table
i am talking about the products table
and the product lines table present
inside classic
models database
so before i start let me display the
records that are present inside the
products table
run it so these are the different
products you can see here
now let's see what we have in product
lines table
so we have the product line the text
description and there's some html
description and image
so
i'll create a view by joining these two
tables and will fetch specific records
that are present in both the tables
so let me first start by writing
create
view
followed by the view name that is
product underscore
description
as
i'll write
select
product
name
comma
then i'll write
quantity
in stock
i also want the msrp
now these three columns
are present inside the products table
and next from the
product lines table i want the text
description
of the products
so i'll write from
products table
i'll give an alias as p
followed by inner join
my other table that is
product lines as let's say pl
on
the common column that is product line
so p dot
product
line
is equal to
i'll give a space
pl dot
product line
okay
so here we have used an inner join to
fetch specific columns from both the
tables
and our view name is product underscore
description
let us run it all right so we have our
view ready
now let me
view or display what is present inside
our product underscore description
view
and select star from
product underscore description
let's run it
there you go so we have the product name
the quantity in stock msrpn
textual descriptions of the different
products in the table
okay
now there are a few other operations
that you can perform let's say you want
to rename a view
instead of product underscore
description you want to give some other
name
so i'll just give a comment rename
description
so to rename a description you can use
the
rename statement i'll write rename table
product
underscore description which is my
old name
i want to change this name to let's say
i'll give vehicle description since
all our products are related to some of
the other vehicle so i'll write vehicle
description
okay
let us run it
all right so here you can see i have
renamed my
view
so here if i just refresh it
and i'll expand this you can see we have
the cursed details view and we have the
vehicle underscore description view
okay
now either you can view all the views
from this panel
or you can use a command let's say
i'll write display views
is the comment
now to show all the views you can use
show
full tables
where
table underscore
type is equal to within single quote
i'll write view
so this is the command that will display
all the views that are present inside a
database
there is some
error here let's debug the error
this should be
okay so instead of table types it should
be table type equal to view
let's run it
you can see the two different views that
we have one is customer details another
is vehicle underscore description
okay
now you can also go ahead and delete a
view
for that you can use the drop command
so i'll write drop
view followed by the view name let's say
i want to delete
customer underscore details or cast
underscore details view
i'll write drop view cust underscore
details
let's run it
you can see
here we don't have the cost underscore
details view anymore
all right
now moving to our final section in this
demo
here we will learn
about windows functions
the windows functions were incorporated
in mysql in the 8.0 version
so windows function in mysql are useful
applications in solving analytical
problems so using the employees table
present inside my sql underscore intro
database so we will find the total
combined salary of the employees for
each department
so
first let me switch my database to sql
underscore
intro database
i'll run it okay
i'll display my table
that is employee
so here we have 20 employees in our
table
using this table
we are going to find the combined salary
of the employees for each department so
we will partition our table by
department and print the total salary
and this we are going to do using
some windows functions in mysql
so i'll write
select
i want the employee name
the age of the employee
and the department of the employee
comma next i'll write
the sum of salary
over
i want to partition it by
department
i'll write partition by department which
is dept
and i'll give an alias as
total salary
so that it will create a new column with
the name total salary
from my table that is employees
the output will be a little different
this time
let's execute it and see the result
there you go
so here we have created another column
in our result that is total salary and
for each of the
employees and the respective departments
we have the highest salary so in finance
the highest salary of one of the
employees was
155 000
similarly if i come down we have the
highest salary from hr
if i scroll further we have the highest
salary from it marketing product sales
and
the tech team
all right
now we'll explore
a function which is called row number
now the row number function gives a
sequential integer to every row within
its partition
so let me show you how to
use the row number function
i'll write select
row underscore number function
over
my
column would be
salary so i'll write order by salary
i'll give the
alias as ro num
give a comma
and i want to display the employee name
and the salary of the employee
from my table that is employees
and i'll order by
salary
so let's see how
our row number function will create
sequential integers okay you can see
here we have a row num column and we
have
successfully given row numbers to each
of the records you can see it starts
from 1 and goes up till 20.
okay
now this row number function can be used
to find duplicate values in a table
to show that first i'll create a table
i'll write create table let's say i'll
give a random name that is demo
and let's say we have in this table the
student id which is of type integer and
we have the student
name
which is of type
var car
the size is 20
i'll create
the small table with a few records
let's create this table first
now we are going to insert a few records
to our demo table so i'll write insert
into
demo
values
i'll give 101
the name is
shane give a comma
i'll insert the second student name 102
the name is
bradley
we'll give a comma
this time
for 103 we have
two records
let's say the name of the student is
herat
we give a comma i'll copy this
and we'll paste it again so we have
duplicated 103
next we have 104
the name of the student let's say is
nathan
then again let's say for
the fifth student
which is kevin we have
two records
i'll copy this
and i'll paste it here
let me give a semicolon and we'll insert
these records to our table demo
all right
now
let me just
run this table for you i'll write
select star from demo
if you see this
we have a few information that are
duplicated in our table
that is for student id 103 and student
id
105
now i am going to use my
row number function to find the
duplicate
records present in my table i'll write
select student underscore id comma
student underscore name
i'll give another comma and write
row underscore
number
over
within brackets
i'll write partition
by
st underscore id
comma
st underscore name
okay
then i'll write
order by
st underscore id
close the bracket i'll give an alias as
row number
from my table that is demo
let's just run it
you can see here
okay
let me just
delete n from here and do it again
all right now if you see here there is
just one student in the name shane we
have one student in the name
bradley
but here if you see for hereth
the second record it says two which
means there are two records for hirath
and if i scroll down there is one record
for nathan and there are two records for
kevin which means kevin is also repeated
okay
now
we are going to see another windows
function that is called rank function
in mysql
so the rank function assigns a rank to a
particular column
now there are gaps in the sequence of
ranked values when two or more rows have
the same rank
so first of all let me create a table
and the name of the table would be
a random name we'll give it as let's say
demo1
and it will have only one
column let's say variable a of type
integer
we'll create this table first
okay
now let's go ahead and insert a few
records to our
table which is demo one so i'll write
value
one zero one
one zero two
let's say one zero three is repeated
i'm doing this purposely so that in the
output you can
clearly distinguish what the rank
function does
next we have one zero four
one zero five
we have 106
and let's say 106 is also repeated
finally we have
107
okay let me insert these values to my
table that is demo one okay this is done
now
if i write
select
var underscore and
use my
rank function i'll write rank
over
then i'll
order by
my variable that is var underscore a
as
an alias name let's say test rank
from
my table that is demo1
let me execute this and show you how the
rank function works
now if i run this
there you go
so here if you mark
so for variable
a101
the test rank is 1 for one zero two the
test tank is two but
for this value which is one zero three
the test rank is repeated because there
was a repetition for one zero three
so we have skipped the rank four here
for one zero four the rank is five now
for one zero five the rank is six now
for one zero six again since the record
was repeated twice
we have skipped the eighth rank and
our rank function has signed the same
value which is seven for one zero six
and for the last value one zero seven
the rank is
nine
all right
now moving ahead we'll see
our final windows function which is
called
first value
so first value is another important
function in
mysql so this function returns the value
of the specified expression with respect
to the
first row in the window frame
all right
so what i'm going to do is
i'm going to select
the employee name
the age and salary
and i'll write
first underscore
value which is my function
and pass in my employee name
and then i'll write over
order by
my
column that is salary descending
i'll give an alias as highest underscore
salary
from my table that is
employees
so let me run this and see how the
first
underscore value function works
all right so in our table
joseph was the employee who had the
highest salary which was
115 000
so
the first value function populated the
same
employee name throughout the table you
can see it here
now you can also use the first
underscore value function
over the partition
so let's say you want to display the
employee name who has the highest salary
in each department so for that you can
use the partition
i'll write select emp underscore name
comma
i want the department
and the salary
comma
i'll use my function that is first
underscore
value
followed by
the name of the employee inside my first
value parameter
i'll write
over
here i'm going to use partition
i'm going to partition it by
department
since i want to know the employee name
who has the highest salary in each
department
and i am going to order by
salary
descending
and i will give my alias again as
highest salary
from
my table that is employees
so let's
run this and see the difference in the
output
okay
so as you can see here
we have
the employee who had the highest salary
from each department so for finance
jack had the highest salary from hr it
was
marcus
similarly in it it was william
if i scroll down for marketing it was
john for product it was
alice who had the highest salary
similarly in sales we had joshua
and in tech we had angela
so this is how you can use the first
underscore value function using
partition
all right
so that brings us to the end of this
demo session on our
tutorial
so let me just scroll through and show
you what we did from the beginning first
we learnt about sub queries in
sql so we initially wrote a
simple sub query and then we used our
classic models database which was
downloaded from the internet and also
shown you the link from where you can
download this database here we used two
different tables and we performed a sub
query operation
we learnt how to create stored
procedures
so we learnt how you can use the in
operator or the in parameter as well as
the out parameter in stored procedure
after stored procedure we learned
another
crucial concept in sql which is called
triggers now triggers are also special
kind of stored procedures so we saw how
to
write a before insert trigger you can
see it here
next
we learned how to
delete a trigger
we also saw how to work with views in
sql so views are basically virtual
tables that you can create from existing
tables
we also saw how you can use views using
two different tables and an inner join
and
we learnt how to display views how to
rename
view names how to delete a view and
finally we explored a few windows
function
in this tutorial we will learn how to
work with databases and tables using sql
with python
to do this demo we will be using our
jupyter notebook and the mysql workbench
you can see it here
so we will write our sql queries in the
jupyter notebook with python like syntax
if you don't have mysql or jupyter
notebook installed so please go ahead
and install them first
while installing the mysql workbench you
will be asked to give the username and
password let me show you
so i am on my mysql workbench so once
you connect it will ask for the username
and the password so i have given my
username as root and password you can
give
while installing it
we will be using the same user id or the
username and the password to make our
connection
so let's get started with our hands-on
demonstration part
first and foremost let me go ahead and
import the necessary libraries
i'll give a comment as import libraries
all right
so first
i'll import
mysql dot connector
next
from
mysql dot connector
i am going to import
my error
method or the error module
next
i want to import
pandas as pd
so let's run this
okay there is some error here
this should be capital e and not small e
all right
you can see i have imported my important
libraries
now
i'm going to create a function
that will help us
create a server connection
so i'll write my user defined function
by using the def keyword
i'll write create underscore
server underscore connection
this is going to be my
function name
and it will take in
three parameters first is the host name
next is the username
and then we have the user password
all right
i'll give a colon
and then
in the next line i'm going to define a
variable
which is going to be connection and i'll
assign it to a value called none
now we'll be using exceptional handling
techniques to connect to our mysql
server
the try block lets you test a block of
code for errors and the accept block
will handle the errors
so i'll write
try and give a colon
and then
i'm going to reassign the connection
variable
to a method which is
mysql dot
connector
dot connect
now this mysql connector dot connect
method sets up a connection so it
establishes a session with the mysql
server if no arguments are passed it
uses the already configured or default
values
so here
we are going to pass in
three parameters the first is the
hostname
i'll write host
equal to
hostname which is host underscore name
i'll give a comma
then i'll write
user
equal to user underscore name
next will be my
password
and
i'll assign the value user underscore
password
all right
now
i'm going to
use a print statement
and write
mysql
database
connection
successful
after this i'll give my
accept block
so i'll use the keyword accept
here
i'll write error as
err
give a colon and then i am going to use
the print statement
here i am going to use some
print formatting techniques using the f
letter
i'll write error colon
and i'll use curly braces
give err
and then
i'll close the
double quotes
after this
i'm going to
return
my connection
all right
let me give a comment here
we are going to assign our password
so we need to put our
mysql
terminal password
so this password you assign it while
installing mysql workbench
i'll write
p
w
and i'll give my password which is
simply
at the rate one two three four five
and
then i'm going to
give my database
name so i'll give
database
name
here
i'm going to write
db
equal to this is the database i want to
create which is going to be
mysql underscore python
let me just scroll this down
okay
now
i'll say
connection
equal to
i'll pass in my
user defined function name which is
create
server connection
and the
parameters which are going to be
localhost that is my
hostname
my username which is root and then i'll
give pw
which is my password that is exactly
simply at the rate one two three four
five
let's just run it now
okay
there is an error here we need to remove
this double quotation
all right
made another mistake here this this
should be root
okay you can see here mysql database
connection successful
all right next
we are now going to create a database
that is mysql underscore python so i'll
give a comment create
mysql underscore
python
database
again to create this database i am going
to create another user defined function
using the def keyword
i'll write
the function name as create
database
passing the parameters as connection
comma
query
give a semicolon
and in the next line
i'll write cursor equal to
i'm going to make the connection so i'll
write connection dot
cursor
and i'll give the parenthesis
so this mysql's cursor of mysql
connector python is used to execute
statements to communicate with the mysql
database the mysql cursor class
initiates objects that can execute
operations such as the mysql statements
okay
next
i'm going to again use my
try and accept block so i'll write
try
give a colon and here i'm going to use
cursor dot
execute
within that i'm going to pass in my
query
next i'll use a print statement
and the message i am going to display is
database
created
successfully
after this
i'm going to write my accept block
i'll write accept
error as
err
give a colon
and then i'll use a print statement i'll
write print
i'll use the
formatting again
error
colon
and i'll write
within single codes i'll give curly
braces
err and then i'll close the double
quotes
next
let's
use the variable
to create
underscore
database
underscore query
and
here i am going to write my
sql query to create the database so i
will write create
database
and followed by that i'll give my
database name which is going to be mysql
underscore python
okay
after this
i'll call my function which is create
database
and i'll pass in the parameters the
first one is
connection
and next
the query is create underscore database
underscore query let me just copy it
and i'm going to paste it here
all right so what i am doing here is
i am creating a new function
that is to create a new database with
the name
mysql
underscore python which you can see it
here
now this function takes in two
parameters connection and query
i am using the connection dot cursor
function which is often used to execute
sql statements using
python language and then i have
created my try and excerpt blocks
so this try block statements will try to
create my new database which is mysql
underscore python
in case it fails to create the new
database
the excel block will work so here i am
writing my sql query to create a new
database which is create database
followed by the database name and i am
assigning it to a variable which is
create database query and then i am
calling my function create database and
passing in the two parameters connection
and
the query
all right
so let's just run it
all right you can see here it has
created my database successfully
now
you can verify this by checking the
mysql workbench or the mysql shell
you can see on the mysql workbench here
on the
left panel under schemas there is a
database called mysql underscore python
let me just expand it now we haven't
created any table so it's not showing it
now
the next step we are going to connect to
this database
so let's go ahead and connect to our
database that we have just created i'll
write the comment as connect to
database
now to connect to a database i'm again
going to create a user defined function
using the def keyword i'll write create
underscore
db which is for database underscore
connection
and the parameters it will take is the
host name
followed by the user name
then we have the user password
and finally we have the
database name
i'll give a colon
in the next line i'm going to create my
variable
which is connection and then i'll assign
it to a value
none
after this i'm going to use my
exception handling techniques so i'll
write my try block first
i'm going to reassign my connection
variable
using the
mysql connector method so i'll write
mysql dot
connector dot
connect
so this method
will take in the
parameters
so first
it will take the
host name
i'll write
host equal to
host underscore name
i'll give a comma
next it will take the
user name so user equal to user
underscore name
give another comma
next
it will take the user password
i'll use pass wd equal to
user underscore password
we'll give another comma
and this time
it is going to be the database name so
i'll write database equal to db
underscore name
now
let's use the print statement
and the message we are going to print is
mysql
database
connection
successful
all right
finally
we'll write my
accept block
i'll write
accept
error as err
give a colon and then i'll use the print
statement
f
within double quotes i'll write error
colon
within single quotes curly braces i'll
write err
and will close the double quotes
finally
this function
will return
the connection value
all right
let's run it and there you go
it has run successfully so we have
connected to our database
now
it's time for us to execute sql queries
i'll give another comment saying
execute
sql queries
all right
now to execute our sql queries i'll use
another user defined function which is
execute
underscore
query
and i'll pass in the parameters as
connection and
query
give a colon
i'm going to write
cursor
equal to
connection dot cursor
now this is used to establish a
connection and run sql statements
next we'll use the
try and accept block so i'll write try
cursor
dot execute
this will take in one parameter which is
going to be my query
and then i'll write
connection
dot
commit
which is another method
now let's use the print statement
so i'll write
print
let's say the message would be
query
was successful
and then
we'll write our accept block which is
accept
if the try block doesn't work throw an
error
using the print statement
within double quotes inside the
inside the curly braces i'll write err
and close the double quotes
all right so let's run it
okay so we have successfully created our
various functions that were needed to
create a database establish a connection
and to execute our queries
all right
now it's time for us to create our first
table inside the mysql underscore python
database
so to do that
i am going to write my
create command in sql
so first we are going to assign our sql
command to a python variable using
triple quotes to create a multi-line
string so let me show you how to do that
i'll write my
variable name
which is going to be create
orders
table
it is always recommended to use relevant
variable names to make it more readable
and now
i am going to use triple quotes
so the triple quote
will ensure
i can create my multiline string
inside the triple quote i am going to
write my
create command which is create table
here i am going to create an orders
table first
and
inside the orders table i am going to
create my
column names the first column would be
the order id
it is going to be of type integer and
i'll assign this order id as my primary
key column
will give a comma
next
the second column would be
customer
underscore name
the customer name column would be of
type
varying character so i'll write var car
and i'll give a size of 30
and
this is also going to be
not null
moving ahead my fourth column would be
the product name column
so i'll write product underscore name
product name will be of type
varying character the size is let's say
20
and it is also not null
next
i am going to create my
fourth column which is the date on which
the item was ordered or the product was
ordered
so i'll write date ordered the data type
will be date
next
i'll create
a quantity column to keep track of the
number of quantities that were ordered
this is of type
integer
my next column would be unit price which
will basically have information about
the price of each unit of product
unit price can be of type float
and finally i'll have the
phone number of the customer
i'll write phone number phone number can
be kept as of type varying character
i have assigned a size of
20. now let's give a semicolon and
we'll
close the
triple quotes
all right
so this is how the syntax would look
like
next
to run this we are first going to
call our createdb function so let me
give a comment as
connect to the database
i'll write connection
equal to
create underscore db underscore
connection
my parameters would be
my host name which is localhost
my username which is root
comma my password
and then my database name which is
mysql underscore python so i'll write
just db
all right
finally let's execute this query using
the execute underscore
query function that we have created
earlier
this takes in two parameter the first
one is connection
followed by
the variable name which is create
orders underscore table
let us run it
okay there is some error here let's see
what's the error
okay so here we have put four
double quotes this should be triple
quotes now let's run it
okay there is another here let's debug
it
it says name cursor not defined
let me just roll it to the above cell if
you see here in our
execute underscore query
function instead of
cursor
i have written cursor so r is missing
let's re-run this
and now let's run this again
there you go you can see here mysql
database connection successful even our
query was also successful
now if you want to recheck if the table
that is orders was created or not you
can check it on the mysql workbench so
let me show you how to do it so i am on
my mysql workbench and under mysql
underscore python database you have
something called as tables let me just
right click and i'll select
refresh all there you go you can see
this arrow just click on this arrow
and here you can see we have a table
called orders so we have created a table
called orders
now you can check the columns as well
you have the order id you have the order
id the customer name product name
ordered
date quantity unit price and phone
number
now it's time for us to insert a few
records to this table which is orders
now to insert records i'll give a
comment as insert
data
i'll start with the
variable name let's say the variable
name is data underscore
orders
i'll give triple quotes
next
i'll write my insert into command so
i'll write insert
into
my table name that is orders
followed by
values
and now i'll start entering
my records for each of the rows so first
i'll give 101 which is the order id
then i'll give the
customer's name let's say steve
and the product he had ordered is let's
say laptop
then i'll give my date in which the item
was ordered
let's say it is 2018
i'll choose
0 6 as the month and the date is let's
say 12.
we'll give another comma this time we'll
pass in the quantity which is 2
let's say the price of each
number this laptop random let's say 6 2
let's say
802
all right similarly i am going to insert
five more records of different customers
and their items that they have purchased
to this table orders
so here on my notepad i have my rest of
the five records let me just copy it and
we'll paste it in the cell here this
will save us some time
okay
let me recheck if everything is fine
i'll give a comma here all right so we
have
six customers in our table which have
their customer ids from 101 to 106. you
have steve
jaws stacy nancy maria and danny you
have the different items they have
purchased laptop books trousers t-shirts
headphones and smart tv is the date on
which they had ordered this item the
number of quantities they had ordered
and then we have the unit price and some
random phone numbers
so let's
create the connection now i'll write
connection
equal to
i'll write create
underscore db underscore connection
then i'm going to give my same
parameters let me just copy it from the
top which is localhost
the host name
root is my username then we have
password and the database name
and then
i'll use the same query as above which
is execute query
i'll copy this
paste it here and instead of create
orders table variable i'll put as data
underscore orders
so this will store my
insert into command you can see the
variable i have used here is data
underscore orders
now it's time let's just run it
all right
there was some mistake here let's debug
it
again this would be triple quotes and
not
four now let me rerun it again there you
go you can see here mysql database
connection successful and my query was
also successful
now
we'll create
another user defined function which will
help us read query and display the
results
so i'll write
my function name as
df
read underscore
query
this will take in two parameters
connection and query
then i'll write
cursor
equal to
connection dot cursor
i'll put my
result as none
and then i'll use my
try and accept block i'll write try
cursor dot
execute
this will take in one parameter which is
query
and then i'll
give another variable which is result
equal to
cursor dot
fetch
all now this fetch all method
will return
all the
results in the table
i'll write
return
result
next
we'll use the accept block
so i'll write
accept
error as err give a colon and i'll use
my print statement
scroll this down
i'll use my formatting f
error
give a colon followed by a space
within single quotes
inside curly priestess i will give err
and close my double quotes
let's run it
all right
so now we are all set
now we are going to use our select
clause having whereby
then we'll see how to use order by
clause
some inbuilt functions will update some
records delete some records and do a lot
of other stuff
so
let's start with our first query
so our first query is going to be
using the
select statement
all right so suppose
i want to display all the records that
we have inserted into our orders table
so the way to do is
i'll
assign my query to a variable let's say
q1
i'll give
triple quotes
within triple quotes i'll write select
star from orders
we'll give a semicolon followed by the
triple quotes
now we'll establish the connection so
let me just go to the top
and i'll copy this line
which is to connect to our database
i'll paste it here
now we'll
create a variable called results that
will store the result of this query
and we are going to assign this variable
to
our function that is read query and this
read query will have
two parameters the connection and the
variable name which is q1 for the query
next to display i am going to use a for
loop i'll write for
results
for result
in
results
print
i'll say result
now we are done
let's just run this query
there you go you can see here you have
successfully printed
all the rows in our table which is
orders you can see we have six records
in total
now we are going to explore a few more
queries so let me just copy this and we
are going to edit in the same query
i'll paste it here
next
let's say you want to display
individual columns from the table and
not all the columns so let me
let me create the variable q2
now instead of star i'm going to display
only the customer name
and let's see the phone numbers of the
customer so i'll write phone underscore
number
all right the rest all remains the same
let me just recheck it and here instead
of
q1 we'll put q2
and
let's run this cell all right you can
see here now we have displayed only two
columns the first column is the customer
name and then we have the respective
phone numbers
okay
now let me just paste that query again
now we are going to see how you can use
an inbuilt function
that is
in our table we have the
order date and from the order date we
are only going to
display the different years that are
present in the order date so to do that
i am going to use the year function
i'll add this query instead of q1 i'll
make it q3
and here i am going to write select
here which is my function name from my
column which is date ordered
from orders and here i'll change this to
q3
q1 q2 q3 are basically query 1 query 2
and query 3 let's run it
there you go so we have successfully
extracted the different years present in
the order date column
now if you want to display the distinct
or the unique dates present in the
column
you can
use the extent keyword in the select
statement
so the way to do it is i'll write select
distinct
give a space
the rest of the query remains the same
and here in q3 i'll write q4
i'll make this as q4
let's run it
you can see 2018 and 2019 are the unique
year values that are present in the
order date column
okay
now moving ahead
let's write our fifth query and this
time we are going to explore how you can
use the where clause
so i'll change this to q5
before i write my query
so let's say you want to display all the
orders
that were ordered before
31st of december 2018.
so to filter this we are going to use
the where clause
so i'll write select
star
from orders
next i'll write where
my date underscore ordered
is less than
within course i'll give my date value
which is 2018 december
31st
so all the items or the products that
were ordered before 31st of december
2018 will be displayed so let's run it
all right you can see here there are
three orders in our table which have
been ordered before
31st of december
now moving ahead
we want to display
all the orders that were made after 31st
of december
so here
what you can do is i'll just copy the
above query again i'll copy this line
so instead of less than
31st of december 2018 i'll make it as
greater than so every order that was
placed after
31st of december will be displayed
if you run it so you can see here there
are three orders in our table which were
ordered after 31st of december 2018.
now moving ahead
let's write a seventh query
now let's see
how the order by clause works in sql so
you can filter your results based on a
particular column or sort it based on a
particular column
so this is going to be my query seven
i'll write it from scratch again let's
say
you want to display all the columns from
the table so i'll write select star from
orders
then i'm going to use order by
unit price
i'll give a
semicolon
let's run this query and see the output
now if you see the result here
and you mark the
unit price column
the result has been ordered in ascending
order of unit price you see here it
starts
with the lowest price and then
goes on with the highest price towards
the end now if you want to order it in
descending order you can use the keyword
desc
so this will ensure your top
or the most expensive products appear at
the top and the least expensive products
appear at the bottom
all right
next
now let's see how you can create a data
frame
from the given table
so as you know
using jupyter notebook and pandas you
can create data frames and work on it
very easily so with this table also we
can create our own data frame
so for that let me create an empty list
first i'll write from
db
equal to i'll assign this as an empty
list
so we are going to return a list of
lists and then create a pandas data
frame
next i'll write my for loop i'll write
for result in
results
i'll assign result
to
list of results so i'm converting the
result into a list
and then i'm going to append it to the
empty variable or the empty list which
is from underscore db dot
append
i'll append the result to
my empty list
next
we need to pass in the
columns now that will be part of our
data frame so i'll write
columns equal to
this column i'll pass it
within a list so i'll give my first
column as order id
then we have the
customer name
next i have my
product name
then i have the date on which it was
ordered
give a comma then we'll have the
quantity column
let me write it in the next line
next we have the unit price column
and
finally we have the
phone number column so i'll write within
double quotes
phone number
and this
we are going to assign it to a data
frame so i will be using pd dot
data frame which is my function to
convert a list into a data frame
my variable i'm going to pass is from
underscore db
and i'll write my next
argument is columns equal to
my
variable name that is columns
finally let's display
the data frame which is df
all right
so here i am creating a empty list first
and then
i am creating a
for loop and i am appending the results
to my empty list here you can see i have
created my column
list
and using pd.data frame i am converting
the list into a data frame
if i run this
this is
append and not appends
all right you can see we have our
data frame ready this is the index
column it starts from zero onwards and
then we have the different
column names
okay
now let's see how to use the update
command
now suppose
you want to
change the unit price of one of the
orders
you can use the update command so the
way to do it i'll first
create my variable let's say update
and i'll
give three
codes or triple quotes
then i'll use my update command which is
update followed by the table name that
is orders
next i'll write set
let's say unit underscore price
if you see this
let's say i want to set the unit price
of trousers from 50 dollars to let's say
45 dollars i want to update this
particular record so i'm going to write
set unit price column
equal to
45 dollars where
the order id equal to
103
so this query will update the
third row in our table which is order id
103
so it will update from 50 to 45 dollars
i'll close the triple quotes
and now
i'll use the
connection
queries again
let me just paste it here
all right
i'll delete
these three lines of code and instead of
that i'll put execute
underscore
query
and this will take into parameters as
always which is going to be connection
followed by the variable name that is
update
let's run it you see here it says mysql
database connection successful query was
successful
now you can recheck that
to do it let me just go to the top and
will
copy our first query which is q1 i'll
copy this
and i'll paste it here
let me just rename this now
this will be
q8
and i'll change this as well
i'll write select star from orders where
my order id equal to 103.
let's see the unit price of 103 now you
can see here instead of 50 now we
updated it to 45
all right
now the last command we are going to say
is how you can delete a record from the
table
i'll write delete command as my comment
now to delete a query
i'll first
give my variable name which is delete
underscore order
and i'll pass in within
triple quotes
next i'll write my delete query which is
delete from my table name that is orders
then i'll give my where clause where
let's say i want to delete my order id
105.
let me just go to the top and explain
you again
so if you say this we want to delete
the order id 105 which was for customer
name maria and she had ordered
headphones we want to completely remove
this particular record
so
i have my delete query ready
now let me just
create my connection and display the
results so i'll go to the top and i'll
copy this connection command
which also has the execute query command
and i'll paste it here
and i'm going to make a change here
instead of update we'll write delete
underscore order
everything looks good let's just run it
you can see our query was successful
and now
if you want to
print it let me just show you i'll just
copy this
we'll paste it here
i'll make this as q9
i want to verify if
my order id 105 was deleted or not
instead of
the statement i'll write select star
from orders
and here i'll change this to q9
if i run this
you can see it here you can mark order
id 105 was deleted and it no more
appears in this table
all right
so this brings us to the end of the demo
session on sql with python let me just
scroll you through what we did so first
we imported the important libraries
mysql connector then we imported the
error function then we imported pandas
using pd
we learned how to create a server
connection to mysql database we created
a new database that is mysql underscore
python
and now we connected to that database
we created a function to execute our
queries
we saw how you can write a create table
command
then we inserted a few records to our
orders table
we created a read underscore query
command to read the queries and display
the results
then we started exploring our
different sql commands one by one we saw
how to use
select query
then we selected a few individual
columns from our table followed by using
a
inbuilt function which was here then we
saw how to use the dextent keyword
after that we used our where clause to
filter a table based on specific
conditions
we saw how to order your results based
on a particular column
then we saw how you could convert the
table into a data frame using
pd.dataframe function
finally we learned how to use the update
command and the
delete command
in this session we will learn who is the
sql developer and what are the
responsibilities in a company then we
will focus on the skills required to
become a successful sql developer we
will see the expected average salary in
both u.s and india we will also discuss
how to become a sql developer and look
at the top companies hiring for sql
developers
so hey everyone i'm abhisaya ahuja from
simply learn and welcome to this video
on how to become a sql developer but
before we begin if you love watching
tech videos subscribe to our channel and
hit the bell icon to never miss an
update
when going through some of the popular
job boards online you would easily see
sql developer is one of the most
demanding jobs seek by companies
as we all know today companies collect
vast volumes of data and store it in
their own databases they want
professionals with a good understanding
of data who can keep it safe and secure
so
first we will understand who is a sql
developer
sql developer is a person who is
accountable in creating and managing
huge data assets of a company
in other terms sql developer is a person
who can develop sql databases as well as
write and test code
let's understand this with the help of
an example
let's say we want to search a particular
product on amazon website and amazon has
stored all its data about products in a
database now we will write the product
name in the search bar and when we click
on the search button it will run a sql
query that fetches all the information
about the product and displays us on the
website so this is the basic task done
by a sql developer
now we will understand the
responsibilities of a sql developer
all databases have a structure and logic
behind how data is stored and retrieved
a sql developer designs the database
accordingly for businesses that is
called database modeling
after the database is created and
deployed it's the sql developer who is
responsible for fixing the general
issues of the database
sql developer should be well versed with
structured query language to create
optimized sql queries and refines the
existing ones to extract information
from the database
sql developers run several diagnostic
tests to keep a check on the server and
the database in order to understand how
to organize companies data sql
developers must communicate with
tactical and non-technical persons from
the business and sql developer also
gathers client requirements and
identifies the features that the
database owners want
as data is an asset to a company sql
developers backup and restore data for
their clients
they also perform tasks like data
management and data migration that is if
a company has stored all its data on a
local storage and now it want its data
to be stored in a cloud storage so the
safe transmission of the data from local
storage to cloud storage is known as
data migration and that is done by the
sql developers
after knowing the responsibilities now
should look for skill set required to be
a good sql developer
one should have a good knowledge of sql
commands functions joins and procedures
let's have a look at few commands such
as create drop alter and truncate these
commands come under data definition
language we also have insert update and
delete commands these commands come
under data manipulation language we have
grant and devop commands these commands
come under data control language we also
have commit rollback and save point
commands these come under transaction
control language these are the basic
commands a sql developer should be
familiar with
and a sql developer may have a little
command on any one programming language
you don't have to be expert in
programming all you need is how to
interface between application and your
database for example you are using mysql
and your web application is based on php
then you should know how to connect your
application to the database and how to
issue queries
how to fetch results and then how to
display it to the users
one should have a good understanding of
various database management systems such
as mysql microsoft access oracle postgre
sql dbase foxpro sqlite
ibm db2 libreoffice base mariadb and
microsoft sql server
one should know integration of databases
with data visualization software such as
power bi and tableau which helps
businesses to make better decisions and
give you an add-on as a sql developer
one should develop critical thinking and
problem solving skills to create
optimized queries
now we'll see how a sql developer is
compensated in both united states and
india in the united states sql
developers draw an average salary of
dollar 72
282 per annum in india the average
salary of a sql developer is rupees 4
lakh 49 49532
now we'll see how person can become a
good sql developer for that one should
have a good command on structured query
language and know how to interact with
database management system and can issue
queries to get the desired result
earning industry recognized sql
developer certifications such as
microsoft certified professional
developer mcpd or oracle pl sql
developer certified associate which
usually require a passing score on an
exam
and it's important to accumulate as much
practical experience as possible start
by designing creating and acquiring
small databases connected with your
hobbies and interests for example your
favorite music videos or your personal
finances
this will enable you to gain experience
test your knowledge and build your
project portfolio which will be highly
beneficial when you start applying for
your first full-time position
now we will see some major companies
recruiting sql developers first we have
the multinational financial services
corporation american express followed by
the multinational professional services
network ernst and young we also have the
messaging company whatsapp then we have
the e-commerce giant amazon as well as
the technology and computer solutions
company dell finally in a list of
companies we have the multinational
technology company google sql is a very
important technology that is used in the
id industry
professionals working as application
developers web developers data analysts
data scientists software testers and
cyber security experts need to know sql
in this video we will cover 30 important
sql questions that are most frequently
asked in the interviews
now these questions consist of a set of
theoretical and practical questions
so we will use different commands
functions joints and other
functionalities in excel to solve the
problems so let's get started with the
first question
so the first question is to state the
difference between where and having
clause in sql
now where and having are very widely
used in sql to solve specific problems
now let's look at the difference one by
one
so where clause is used to filter the
records from the table based on the
specified condition and can be used
without the group by clause on the other
hand having clause is used to filter the
records from groups based on specified
conditions
now where clauses cannot have aggregate
functions so you cannot use some count
average min and maximum functions in the
where clause
while in the having clause you can
operate on aggregate functions
and those aggregate functions are used
to filter values from a group
now where clause is implemented on rows
or at row level
so for each row of data you have the
where condition applied
now having clauses are implemented on
columns so for each column of data you
have the having condition applied
now another important difference between
wear and having
is that the where clause is executed
before the execution of the group by
clause and after the execution of the
from clause
on the other hand the having clause is
executed after groups are created
now we will learn more about where and
having and understand the usage better
when we tackle practical problems in
this video
now moving to our next question
which is
how is drop different from truncate
so drop and truncate are two different
commands
so drop command is used to drop the
whole table removing the table
definition and its contents while
truncate deletes all the rows from the
table
we can drop the whole table structure in
one go so the view of the table does not
exist
by using the truncate command the
existence of all the rows in the table
is lost but the view in the table exists
now integrity constraints
will be removed in drop command while
the integrity constraints will not be
removed when you use the truncate
command
now moving to our third question now
this is a practical question so we will
be using a
table which is present in my mysql
database so the table name is called
employees and i want to find the lowest
salary of the employees in each
department
you can see here this is how my
employees table
looks
and
the output query would be something like
this
so here since i want to find the lowest
salary of the employees so i am using a
min function to find the lowest salary
in the table
and then i am grouping
all the employees and the results by
department so let's do this on mysql
workbench
okay so here i am on my mysql workbench
first let me go ahead and create a new
sql script
so i'll click on this
and that will create a new script
okay so here we'll write our commands
all right
so
our question was to
find the
lowest salary
for each department
okay so i have given my comment to make
my
commands
and whatever i am doing more readable
so
first before i proceed
i need to
select my database so i'm going to use
my sql underscore intro database
so i'll write use sql underscore intro
now this database has a lot of tables
that we'll be using in this
interview questions
video i'll run it
okay
we are in our sql intro database now
there is a table called
employees let me show you the table
first
if i write select star from employees
okay so here you can see this is the
table i'm talking about
now these are the
rows
that are present in the table we have 20
rows and here you can see the different
columns we have the employee id employee
name each gender
we have the department city and salary
now this is the same table that we have
also used
in our other videos that are already
live on youtube
ok
so
let's solve our question to find the
lowest salary for each department
now
for that
i'll write select
i'll select my department column which
is dept
comma
and then
to calculate the lowest salary or to
find the lowest salary i'm going to use
the min function
so that will return the minimum salary
present in the salary column
so i'll write min salary as i'm giving
an alias name as let's say
lowest
underscore salary
from
my table name that is employees
then i'll write
group by
department
now i'm grouping it by department
because we want to find the lowest
salary of the employees in each
department
now let's run and see the result
there you go
i'll just
move it to the top so that you can see
the results
clearly
okay so here we have total seven
departments you can see at the bottom
and
in these seven departments you can see
in sales seventy thousand let's say
dollars was the lowest salary in
marketing we had fifty five thousand
dollars as the lowest salary similarly
if i scroll down we have other
departments like
tech i.t finance and hr so
these are the lowest salary
in each department
all right
now moving to our next question
so our fourth question is
which query will help you fetch unique
values from a column in a table
so this is a multiple choice question
which is another type of question that
is often asked in the sql interviews
now we have multiple queries here and
you need to choose the right query that
will solve our problem
so
since i want to
get the unique values from a column in a
table
so the right option
would be to use the distinct keyword in
the query so if i write select
distinct followed by the column name
let's say you want to find the distinct
cities or the distinct departments in
the employees table so the query would
be select distinct city or let's say
department from the table name that is
employees
hence this is the right option if you
want to find any unique values from a
column
now moving to the
fifth question
now the fifth question says
it is actually a similar question here
we want to write the sql query to fetch
unique departments from the employees
table
so as we saw this is our employees table
and if you want to find the unique
departments from the employees table you
can just write select
distinct then followed by the column
name
which is departments here so dept from
employees
let's
do this
on our mysql workbench
okay so let me just scroll down
and i'll
give a comment here
that is we want to find the unique
departments
so the query would be
select
then i'll use the distinct keyword if i
hit tab it will auto complete
then i have my column that is department
from
my table name that is employees
if i run this
the query will give us
the unique departments that are present
in the table so here we have total
seven unique departments in the table
you can see here we have sales marketing
product
tech id
finance and hr
but
if you see our original table which is
the employees table
so there are total
20 records
and if you see the department column
there are
multiple departments to which each of
these employees belong to
okay
now moving ahead
now the sixth question is to write an
sql query to fetch the
unique values of departments and print
their length
now
this question consists of two parts
first we need to fetch the unique values
of departments that we saw in our fifth
question
and then we want to print the length of
each of the departments so for that i'm
using the distinct keyboard to find the
unique departments and then
i'm using the
inbuilt
length function that is present in mysql
to find the length of the department and
then i'm
using an alias that is length underscore
department from employees so let's
say this on
our workbench
okay so let me
give a comment
i'll say
unique
departments and
length
okay so the query would be
i'll write
select
distinct department
and then
let me just scroll down
i'll give a comma
and use my inbuilt length function see
i'm hitting tab to autocomplete
and inside the length function i will
give my column name that is department
i'll give an alias as
department underscore
length
from my table that is employees this is
pretty simple so first i am finding the
unique departments and then using the
length function i am finding the
length of each department
let's run and see
okay you can see the result here so
sales
the length is five
marketing the length of marketing is
nine so basically you're counting the
number of characters that are present in
each of the departments so in sales
there are total five characters in
marketing there are total nine
characters in product there are total
seven characters in it we have just two
letters i and t so hence the
length is two similarly finance is
seven and h r is two because we have
just two letters h and r
okay so this is another variation of
using distinct along with
any inbuilt function
all right
now moving to the seventh question
the question is what is the use of datif
function in sql
now dative
returns the number of days between two
date or date time or time stamp values
so d diff is another
crucial
inbuilt function that is present in
mysql
so here is how you can use the datedif
function so it will return the
number of days between two dates or
datetime or time stamp value so here i
have two date values that is
10th of
april 2021 and
i have
30th of
march 2021
so this query will give us the
total number of days that lie between
these two dates and similarly
here is another example of using the
datedif function
so i want to calculate the total number
of days that are present between today's
date so i'm using the now function and
between
20th of april 2021
so let's do this demo on the workbench
all right
first i'll give a comment
saying
dated function
okay
now the way to use this
i'll write select
and then
you can see here once i type date
mysql workbench is automatically
suggesting some of the inbuilt functions
i am going to use datedif
and within datedif i am going to pass in
two values so i am passing into date
values let's say 2021
april
so i'll write 0 4 and let's say
10th of april
i'll give another comma
and i'll pass in my second date value
that is going to be
30th of
march
2021
all right
now another thing to note here is
the
date value should be present inside
quotations
now if you want you can give an alias as
will
i'll write as
total these
let's run it
there you go it has given us the output
as 10 so there are total 10 d's between
31st of march
to
10th of april
now let's see another example
i'll write select
date diff
and we'll pass in
my now function so the now function
returns the
current
date that is today's
date
and i'll give another date value let's
say
2021
april
20th
now we'll see the results
if you want you can give an alias name
so that the output is more readable here
i'll run it
okay
so between
today's date and
my previous date that was 20th of
april
there are total 49 days
so today's date is actually 8th of june
so between
20th of april and 8th of june there are
total 49 days
all right
now moving ahead
now in the eighth question we want to
write
an sql query to display the departments
that have
more than two employees
so
this is our employees table that we have
been using
and here is how the
command looks like so here
we are using both group by and having
now i am grouping by department because
i want to
display the departments that have more
than two employees now for the second
filter i am using the
count function of the employee ids
and checking if the employees
in each department are more than two or
not
let's do this
let me
move down a bit
and i'll give a comment
departments with
more than
two employees
okay
now let's write our query
so i want to select
the department
and then
i'm using the count function to count
the
employee ids in each
department or the employees
present in each department
from my table that is employees
i am going to group by
department
and then i use having
my count of
employee id
this should be greater than 2
so
our query will return only those
departments which have more than 2
employees let's run and see
there you go
so we have
total four departments that is sales
product tech and i t
where we have more than
two employees you can see here sales has
four employees product has three
tech has four
and it has three the rest of the
departments like finance hr and others
have less than two employees
now if you want you can give an alias as
well let's see as
total employees
okay
let me run it again
and here you can see i have the
column name as total employees
okay
so moving ahead
the ninth question we want to display
the details of the employees for all the
departments except marketing
now
here i have my employees table
now if i were to display all the details
of the employees apart from
marketing department
i can give a condition like where
department
not equal to marketing so this is the
way how you write not equal to so you
use the less than and greater than
symbol
another way to do is use the exclamation
mark
and give equal to so this means
select all the employees where
department is not equal to marketing
now let's do this
i'll move down a bit
and will give a comment as
details of employees apart from
marketing
so the query would be select
star from employees
i am using star because i want to
display all the details that means i
want to display all the columns
then i am going to use my where
condition where
department
not equal to
marketing
i'll put marketing under
quotes
let's run it and see the results
there you go
so we have
total
18 rows of information
and if you see the department column we
have
all the departments apart from marketing
now if you remember
our employees table had total 20 rows of
information out of which two are missing
which means there were two employees who
were from marketing department and those
departments were
not displaying
now
another way to do is
to use
exclamation mark and equal to
so this also means
select all the employees where
department is not equal to marketing
let's run this you see here
it gives us the same result and has
returned us
18 rows of information
leaving apart
the employees from the marketing
department
all right
now moving ahead
so our tenth question is to write an sql
query to print the details of the
employees who have joined before
april 2010 and after
may 2005
so here is my employees table
and
this is my sql query so here we are
using
just a where condition to filter our
results
and
my condition is
the employee should have joined after
may 2005 so i have written
after
31st of
may 2005 and before april 2010 which is
before
31st of
march 2010
let's do this
i'll
give a comment here
we'll write
employees
joined
before
april
2010
[Music]
and
after
may 2005
now let's write our sql query so i'll
write select
star from
employees
where
my date of join if you see here i have a
column called date of join which has the
details about the day on which the
employee had joined
the company
so i'm going to write where date of join
is greater than
31st of
may
2005 so i'll write
2005
this is one of the formats to use date
values
so this is the year value this is the
month value and this is the d value
and
my date of join
should be
less than
31st of march 2010 so i'll write
2010
march
31st
i hope
you were able to understand this
date of join greater than 31st of may
2005 means
after may 2005
and data joined less than
31st of march
2010 this means
employees joined before
2010 april
let's run it
okay so we have total three employees in
our table you can
see the
date of join
and all of them have joined
after may 2005 and before april 2010
okay
now moving ahead to the 11th question
so here we want to find the employee
with the
third highest salary from the table
so i have my employees table here
and my command would look something like
this so here we are going to explore how
to write
sub queries in sql so
i'm using a sub query here where i'm
trying to find
the
employees who have the
top three salaries or the top three
employees who have the highest salaries
and from that i'm going to filter out my
third highest salary employee so let's
do it on our workbench
okay
so i'll come down and let me give a
comment as
third highest salary
okay
so
let me first write down my sql query and
then i'll explain so i'll write select
star from
after that i'll start a bracket and
write my inner query so i'll write
select
star from
employees
order by
salary
descending
then i'll use my limit keyword
and i'll write limit 3
as i'll give an alias name let's say t
and then
i'm
again going to use
my order by
salary
limit
1.
okay now let me explain you the flow
so first let me run the inner query i'll
select my inner query
and i'll run it
so the inner query returns
my top three employees who have the
highest salary and this is ordered in
descending order since i used salary
descending
now let me just
use this okay now you can see it clearly
so these are my top three employees who
have the highest salary so joseph has
the
maximum salary followed by
angela and then we have jack
now from this i want to return
only
the record for jack because jack is the
employee
who earns the third highest salary so
for that
i am going to
use the result written by my
sub query or the inner query and on top
of this
i am going to order the salary and say
limit equal to 1 so i am again ordering
this salary in ascending order so what
will happen
jack will appear at the top angela will
be at the second place and joseph will
come to the third place and from there i
am using limit1 so that i can only get
the record for jack
now if i run the entire query
you see the result i have my
employee name as jack who wants the
third highest salary
okay
now moving ahead to the 12th question
the question is to print all the
alternate records in a table so here is
my employees table and from this table i
am going to print all the alternate
records for example i am going to print
my employee id 101 then i am going to
skip 102 and print 103 followed by 1 0 5
1 0
7 1 0 9 so all the
employee ids that have an odd value
and you can look at this example in
another way of displaying the employees
which have an employee id
of even numbers so 102 104 106 and so on
now the way to do is
either you can use a simple select
clause and say employee id
percentage or modulus 2 equal to 0 which
means i want to filter only those
employees which have an even employee id
else
what you can do is you can use a cte as
you can see here
so cte or the common table expression is
a temporary named result set that you
can reference within a select insert
update or delete statement now it is
used to simplify complex joints and sub
queries and to provide a means to query
hierarchical data
now let's
write this query on our workbench and
see how it works
but before that let me explain you i am
using a few
new functions such as row number this
will
create a row number for each of the rows
or the records present in my table
and then
from this cte i am going to use my
filter class or the where clause
where rn which is row number percentage
2 equal to equal to 1 so this will
return
only the odd records from the table
let's see how to do it
okay
so
i'll give a comment
print
alternate
records
okay
now i'll start with my
simple query which is select star from
employees
where
let's say i want to find only the even
employee ids or the employees who have
an even employee id
so i can use employee id
percentage 2 equal to 0. so it has to be
a perfect division
and the result should be 0 only then i
can get only the even employees if i run
this
okay there was an error here it should
be employees
i'll run it again
you can see here i have printed the
alternate records in a table so we have
skipped one zero one because it is not
divisible by 2
i have started with 102 followed by 1 0
4
1 0 6 1 0 8
and then finally we have
1 2 0 or 120
now if you want
to print only the
odd records in the table you can use
employee id percentage to equal to one
so you can see here i have one zero one
one zero three one zero five one zero
seven up to
119
now the
best way to do this is
to use a common table expression or cte
so i'll start with
my command that is with cte
as
i'll
start with my bracket i'll write select
star
comma
then i'm going to use my row number
function
so i'll write
row number
then
i'll write over
then i'll use order by
employee id
so this
row number for each of the rows is going
to be created over my employee id column
and that is sorted in
ascending order i will give an alias as
rn which stands for row number
from
my table that is
employees
i'll scroll down
and then i'm going to
close my bracket
i'll write select
let me remove the space here
okay and let's select star from
cte
where
my
row number
percentage 2 equal to
1.
now
let's
see this from the top
so i have my common table expression
where
i am
going to create a
row number column named as rn
and this row number column is based on
my employee id column which is sorted in
ascending order
and from that i am going to filter only
those row number values that are not
divisible by 2 or i am going to print
only the
odd records from the table so let's run
it and see the results there you go so
here if you mark i have my row number
column created
and i am filtering only the odd records
in the table so it starts with 1 3 5 7
and goes up to 19
and similarly here you can see the
employee ids the name the age gender and
other information
now if you were to print
the even records in the table
the alternate even records you can use
rn percentage 2 equal to 0 let's see the
difference
i'll run this
there you go
so i have my even row numbers starting
from 2 which goes up to
20
okay so this is how you can print
alternate records in a table
now moving to the next question
now in the 13th question we want to
write an sql query to fetch
all the duplicate rows in a table now
this is another crucial interview
question that is often asked in most of
the interviews
now i have a table which is named as
duplicate table and here you can see i
have some employee id name and each and
a few records are duplicated for example
101 sam
40 the first record is duplicated and
you can see here
it has the same
values
now if you mark
103
mary and 28 is not duplicated because
here the age is different so this is a
different person
than
compared to the
third name that we have
so this is how you can find
the duplicate rules in a table so i am
going to select my employee id name and
age and then count
all the employee ids the names and each
and compare them with whether they are
greater than one or not so if they are
greater than one
then
i'll say that particular record is
duplicated or is present more than one
time in the table let's
do this
implementation on our
workbench
okay
so i'll come down
and let me give my comment as
duplicate records
okay
so
let me first
show you the records that are present in
my table so i'll right select
star from dup underscore
employees
i'll run it
okay you can see here i have my table
that we saw in the slides
so
employee id 101 with name sam and age
40 is duplicated
so we want to find this duplicate record
the way to do is
i'll write
select
e underscore id which is employee id
comma name comma age
comma i'm going to count
all of them
so i'll write count star
as
duplicate
count this is my alias name
from
my table that is dup underscore
employees
i'll say
group by
employee id
name
and age
and then i am going to use my having
clause saying having
count of
employee id
is greater than 1
and count of
name
should also be greater than 1
and
my count of age
should also be
greater than 1.
let's run it and see the results
okay there is some error here
the name of the table should be
employees
okay
let's run again
we have
our correct result
that is employ id101 with name sam
and each 40 is duplicated so the value
is 2.
great
now
moving ahead
now the 14th question is a bit tricky
but in we want to display the employees
with exactly two
a's in their name
so you see here i have my
employee names and there are certain
employees who have just
two e's in their names so i want to find
those employees
only
now the way to do is
it is a bit tricky to understand i am
going to break it down and make you
understand
on my mysql workbench
so here you can just have a glance i
write select star from employees where
i am finding the length of my employee
name and then subtracting
my length
wherein i have
replaced my employee name
that has a with a
blank
and if this subtraction is equal to 2
then
that particular employee has two e's in
their names
so let me show this first
let me
first give my comment as
employees
with
two
e's okay
so
first
i'm going to write a select statement
okay before that i'll show you
the records present in my table
okay
if you see here
shane is one of the employees that has
just one e
in its name then we have mary 1 a
duin has one a but if you see sarah
sarah has 2a
in the name so we want to extract sarah
then
jack has 1a again if you see angela
angela has 2a it doesn't matter if it is
uppercase a or lowercase a we just need
to find
if the employees have two e's in their
name
and similarly if i scroll down let me
check if we have
any other employee with two a's in their
name marcus has one dbid has one sophia
has one
we also have amelia that has two a's in
its name or in her name
and we also have maya
okay
now
let me go ahead and write a sql query
and then i'll explain you what i'm
trying to do
i'll write select
i'm using the length function
and
in the length function
i'm going to replace
then i'll use another function called
upper
on top of employee name
i'll write
a and then replace it with a blank so
i'm using quotations to represent blank
from
employees
okay
let's run this and see the results
you see here
it has given us
the length
of the employee strings after
replacing all the e's with a blank
so here
i'm essentially
converting my employee names to
uppercase
and i'm changing wherever there is an a
i'm replacing
that a with a blank and then i'm finding
the length
so this trick i'm going to use
in my
final query so i'll write select star
from
employees
where
what i'm going to do is
i'll bring this to the next line i'll
write
length of
employee name
minus
then i'm going to use my above
condition
i'll
copy this
i'll paste it here and this value should
be
2.
so what i'm doing is i am first
finding out the length of my employee
name
from that
i'm subtracting
the length after replacing
the e is present in the employee name
with a blank and this value should be
equal to 2. the reason being we are only
trying to find the employees who have
two a's in their name
let's run and see the results
okay if you see here we have sarah
angela
emilia and maya who have
two a's in their name so we have
sara
that has 2a angela has 2a amelia has two
a's
and then maya also has 2a
okay
now moving ahead
now the 15th question is given a string
how will you extract four characters
starting from the
second position
so i have my string here
which says michael ballack now michael
ballack you must be aware he's a popular
footballer he's from germany and also
was the captain of germany
so from the string michael ballack i am
going to extract four characters
starting from the second position
you can use two inbuilt mysql functions
to
do this the first is called
sub str
wherein we pass in the string
then we
give the position from where we want to
extract the characters so here i am
going to extract from the second
position so hence 2
and then the number of characters that
you want to extract which is 4.
the other way is to use the substring
function
which is again similar to the sub str
function
in the substring function also i am
first passing in my input string and
then giving my starting position which
is 2 and then i want to extract 4
characters from it
let's do it
i'll give a comment
extract
strings
so here i'm going to write select
first i'm going to use sub str
which is my inbuilt function
i'm going to pass in my input string
which says
michael
ballack
and then
i'll give my starting position which is
2 and then the number of characters that
is 4.
let's run it and see the results
you can see here it has given us
i cha
so if you see m is at the first position
from the second position onwards i
needed four characters so m c h and e
these are the four characters starting
from the second position
similarly let me just copy this
and instead of
sub str i am going to use the substring
function i will write just
ing that becomes sub string
let's
select and run it
and this also returns the same result
suppose you wanted to extract
from the fourth position
you wanted to extract let's say three
characters
let's see the results
it gives us h a and e if you see here
m is the first position i is at the
second position c is at the third
position h starts from the fourth
position
so h a and e are the next three
characters starting from the fourth
position
so hence this is the result
all right now moving ahead
now my sixteenth question is on
how does self join
work so self join joins a table to
itself
so the table must contain a column x
that acts as the primary key
and a different column let's say y that
stores values that can be matched with
the values in column x now
this might
not be really easy to understand you'll
get to know once we do this demo so i
have a table
which is called employee manager so this
is my table
now let me tell you how to interpret
this table we have five different
employees starting from employee id one
two employee id five
gary gibbs smith latham and
jimmy are the different employees we
have we have their salaries and now you
have
the employees reporting to which
manager
now if you see here
gary's manager
id is three
so if you see a table at 3 we have smith
so gary is reporting to 3
or in other words
smith has a employee under him who is
gary similarly
gibbs is reporting to manager id 1 or
employee id 1 which is gary so
gibbs manager is gary similarly if you
see for smith smith is reporting to the
person with manager id 4 or employee id4
we have latham so litham has one
employee under him who is smith
now litham in our table has no managers
then we have jimmy who's reporting to
the employee id3 who is smith
okay
now i want to
use this table and return the name of
the manager for each employee
to do that i am going to use my self
join so here i am using
a self join to join both the tables
here both the tables mean i'm using
the same table twice so i have written
select e dot employee id e dot employee
name then we have e dot manager id
then i'm using another alias for
managers so m dot employee name as
manager underscore name from
employee underscore manager as e
this join means self join employee
underscore manager sm on
e dot manager id equal to e dot employee
id so this is my common column that is
employee id and manager id let's do it
all right
i'll give a comment here
saying self join
and i'll start with myself join i'll
write
select
let me first display my table i'll write
select star from
and my table name is
emp underscore manager
i'll run it
you can see the table here this is the
same table that we saw
in the slides
now i'll write my
join query i'll write select e dot
employee id
comma
e
dot
employee name
comma
e dot
manager id
comma
then i'm using another alias as m
for
finding the
manager name so m dot employee name as
manager name
there shouldn't be any space in the
alias name
then i'll write from
emp underscore
manager as e
join
emp underscore
manager as
m
on
e dot
manager
underscore
id equal to
m dot
emp underscore
id
let me run this and we'll see the
results
there you go
so gary
reports to
the manager id 3 so from the table 3
is for smith so gary's manager is smith
gibbs manager is gary
smith's manager is lithum and jimmy's
manager is smith
okay so this is how you can use self
join
now moving ahead with our
next question
so the 17th question
is on which of the following is called a
virtual table in sql so again we have a
multiple choice question
so the answer is
view you can see here
so view is a virtual table that has rows
and columns as they are in a real table
in the database now we can create a view
by selecting fields from one or more
tables present in the database
next moving to the 18th question
so here we want to write an sql query to
fetch the list of employees with the
same salary
again i am going to
use a self join here wherein i'll join
the same employees table
and this is how my
query would look like so i am
selecting distinct employee id so e dot
employee id e dot employee name e dot
salary from employees then i'm joining
employees as e on employees e1 where e
dot salary equal to e1 dot salary
because i want to fetch
the list of employees with the same
salary and i'm ensuring that
the employee ids from both the tables
are different
let's do it
i'll give a
comment here and write
employees
with
same salary
and i'll start with my
query i'll write
select
extinct
e dot
employee id
comma
i'll write e dot
employee name comma dot salary
from
employees
as e
then
employs as
e 1
where
e dot salary equal to
e 1 dot
salary
and
e
dot employee id is not equal to
e1 dot
employee id
i'll give a semicolon and let's print
the results
you see here we have
emilia
bayla sheen and sarah
who have the
same salaries so amelia and sheen have
the same salary of fifty five thousand
dollars bill and sarah have the same
salary of seventy 72 000
okay
now moving to the 19th question
so the question is to write an sql query
to print one row twice
in results from a table
so i have a table here called employees
and i want to print
one row twice in the results
so to solve such kind of problems
you need to use the union all operator
in sql
so union all combines the result sets of
two or more select statements
it does not remove duplicate rows
between the various select statements
all the rows are returned
so let's say i want to print the
employee name and department for those
employees who are from the hr department
now to do this we can use the union all
operator you can see it here so i am
selecting my employee name the
department from my table employees as e
then i am giving my where clause where e
dot department equal to hr
and then i am using the union all
operator
then i am again selecting my employee
name department from employees with
another alias as e1 where e1 dot
department equal to hr so let's do this
okay
so i'll give my comment as
print
row
twice
okay
now
i'll start with my query i'll write
select
my employee name
comma the department
from my table that is employees as e
then i'll use where
e dot department equal to
hr
then i am going to use the union all
operator
so the union all will combine the result
set of two or more select statements
then i am going to write select
emp underscore name
comma
my department
from
employees
as
e1
where
e one dot department
equal to
hr
i'll give a semicolon now let's run it
there you go you can see here
marcus and sophia are from the hr
department and we have printed them
twice in our results
coming to the next question
the question is
using the num table
write a query to add 10 when number is 0
20 the number is 1
else
print the number itself
so you can see here i have my table
called num
and it has just one column which is
num id or number id
we have some
numbers here
and
from these numbers i want to add 10 if
the number is 0 20 if the number is 1
else i would print the number itself
so
to answer this question we'll use the
case statement in sql
so the case statement is sql's way of
handling if then logic
the case statement is followed by at
least one pair of when and then
statements
so here you can see i have my case
statement i'm writing one case
my column name and underscore id equal
to 0 then add
plus 10
if it is 1 then add plus 20
else
we'll just return the number id
now let's do this
okay
i'll give a
comment saying using
case statements
okay first of all
let me
display the values present
in my
num table you can see here this is my
table and there are total
12 rows
of numbers
now let's start with our
query i'll write
select
n underscore id
comma
then i'm going to write my case
statement so i'll use the keyword as
case when
n underscore id equal to 0
i'll use then
n underscore id
plus 10
i'll write when
n underscore id equal to 1
then
an underscore id
plus 20
else
i'll just print an id
now i'll end my key statement i'll write
end as
an alias name let's say num underscore
add
from my table that is num
let's run and see the results
okay you can see here
my first
number was 0 so since it was 0 we have
added num id or n id plus 10 so the
result is 10
now
wherever
the num id is 1 for example here we have
added 20 so the
result or the output becomes 21.
similarly here the value was 0 so we
have added 10 the output is 10
and you see here again here we had
another one so we added 1 to
20 so the result becomes 21
and for the rest of the numbers for
example 3
we had 2
the values are the same
okay
now moving ahead
so we have
a table called num1
and using this table we want to write a
query to find the sum of all positive
values and the negative values
so let's see the table first so this is
my table which is num1 you can see here
we have a list of integers
there are positive as well as negative
integers
so for positive values
and the negative values we want to find
the sum separately
so again for this we are using the case
statement you can see here i have used
two key statements
i am writing select
and then i am using the case to find if
the number is greater than zero which
means it is a positive number so i am
finding out the sum
and then i'm checking
case when
the integer is less than zero so it's a
negative number and i'm finding the sum
for the negative numbers as well
let's do this
okay
so
i'll give my comment
as
add
positive and
negative numbers
okay so let's start with our select
query
i'll write select
i'll use the sum function and inside the
sum function
i'll use my case statement so i'll write
case when
num
underscore
integer
okay before that let me just print the
values present in my
table so i'll write select star from
my table name that is num1
okay
so you can see here these are the values
or the list of integers that we have
there are some positive as well as
negative integers
okay let's continue with our query
so here i'm going to write case when
num underscore integer or int which is
my column name
if it is greater than 0
then
i'll return num underscore
int
else i'll say 0
and end my key statement
i'll give an alias as sum of let's say
positive numbers give a comma
then i'll use another sum function
and inside the sum function we'll use
the case statement to find
the sum of
negative numbers or integers
so i'll write num underscoring if it is
less than 0
then
num underscore end
else
0
and i'll end
okay
and i'll give another alias name as
let's say sum underscore any g which
stands for negative
pos is for positive integers
and then i'll write from my table that
is num1
let's
run it
okay there you go we have our results so
we have two columns
sum of positive integers and sum of
negative integers you can see the
results 19 and minus 14 respectively
okay now moving ahead
now in question number 22 we want to
list the difference between
primary key and foreign key
so as you can see here
primary key is something that can
uniquely identify a record in a table
so if you consider a school database a
primary key would ideally be
the
role number or the registration number
of the student
because that is unique to all the
students in a school
now
foreign key is the field in the table
that is
primary key to another table so suppose
you have another table called courses to
which the
students of enroll2
now
if you have a roll number or a
registration number column in the
course table that becomes the
foreign key
now the other difference is primary key
don't accept or cannot accept null
values
while foreign key can accept null values
you can have only one primary key in a
table but you can have more than
one foreign key in a table
now coming to the 23rd question what is
the difference between primary key and
union
so you can have only one primary key in
a table as we discussed in the previous
question
but you can have more than one unique
key in a table a primary key column
cannot have null values but union can
accept null values
now
if you assign a column as a primary key
you create a clustered index
and similarly if you assign a column
with union
you create non-cluster index
okay
now coming to the 24th question
what is a check constant in sql
so check constraints are used while
creating tables
check constraint
helps to limit or restrict the values
that can be inserted into a column
for example
we have a
table here let's say dummy1
and you want to ensure
that every time you insert the
age of
people or persons in the table you want
to make sure that age should be always
greater than zero reason being a person
cannot have or an animal cannot have or
a tree cannot have a negative each
similarly you can set a constant for the
salary column in a table to ensure that
it is always greater than zero because
you cannot earn a negative salary or it
cannot be less than zero
now we are going to create a dummy table
on my mysql workbench and see how
check constraints can be applied
okay
so let's give our comment as
check constraints
all right
so i'm going to create
a table
called
dummy
let's say underscore
sql
now this table
will have
a few columns first we have let's see
eid which stands for employee id
the data type is integer and
i'm going to assign employee id as my
primary key so i'll write primary key
here
okay i'll give a comma
next we'll have a
city column
city column is of type var care or
varying character
i'll give the size as 30
and here
i am going to apply my check constraint
to this
city column
i am going to check
the city should
take only
values as mumbai
let's see
i'll have my final column that is each
ages of type integer
and here i'm going to check my age
should always be
greater than zero so i'll write check
age
greater than zero
okay
so our dummy sql table has
one primary key constraint and we have
applied two check constraints
on city and h column
let's run
this okay so we have created our table
successfully you can see it here
now
let's insert a few records and we can
see the difference
i'll write insert into
dummy
underscore sql
i'll write
values
i'll have my employee ids 101
i am giving my
city as mumbai
which is what you want
and let's see
i'll give my age as
10.
now this should perfectly bore because
my city is mumbai and my age
is greater than zero
so
i should be able to insert this record
successfully you can see here
i have inserted
this record to the table
i'll write select star from dummy sql so
that you can check
let's run it
oh there is some mistake i should write
from
okay
let's run it
you can see it here we have one record
or one row returned
now let's see we'll insert another
record
and this time i'm going to give my
employee ideas 102 because it has to be
unique
and this time instead of mumbai i am
going to give my city as let's say delhi
so i am not following my check constant
where i am
supposed to give only mumbai
i am purposely giving
delhi here to see the difference if i
run this
let's see we'll have
ages 40 which is greater than 0
let's run it
you see here we get an error saying
check constraint dummy underscore sql
underscore
check
is violated
similarly
let's see i'll change this to mumbai
again
and instead of 40 let's say i'll give us
minus 30
so your each can never be in negative
numbers if i run this i get the same
error my check constraint has been
violated because each
should be greater than
zero
okay so this is how you can use check
constraints in sql
now coming to the 25th question
so given two tables a and b
you want to write a query to fetch
values in table b
that are not present in table a
now to answer this question
you can use the left join
so what left join does is
it returns all the rows from the left
table and only matching rows from the
right table
and i've used my
condition as a dot id which is in the
right table should be null
let's write this query on the
workbench
okay
so i'll give my comment
using
left join
first of all let me display my
tables i'll write select star from
e
where on this i have the
ids there are total five ids in table a
similarly
i'll copy this and
we'll see the values that are present in
table b
again i have five values there are a few
non-matching values as well so i want to
return those non-matching values that
are not present in table a
so for that
i'll write select
id
from
table b
i'll use left join
a
using my id column
this is another way to give the
condition
or you can use the on operator
then i'll give
bear
a dot id
is
null
let's run and see the results
there you go so 150
275 are not present in table a but are
present in table b
okay
now moving ahead
so now we look at the last set of five
questions
so these questions are based on the
popular northwind sample database
provided by microsoft now there are
several tables in this database so we
have an order table customers employee
products region table and others
we'll use our microsoft sql server to
solve the five questions
so my next question which is based on
microsoft sql server
the question is using the
north wind
database find the customers who don't
have any orders
okay so i am on my microsoft sql server
management studio so this is how the
interface looks like
and here you can see i have a list of
databases now to solve the last five
questions i'm going to use the northwind
database if i expand this
i'll click on the plus sign you can see
there are a lot of tables that are
already present in the
database you can see here we have
customers employees employee territories
order details orders products region
shippers suppliers territories and more
okay
let me just collapse this
all right
so
to write my queries i am going to create
a
new query file
and here you see
i am currently on my master database i
am going to change this to
northwind database so that we can
utilize all the tables that are present
so my 26th question was to find the
customers who don't have any orders
so for that
i am going to use two tables
customers and orders
so let me first give a comment
saying
customers
with
no orders
and now
let's go ahead and display the columns
that we have and see the
records present in the tables
customers and orders so first time
checking all the
columns and the rows present in the
customers table i'll
execute using this button or you can hit
f5 as well
okay you can see here there are total
91 customers these are all unique
customers you have total 91 unique
customer ids you see here the company
name of the customer
you have the contact name the contact
title address city to which the
customers belong to
then the region postal code country
phone fax number
okay
now let me just copy this query
and
now we'll check for the orders table
i'll write select star from
orders
and let's execute it or run it
okay so there are
total 830
rows of information so there were total
830 orders
or order ids we have the customer id now
this customer id is actually the
foreign key
for the orders table
but for the customers table customer id
is the primary key and in the orders
table order id is the primary key
we also have the employee id again this
employee id is the foreign key for this
orders table
we have the order date
we have the required date ship date
ship wire which means
by which medium the order was shipped we
have the free charges ship name and
ship address as well
then you have the
city from which the item was shipped the
region postal code and the country
okay
now
let me use the distinct keyword i'll
write select
dextent
i want to find the distinct
customer ids
from
my customers
table let's run and see how many unique
customer ids we have so there are total
91 customer ids or customers
now let's check for the orders table
let's run it and see the difference now
if you see here there are total
89
customer ids in the orders table which
means
there are two customers missing from the
orders table
and that implies those two customers
don't have any orders
so to
get the result i will use two different
queries
to derive at the same
output
so i'm going to
select my customer id
from
my table that is
customers
i'm going to use
where
my customer id
and then i'm going to use the not in
operator
i'm going to use a sub query
select
customer id
from
my orders table
close the bracket and i'll give a
semicolon
now what this query essentially does is
it is first going to
find all the customer ids that are
present in my orders table
and
in the outer query we are only going to
return
the customers that are present in
both the tables and
we are going to
exclude those customers which are not
present in the
orders table
so let's run and see the results we
should get two customer ids there you go
so these are the two customer ids which
are
present in the
customers table and are not present in
the orders table meaning that they don't
have any
orders in their name
now there is another way to do it
that is to use the not exist operator
wherein you can write another
sub query to get this same result we
will leave that to you you can try this
out using the not exist operator as well
coming to the 27th question
using the orders table in the northwind
database we want to find all the
month and orders so such problems you
will face while dealing with sales data
so very often sales executives would try
hard to meet their month end targets we
want to display all the orders made on
the last day of the month
so let's solve this question on our
microsoft sql server
okay so let me first give my comment for
the 27th question
so the question is to
find all the month end orders so will
just write
month end orders
okay
now to get the month and orders we are
going to use a
built in
eo month function which stands for end
of month so let's start with the query
i'll write select
we are going to select the
employee
id
comma
i also want the order id
and
we want the order date
from
my table that is
orders
i'll
then give my where clause i'll write
where
my
order date
equal to
and i'll use my
inbuilt function that is end of month
i
have hit tab to auto complete
and inside this function i will pass in
my order date column
then i am going to
use the order by clause i am going to
order it by
employee id and the order id
i'll just move down and hit tab
ok
let's
run the query there you go
we have got 26 rows of information
you see on the left side we have the
employee ids the order ids and then we
have the order date column now if you
mark the values present in the order
date column these are all
the
end of
month date values you see this is 28th
of feb
then we have
31st of
july we have 30th of june
so on and so forth
so these are the list of all the orders
that were placed
on the last day of the month
coming to the 28th question
we want to find the top five countries
with the highest freight charges in the
year 1997.
so freight charge is the amount paid to
a carrier company for the transportation
of goods from origin to another location
the fret charge is calculated based on
the
mode of transportation and the distance
between the pickup place or the pickup
location and the destination
so let's try this out on the
microsoft server management
studio okay so let me go ahead and
give my
comment
so since we want to find the top five
countries with the highest freight
charges
i'll just give my comment as
highest
freight charges
okay
now
to solve this question
i'll just change this to
ghd okay
we are going to use
our
orders table
so the way to do is i'll write select
i'm going to use the
top 5 so top is another
keyword or
an operator
so i am going to find out the
ship country
and then
i'll calculate the average freight
prices so i'm going to use the average
inbuilt function
on top of my
column that is
freight
i'll give an alias as
let's say
average
fret
there should be no space i'll give a
underscore
i'll write from my table that is
orders
i'll use my where clause where
and then i am going to find the year
from my order
date column and this year should be
1997.
i'm going to
group it by
my ship country
and
i'll use
order by
my alias name that was average freight
and in descending order i'm going to
sort it
let's see the top five
shipping countries who have the highest
freight charges these are the results
you have austria switzerland sweden
canada and ireland and here you can see
the average freight prices
sorted in descending order
okay
now moving ahead to the
29th question
so here we want to display the total
number of products in each category so
we have two different tables products
and categories so both these tables we
are going to use to find a solution to
this problem that is
to display the total number of products
in each category
so first let me give my comment to
display the total number of products in
each category i will just write print
total
products
okay
so
to solve this problem we are going to
use our two tables
so let me first display the rows and
columns from both the tables the first
table is products
okay it is products
let's run this and see the columns that
we have in this table
okay so you have the product id which is
the primary key you have the product
name so there are total
77 different products okay
and then you have the supplier id you
have the category id so these two
columns are the foreign key columns you
have the quantity per unit unit price
units in stock
units and order
and if you want to
reorder
some product to fill in the stocks so
you have information for that as well
and if the product has been discontinued
or not
i'll copy this and let's see what
rows and columns we have
in my categories table
okay
let me execute this
okay
so we have total eight categories of
products you can see beverages we have
dairy products
meat or poultry you have produce seafood
these are the description
okay
now to find the total number of products
in each category
i'll write my query as
select
i'll write
category
name
comma
count
star
i'll give this an alias name as total
products
give an underscore and write products
from
my first table that is
products
given alias as p
i am going to use an inner join
with
my categories table
and i'll give my alias as c
on my common key column that is p dot
category id
is equal to c dot
category id
then
i'm going to
group my results
based on the category names
so i'll write category
name
and we'll use the
order by clause i'll write order by
count star
as
descending
so let's see the total number of
products that we have in each category
so this shouldn't be as descending
should be just count star descending
okay
i'll select and run it
there you go
so here on the left hand side you have
the different category names and
on the right you have the
total number of
products that belong to
each of the categories
all right
now moving on to the final question
so the last question is to use the
northwind database
and using this database we want to find
the list of late orders for all the
employees
so this is a real world problem that
often occurs
so the shipment of your orders might get
delayed due to logistic issues or if the
products are not available on time
there can be various other reasons as
well so here we want to find those
orders for the employees
where the required date is less than the
shipment date
we are going to use two different tables
that is
orders and employees
okay now let me give my comment for the
final
query that we are going to write in this
interview questions tutorial
so using the orders table i want to find
the list of orders for all the employees
so i'll just give list
of
late orders
not just orders for employees i write
emp
s which stands for employees
so here i'm going to use two tables
orders and employees
orders table we have already seen let's
see the rows and columns that are
present in the employees table
i'll write select star from employees
and let me run it
okay so there are total nine employees
we have
so we have the employee id this is the
primary key column which goes from one
to nine we have the last name of the
employee the first name of the employee
we have the title
then we have the
title of courtesy by the doctor
mr mrs
we have the birthday of the employee the
higher date or the date of join you have
the address city region postal code and
other information
all right
so let's
see how you can join the orders table
and the employees table to get the
list of late orders and we must remember
that late orders are those
where the required date is less than
equal to the shipped date
so i'll start with select
e dot
i'll write employee id
comma
i want the
first name
comma i'm going to count
star as
late orders
from
my table orders as o
then i'll use my inner join
i'll write
employees
as
e
it doesn't matter actually if you use
small e or capital e
then i'm going to use my on condition on
e dot
on
e dot
employee id
equal to
o dot employee id
so this is my common key column that is
present in both the tables
then i'll use my where clause where
you should be careful
and you should keep the right
clause
so my required date
should be less than or equal to
my
shift date
so this is my condition
and then i'm going to group by
e dot employee id
comma e dot
first name
and then i'll use my order by clause
order by
my alias name that was late orders
and i'll arrange it in descending order
so let's run this and see our result
okay
so
you have the employee ids on the left
then you have the first name of the
employee ids and then you have the late
orders for each of these employees so if
you see here
employee id 4 has the highest number of
late orders followed by employee id
3 and 8
as well as 9 who have 5 late orders then
we have the employee id 2 which has
4 late orders even employee seven has
four lead orders employed five that is
steven has only one late orders
so we are done with our
demo section and we have covered all our
30 questions
out of which 25 questions were based and
used on mysql server
and to address the last five questions
we used our northwind database that had
a lot of tables you can see it here and
using those tables we solved some
interesting questions
i hope it was useful and informative
if you have any queries please feel free
to put them in the comment section of
the video thanks again stay safe and
keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
you